WELCOME TO OUR JOINT HEARING ON
HOMELESSNESS FUNDING AND WITH
SUBCOMMITTEE FOUR ON STATE
ADMINISTRATION THE HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE
TODAY AND ROOM FOR FORTY FOR THE
PANELISTS ON THE AGENDA ARE
APPEARING REMOTELY USING ONLINE
TECHNOLOGY WE ARE ACCEPTING
PUBLIC COMMENT AT THE END OF
THIS HEARING BOTH IN THE HEARING
ROOM AND ON THE PHONE THE PHONE
NUMBER TO CONNECT IS ON THE
COMMITTEE WEBSITE AND SHOULD
ALSO BE ON THE SCREEN IF YOU ARE
WATCHING OVER THE INTERNET. THE
PHONE NUMBER IS TOLL FREE.
877-692-8957 AND THE PUBLIC
ACCESS CODE IS. ONE THREE ONE
FIVE FOUR FOUR FOUR IF YOU
ENCOUNTER ANY PROBLEMS PLEASE
CONTACT THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET
COMMITTEE AT 916-319-2099 AND A
STAFF MEMBER WILL ASSIST YOU WE
ENCOURAGE THE PUBLIC TO PROVIDE
WRITTEN TESTIMONY BEFORE THE
HEARING PLEASE SEND YOUR WRITTEN
TESTIMONY TO BUDGETS UP FOR AT
ASM. DOT C. A. DOT G. O. V. WITH
THAT I WOULD LIKE TO HAND IT
OVER TO MY CO CHAIR ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WICKS FOR ANY OPENING
REMARKS AND TO INTRODUCE THE
FIRST PANEL. THANK YOU CARE
CARILLO. ALSO THE THINKER
STAFFER YOUR OFFICE
PARTICIPATION IN THIS HEARING.
HOMELESSNESS IS A COMPLEX HOLD
ON HOLD ON ONE SECOND I WANNA
MAKE SURE YOU'RE ON. MY MIKE
WORKING. NO IT'S NOT THERE YOU
GO OKAY HI EVERYONE. I WANT TO
THANK CHAIR CARILLO AND HER
STAFF FOR ALL THE WORK THEY PUT
INTO THIS- HEARING TODAY
HOMELESSNESS IS A COMPLEX
PROBLEM AS WE START TO PUT MORE
MONEY TO THE SOLUTIONS WE SEE
MORE NEEDS AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN
SUPPORT OF HOUSING ARE PART OF
THE SOLUTION BUT SO IS TARGETED
PREVENTION AND RENTAL ASSISTANCE
TO KEEP PEOPLE HOUSED. HOUSING
AND IS PART OF THE SOLUTION TO
HOMELESSNESS BUT SOURCE
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES TO ADDRESS
THE HEALTH AND MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES THAT MANY OF THESE FOLKS
FACE ONE THIRD OF PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS HAVE
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES THAT MAKE
IT HARDER FOR THEM TO REMAIN
HOUSE WITHOUT SIGNIFICANT
SUPPORT OF SERVICES. OVER THE
LAST THREE YEARS THE STATE HAS
INVESTED SIGNIFICANT RESOURCES
TO RESPOND TO HOMELESSNESS
INCLUDING TWO BILLION DOLLARS IN
THE HOMELESSNESS HOUSING
ASSISTANCE AND PREVENTION
PROGRAM WHICH WE WILL OFTEN
REFERRED TO AS HAPPIER. LAST
YEAR THE ASSEMBLY PRIORITIZE
MORE ACCOUNTABILITY THE STATE
AND LOCAL LEVEL FOR HOW WE
COORDINATE OUR INVESTMENT IN THE
BUDGET AS A RESULT LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ARE REQUIRED TO
DEVELOP A HOMELESSNESS ACTION
PLAN BASED ON LOCAL DATA TO
DIRECT THEIR HAPPY FUNDING. AND
SET PERFORMANCE GOALS TO EXCESS
ADDITIONAL FUNDING LAST YEAR'S
BUDGET ALSO REQUIRE THE STATE
COMPLETE LANDSCAPE ASSESSMENT TO
DETERMINE HOW WE ARE SPENDING
OUR RESOURCES TO REDUCE
HOMELESSNESS TODAY I HOPE TO
HEAR MORE ABOUT EFFORTS TO
COORDINATE THE STATE AND LOCAL
LEVEL. AND TO ADDRESS
HOMELESSNESS AND I WILL SAY
OFTEN IN THESE POLICY
CONVERSATIONS WE GET IN THE
WEEDS IN THE TECHNICALITIES OF
THE PROBLEM BUT LET'S ALSO
REMEMBER THAT I THINK MANY OF US
HERE BELIEVE THAT SOLVING THIS
PROBLEM IS A MORAL IMPERATIVE AS
WE SEE THE HOMELESS IS GROWING
IN OUR COMMUNITIES AND OUR
STREETS REGARDLESS OF WHAT PARTY
WE COME FROM WE COME HERE.
SEEKING SOLUTIONS. BEFORE YOU IN
THE FIRST PRISON. I WANT TO
CORRECT AN ERROR IN THE
BACKGROUND PAPER REGARDING
PROJECT HOME KEY. A TOTAL OF
SIXTEEN THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED
TWENTY SEVEN ROOMS WERE SECURED
BY ROOM ROOM HE AND SEVENTY
THREE PERCENT. WERE OCCUPIED AT
THE HEIGHT OF THE PROGRAM. AND
FIFTY THOUSAND PEOPLE WERE
HOUSED IN FIFTY FIVE COUNTIES
THROUGH FIVE TRIBAL ENTITIES. SO
THE FIRST PANEL IS NAVIGATING
THE HOMELESSNESS RESPONSE SYSTEM
. JOE BARRETT THE RESIDENT
UNITED NETWORK IS GOING TO BE
OUR FIRST WITNESS- JOE BARRETT
IS AN ADVOCATE AND LEADER IN SAN
DIEGO SHE SERVES ON THE SAN
DIEGO REGIONAL TASK FORCE
CONTINUUM OF CARE ADVISORY
COMMITTEE. SHE WAS ALSO A CO
CHAIR OF THE REGIONAL TASK FORCE
RACIAL EQUITY AD HOC COMMITTEE
FOCUSED ON ADDRESSING THE ISSUES
OF RACIAL DISPARITIES
SPECIFICALLY IN REGARD TO BLACK
SAN DIEGANS EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS SHE IS A MEMBER OF
THE RESIDENT UNITED NETWORK. A
PROJECT OF HOUSING CALIFORNIA.
ARE YOU THERE YES I AM. THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. OKAY THANK YOU
HELLO EVERYONE MY NAME BARRETT
AND I LIVE IN SAN DIEGO I AM
CURRENTLY ORDER DIRECTING THE
SAN DIEGO REGIONAL CRACKS FORCED
ON HOMELESSNESS. CONVENIENT CARE
ADVISORY COMMITTEE AND PRESIDENT
UNITED NETWORK PETER. I'M HERE
TO TODAY TO TALK ABOUT HOW THE
STORY AND GET US OF WHAT HIS
LIFE FOR SUBCOMMITTEE PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA. I DID EXPECT TO BE
NOT. COULD HAPPEN TO ANYONE.
THAT'S WHY IMPORTANT THAT WE
ASIDE AN AVERAGE. TO MAKE SURE
THIS CAN'T JUST BE WHEN THEY. I
WAS MAKING FIGURES WHAT THE
COMPANY FOR TWO YEAR WORK ON THE
MILITARY OF GOVERNMENTS FROM. I
HAD A HOME A SAVINGS LOAN QUE.
AGAIN I'M SADLY MADE UP THE MARK
CRASH INTO THE EIGHT. BOEING MAC
AN OFF DUTY CUTBACKS IN FUNDING
TO THE GUY. ALL THE PROGRAM ARE
KIND FUNDED. WHAT I WOULD TO
FIND POINT THERE WAS MASS AT. P.
APPLYING FOR JOB MY. AFTER
BUILDING I COULDN'T SO I DON'T.
IT UPS DOWN. I'D LIKE THREE
TIMES REMOTE ONE OR MORE. BUT
WITH READING BY THE COMPANY. I
HAVE AN- MY- AB ORLAND PAY JUST
TRYING TO GET A ROOF OVER HEAD
AS LONG AS I COULD. WITH NO
PLACE TO GO I FELT COMPLETELY
LOST. I WAS THAT FEELING
DEFEATED EXCHANGE OUT AND
PROBABLY A WHOLE HOST OF OTHER
EMOTIONS RIGHT MYSELF FOR
STICKING. I THINK THAT MY SHALL
AT TWENTY AFTER A DAY. LEVIN AND
SHALL LOOK VERY TERM. DANGEROUS
AND IMPACT ON MY HOUSE. AND MY
WELL BEING. AS WELL PRIME AND
HELP THAT WAS VERY FOR ME TO THE
DALY. IT GRADE AND IT IT BECAME
. LIKE TIME TO EVEN SHOW. MY
SECTION EIGHT VOUCHER THROUGH
BUT THE WHO WASN'T TO ME FIND IN
A PART COULD FIND IN. THERE WAS
JUST NOTHING THERE. I HAD WHAT
WILL HAVE IN. BUT I BAD CREDIT.
I LIVED IN MY HOME AND AFTER
PAYING THE THIRTY FIVE OR
DOLLARS CHECK HE I WAS TO BE. I
TO HAVE A WITH THE DIRECT OF THE
WILL CENTER A WEEK BEFORE MY YOU
EXPIRED AND SHE FOUND ME IN AN
EFFORT. SINGLE ROOM ARCHITECT
STATE BACK ESTARÁ VERY. AND I TO
GET A OF THERE SO BADLY. BUT
AFTER YOU. I GOT A CALL FROM THE
DIRECT THERE WERE AN OLD. AND
AFFORDABLE THE- AND I'VE BEEN
INTERESTED THERE SINCE TWO FIVE.
IT'S GIVEN ME. MY IN THE BILL
BACK. THERE ARE MORE A HUNDRED
HUNDRED SIXTY BE IN CAL. LAST
YEAR AFTER FROM HOMELESSNESS AND
IT HURTS MY HEART TO SEE THAT
PEOPLE IN THE SITUATION I WAS IN
. I WOULD LIKE TO STATE TO IN.
AND SUPPORT THAT WOULD HELP. AT
EVERY STEP OF MY STORY. TO
PREVENT PEOPLE FROM. FROM LOSING
THEIR HOMES TO MAKE SURE THAT
WHEN I DID LOSE MY HOME I HAD A
PLACE TO GO. BESIDES MY CAR.
DETAILED ENOUGH AFFORDABLE
HOUSING SO THAT PEOPLE CAN GET
INTO A PLACE RIGHT AWAY. NOBODY
HAS TO RELY ON A PERSONAL
CONNECTION AND A LOT AND HOUSING
. WE NEED ENOUGH RESOURCES TO
MAKE SURE THAT NO ONE ESCAPES
THROUGH THE CRACKS. I'M ASKING
YOU TO KEEP MY STORY IN MIND.
AND THE STORIES THAT THOUSANDS
OF PEOPLE ACROSS THE STATE WHO
ARE ON HEALTH. KEEP THEM IT'S
NOT IN MIND AS WELL WHEN YOU
MAKE DECISIONS ABOUT THE STATE
BUDGET THIS YEAR. I THANK YOU
AND I THINK YOU FOR LISTENING MY
STORE. MISTER THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR THAT TEST I THINK OFF. IN
SACRAMENTO OR IN DIFFERENT
SPACES WE GET- WE WORK IN A SILO
WHERE WE THINK OF POLICY AND
FUNDING AND RESOURCES AND THEN
WE VOTE ON IT AND WE LET IT GO
AND ONE OF THE MOST IMPORTANT
THINGS THAT WE CAN DO IS
ACTUALLY. HEAR FROM PEOPLE THAT
HAVE BEEN IMPACTED AND WHOSE
RESOURCES HAVE HELPED IN GETTING
YOU TO A BETTER PLACE AND I
THINK WE ALL SHARE THAT
SENTIMENT THAT YOUR TESTIMONY
TODAY IS SO INCREDIBLY VALUABLE.
IN THE WORK TAT WE DO AND SO
AND WITH THAT I HAVE A COUPLE
QUESTIONS AS I'M SURE MY
COLLEAGUES TO AS WELL. PRIMARILY
HOW CAN WE- IMPROVE AND THE
RESPONSE SYSTEM AND WHAT YOU
EXPERIENCE WHILE YOU WERE
SEEKING ASSISTANCE. WHAT ARE THE
PRETENDING LIKE I SAID- ON THE-
ASSEMBLY CARE HOMES AND THEN. I
HAVE A PLACE TO GO TO BESIDE
THEIR CAR- ENVELOPES AND
AFFORDABLE HOUSING ARCHITECTURES
NOT ENOUGH PEOPLE EVEN WITH THE
LAST COUPLE YEARS WITH THE
OBJECTIONS AND CULTIVATED PEOPLE
LOSING THEIR JOBS IT'S JUST
ANOTHER CYCLE THAT HAPPENED AT
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT. OF WHAT THE
MARKET CRASHED SO HE'S PEOPLE
LEARN DURING THIS CURRENTLY
DURING DURING THIS TIME FRAME
WITH THAT BEING ON HOUSE. SO I
JUST THINK ABILITY NOW FOR HOUSE
WILL. TAKE THE RIGHT IN AND BEEN
- SOME PLACES WITHIN THE GO
IMMEDIATELY WITHOUT EVEN IN
THEIR CAR AND- ANOTHER AREA.
THANK YOU AND WITH THAT WE WANT
TO OPEN IT UP TO OUR COLLEAGUES
AS WELL- MR WARD. THANK YOU
SHARE THEM HI JOE IT'S CHRIS
WARD IT'S REALLY GOOD TO SEE YOU
EVEN THOUGH WE'RE ABOUT FIVE
HUNDRED MILES AWAY WE SERVED
TOGETHER ON THE REGIONAL TASK
FORCE ON THE HOMELESS AND IT'S
ALWAYS REALLY GREAT. TIME TO
HAVE AN ADVOCATE LIKE CHAU
LEADING ON THE EFFORT- FROM DOWN
IN SAN DIEGO JOE I WONDER IF YOU
COULD EXPAND A LITTLE BIT ON
SOME OF THE LEADERSHIP THAT
YOU'VE BEEN PROVIDING LOCALLY TO
REALLY TRY TO TEASE OUT. SOME OF
OUR APPROACH IS TO DEAL WITH
BLACK HOMELESSNESS AND YOU KNOW
SOME OF THE EXISTING ON
CHALLENGES THAT WE HAVE IN
FUNDING. AND I'M POSSIBLY IN
POLICY AS WELL- TO CORRECT SOME
OF THE RISKS DISPARITIES AND YOU
KNOW TRY TO TRY TO REACH
POPULATIONS OF WOMEN LEFT BEHIND
. YES THAT'S TRUE- RIGHT NOW
THAT THERE'S POLICY THAT THE
HEIGHTENED HIGHER LEVEL. THAT
THERE IS A PLACE THAT DOESN'T
ALLOW CERTAIN PEOPLE. LIKE THAT
THE SPARE CARE ACT PEOPLE OR
PEOPLE OF COLOR. TWO IF THEY
HAVE CRIMINAL RECORDS OR IF THEY
HAVE LIKE. TODAY BACKGROUND IT
MIGHT BE THE MY HOME. BUT BUILT
BARRIERS THAT ARE KEEPING P.
FROM HELP AND MOST OF THE TIME
THOSE PEOPLE ARE HAVE CRIMINAL
BACKGROUNDS ARE PEOPLE OF COLOR
AND NOT A LOT IN ALL CASES BUT-
BUILDABLE. SOME OF THE- NOW
THERE ARE. AT KEEPING PEOPLE
FROM HOUSE. AT SCHOOL ITEM THAT
I KNOW. THE THING YOU JOE
EXACTLY WE TO WORK ON THE THINK
ALL THESE POLICY CONSTRAINTS AS
WELL TO MAKE SURE THERE ARE NO
BARRIERS- AND- AND HELP TO- YOU
KNOW REACH A LITTLE BIT DEEPER
FOR- YOU KNOW THAT COMMUNITIES
THAT HAVE BEEN LEFT BEHIND. OVER
THE DECADES. THANK YOU'RE
WELCOME. MISS FONG. I JUST HAVE
A QUICK QUESTION AND BUT AND I'M
SURE IT'S MORE LIKE THE ANSWER
BUT ARE THERE PROGRAMS THAT
YOU'RE SEEING NOW THAT- ARE
EFFECTIVE AND ARE THERE OTHER
PROGRAMS THAT- USE YOU SEE ARE
BEING CHALLENGED WITH WITH
VARIOUS REASONS THAT NEED
IMPROVEMENT. I'M PERFECT
PRESSURE AT TWO MAIN. WELL I
DON'T KNOW THERE'S A LOT OF
RESOURCES OUT THERE BUT- I JUST
RIGHT NOW I JUST DON'T SEE IT
BEING EFFECTIVE IN HELPING. A
LOT OF PEOPLE IN THERE STILL BE
SOME MANY PEOPLE OUT THERE THAT
ARE. AND THAT'S HELPED THAT
TELLS THE STORY RIGHT THERE. THE
OVER A HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
PEOPLE THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA AND
IF IT WAS EFFECTIVE A LOT OF-
THOSE PEOPLE HAVE BEEN HOUSE BY
NOW- I GUESS MAYBE WOULD MAKE IT
EVEN MORE. OKAY WHAT'S INTERVIEW
. YEAH IT IT'S JUST THAT I KNOW
WHEN WE WERE SANTEE THERE WASN'T
SEVEN HUNDRED PEOPLE THAT WE HAD
IN HOUSE- DURING THE CALL THE
PORTION AND NOW IT SAYS DOUBLE
BECAUSE OF COLOR WITHIN PEOPLE
LOSING THEIR JOBS IN THEIR HOMES
BEING INFECTED SO- IF IT WAS
EFFECTIVE A LOT OF THESE PEOPLE
WOULD BE. IN HOMES RIGHT NOW. I
WOULD SAY THAT- CERTAINLY THE
HOMELESSNESS PREVENTION SPACE WE
- I THINK THERE NEEDS TO BE MORE
ATTENTION TO THAT I THINK THAT'S
KIND OF WHAT YOU'RE HIGHLIGHTING
THAT THERE A LOT OF PEOPLE AT
RISK OF BEING HOMELESS. THAT WE
PROBABLY- THAT WE NEED TO
PROVIDE- SOME SUPPORT FOR A IN
SAN DIEGO I WOULD AS I JUST MADE
A GIVE ME BY THE QUESTION WOULD
HAVE BEEN BETTER **** ARE THERE
PROGRAMS IN SAN DIEGO THAT YOU
FEEL ARE. PERFECT THERE ARE
DOING A GOOD JOB THAT YOU CAN
HIGHLIGHT. FOR US. NOT AT THE
TIME I KNOW THAT IT'S A STRUGGLE
JUST FOUGHT JUST TRYING TO FIND
AFFORDABLE HOUSING- EVEN IF YOU
DO HAVE A VOUCHER A LOT OF
PEOPLE ARE LOSING THEIR VOUCHERS
SO. THE FLAG NOT WORKING TO GET
PEOPLE HOUSE TANK I THINK WE CAN
DO BETTER. THANK YOU FOR THAT
PERSPECTIVE I APPRECIATE. THERE
ARE NO ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS FROM
MEMBERS OF THE DYESS I JUST WHAT
REALLY QUICKLY- IS BURIED YOU
MENTIONED- EVICTIONS IN THE WORK
THAT YOU DO WHAT IS THE
PERCENTAGE OF OUR OWN HOUSE
RESIDENTS THAT HAVE AN EVICTION
NOTIFICATION THAT DOESN'T ALLOW
FOR THEM TO BE ABLE TO MOVE
FORWARD WITH HOUSING. IT IS
BASED ON THE BALLOT WELL. MY
EXPERIENCE WITH MY FORECLOSURE
AND I KNOW THAT THERE'S PEOPLE
THAT ESPECIALLY WITH AFFORDABLE
HOUSING IS JUST THAT ABSOLUTELY
REJECTION IF YOU HAVE AN
ADDICTION ON YOUR RECORD.
BUILDER ANOTHER VERY. AND ALSO
FOR CULTURE WITH NO FAULT OF
THEIR OWN. BEING AT THE CURRENT
TIME. NO FAULT OF THEIR OWN AND
BAKED IT- LIKE MY FORECLOSURE
WITH AN UNLOCKED UNLAWFUL FOR
POSTED BACK IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHT BUT THEY IMPOSSIBLE POLL
TO GET. GET ME OUT OF THE HOUSE
- I DON'T KNOW BUT IT DOES HAVE
DARIUS CURRENT THERE WE NEED TO
ADDRESS. THANK YOU VERY I THINK
WAS YOU'VE- US OF THE THINGS
WE'VE BEEN THINKING ABOUT AS
WELL ESPECIALLY WITH. A COLD
EVICTIONS AND FORECLOSURES
RELATED TO THE PANDEMIC- AMID
SOME OF THE- THE DIFFERENT
PLACES ACROSS THE STATE IN WHICH
THE EVICTION MORATORIUM WAS NOT
SET IN PLACE JUST YET AND SO.
SOMETHING FOR US TO DEFINITELY
THINK ABOUT. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
IF THERE ARE NO ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS- IS VERY
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY TODAY. AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CREATING SOME REALLY
GREAT POLICY BASED ON WHAT
YOU'VE SHARED THANK YOU. THANK
YOU BYE BYE. WE ARE GOING TO
MOVE ON TO OUR PANEL NUMBER TO
OUR PANELISTS TODAY- FOR FUNDING
I FUNDING OVERVIEW. INCLUDE SAID
LOU THIS MODUS WITH THE- FISCAL
AND UP AND THE L. A. O. MS
MONETARY THERE. GOOD AFTERNOON
AND MY LIST WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE I'M- NOT AYE WE
SPEAKING FROM I DON'T SEE MY
SHARE OPTION BEING ACTIVE QUITE
YET. CAN WE PLEASE ACTIVATE HER
SHARE SCREEN. THANK YOU ONE
MOMENT. IT'S GONNA. YES WE CAN
SEE YOUR SCREEN. THANK YOU
STARTED. I'M COMMITTED TO
PROVIDE AN OVERVIEW OF THE MAJOR
STATE SPENDING ACTIONS IN RECENT
YEARS RELATED TO HOMELESSNESS
THE HAND I'LL BE SPEAKING FROM
IS AVAILABLE ON OUR WEBSITE.
SOME OF THE FOREVER BY THE
FUNDING OVER BILL PROVIDE A
LITTLE BIT OF CONTEXT FOR THE
SIGNIFICANCE OF MEDITATION WE'VE
SEEN IN THE STATE WHICH I'LL
DESCRIBE NEXT. WELL WE KNOW
HOMELESSNESS IS A COMPLEX
PROBLEM WITH MANY CRISIS THE
HIGH COST OF HOUSING IS A
SIGNIFICANT FACTOR IN THE STATE
OF THIS CRISIS. TWO POINT FIVE
MILLION HOUSEHOLDS IN THE STATE
ARE COST BURDENED MEANING THEY
SPENT MORE THAN 30% OF THEIR
INCOME ON HOUSING. THESE LISTING
HOUSE. THAT ARE SPENDING A
SIGNIFICANT PORTION OF THEIR
INCOME ON HOUSING. JOB LOSS
AREN'T EXPECTED EXPENSE COULD
RESULT IN HOUSING INSTABILITY
AND HOMELESSNESS. IN JANUARY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE THE MOST
RECENT YEAR WE HAVE COMPLETE
FEDERAL DATA. CALIFORNIA HAVE
WHERE PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS THAN ANY OTHER
STATE WITH ONE HUNDRED AND SIXTY
ONE. THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED
INDIVIDUALS EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS. WE RECENTLY
LEARNED THROUGH- ADDITIONAL
FEDERAL DATA. THAT ABOUT FIFTY
ONE THOUSAND PEOPLE EXPERIENCED
HOMELESSNESS IN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE WITHIN SHELTERS. DUE TO
FACTORS RELATED TO THE PANDEMIC
WE DON'T HAVE THE NUMBERS.
RELATED TO UNSHELTERED
HOMELESSNESS. SO IF THE HOME
DISCUSS HAS BECOME SORT OF MORE
ACUTE IN RECENT THE STATE HAS
TAKEN LARGER INFO AND- LAW
GOVERNMENT OCCURRED. TO ADDRESS
HOMELESS. OVERALL THE STATE HAS
INCREASED ITS ROLE IN ADDRESSING
HOMELESSNESS BY PROVIDING
SIGNIFICANT ALTHOUGH ONE TIME
TEMPORARY FUNDING TOWARDS
INFRASTRUCTURE AND FLEXIBLE AID
TO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS. SO ON THE
NEXT HE GAVE ME COMBINED EIGHTY
PEOPLE THAT SUMMARIZES THE MAJOR
BECAUSE OF MEDICATIONS. AND WE
PROVIDE A BRIEF SUMMARY OF THE
PROGRAM'S REFLECTED ON THE
TABLE. THANK YOU SEE IT'S REALLY
INTO THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN SCHOOL YEAR WHEN THE
STATE BEGAN TO TAKE A MORE
ACTIVE FISCAL ROLE IN ADDRESSING
HOMELESSNESS. VOTERS APPROVED NO
PLACE LIKE HOME INITIATIVE WHICH
PROVIDES PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING TO PEOPLE WITH MENTAL
ILLNESS WHO ARE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS OR AT RISK OF
HOMELESSNESS. IN THE THING
FISCAL YEAR THE BUDGET PROVIDED
FLEXIBLE EMERGENCY AID TO THE
LARGEST CITIES AND CONSUMES A
CARE IN THE STATE. THROUGH HEAT
THE HOMELESS EMERGENCY PROGRAM.
THE TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY
BUDGET CONTINUE TO RECOGNIZE THE
NEED FOR LOCAL FLEXIBLE EIGHT
THROUGH THE ESTABLISHMENT. OF
THE HOUSE. IN CONTRAST TO HEAT-
FROM THE PREVIOUS YEAR HALF WITH
LESS FOCUSED ON SHORT TERM
SOLUTIONS AND WANTED TO
ENCOURAGE MORE REGIONAL
COLLABORATION TO ADDRESS
HOMELESSNESS. HOWEVER IN MARCH
OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE THE STATE
EXPANDED ITS SUPPORT AND
APPROACH TOWARDS HOMELESSNESS
FOLLOWING THE EMERGENCE OF THE
COVENANTING CONDEMNING. WE SEE
PROJECT WILL KEEP AGAIN IN THAT
YEAR WHICH SHALL HELP LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ACQUIRE HOTELS AND
MOTELS TO PROVIDE FOR IMMEDIATE
HOUSING NEEDS OF PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS AS A
WAY TO HELP INTERNATIONAL TRUCK
AND REDUCE THE SPREAD OF. THE
NINETEEN WITHIN THE COMMUNITY.
FULL FUNDING HAS CONTINUED FOR
HOME KEY OVER THE LAST FEW YEARS
THIS WAS INTENDED TO BE A
TEMPORARY PROGRAM AND SO TO THAT
END TO THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO BUDGET. PROVIDED A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS TO ROOM KEY TO HELP
TRANSITION PARTICIPANTS INTO
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING. AT
THE SAME TIME TO THE BUILDING
OFF OF THE FACT THAT THE PROJECT
ROOM KEY THE TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE BUDGET ESTABLISHED.
THE HOME KEY PROGRAM. SIMILARLY
TO REPEAT THIS PROGRAM ALLOWED
ACQUISITION OF HOTELS AND MOTELS
AS WELL AS OTHER PROPERTIES IN
THIS CASE IT WAS TO ALLOW THE
HEALTHY TO USE FOR PERMANENT
HOUSING FOR PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS OR AT RISK OF
HOMELESSNESS. AND FUNDING FOR
WHOM HE HAS CONTINUED INCLUDE
SUBSEQUENT YEARS. CONCURRENT BUT
ACTIONS. RELATED TO ADDRESSING.
THE PANDEMIC THE C. HAVE
CONTINUE TO PROVIDE FLEXIBLE AID
TO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND-
PARTICULARLY THE LARGEST CITIES
COUNTIES AND CONTINUES TO CARE.
TO HAPPEN. FOR TURNING THE
PROGRAM RULES FOR HALF OF THE
VAULT AND MOST RECENTLY AS WELL
OUTLINED IN THE AGENDA. THE
LEGISLATURE HAS ESTABLISHED
STATUTE THAT REQUIRES LOCAL
ACTION PLANS THAT WILL HELP WITH
ACCOUNTABILITY AND WITH THE
LEGISLATURE PROVIDING OVERSIGHT. OF THAT PROGRAM OVER TIME. CAN
FINALLY THE TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO PROVIDED FUNDING TO LOCAL
ENTITIES TO ADDRESS SUPPORT
ENCAMPMENTS WITHIN THEIR
JURISDICTIONS AND SO OVERALL YOU
SEE THAT THE STATE HAS
SIGNIFICANTLY EXPANDED ITS
FISCAL ROLL OVER THE YEARS. AND
IT'S FROM PRIMARILY THROUGH SORT
OF A ONE TIME OR TEMPORARY
FUNDING THAT SUPPORTS
INFRASTRUCTURE AND FLEXIBILITY
TO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS. AND THE
SECOND TABLE TO MORE
DESCRIPTIONS OF THE PROGRAMS- I
JUST DESCRIBED AND THE FINAL TWO
PEOPLE IN MY COMMENTS TODAY.
JUST REALLY HIGHLIGHTS THE REST
OF THE ACTIONS RELATED TO
HOMELESSNESS ACROSS THE STATE WE
HIGHLIGHT. OTHER PROPOSALS
ACROSS THE NUMBER OF DEPARTMENTS
THAT HAVE SOME RULED IN
ADDRESSING HOMELESSNESS AND IT
REALLY GIVES YOU A MORE COMPLETE
PICTURE OF TOTAL SPENDING AT
LEAST IN TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO.
AND A PICTURE OF THE NUMBER OF
DEPARTMENTS REALLY INVOLVED IN
ADDRESSING THIS COMPLEX ISSUE.
INTO THAT COMPLETES MY PREPARED
COMMENTS REPORT OVERVIEW OF
FISCAL MATTERS I'M HAPPY TO TAKE
ANY QUESTIONS WHEN APPROPRIATE.
THANK YOU RESTAURANTS STAR UP
WITH A QUESTIONS AND ON TO THE
PANEL. HOW CAN THE STATE ENSURE
THAT THE FUNDING WE ARE
CURRENTLY INVESTING IN THESE
VARIOUS STATE PROGRAMS ARE
COMPLIMENTING EACH OTHER. AND
NOT DUPLICATING EFFORTS. I HAVE
TO QUESTION IT IS YOU KNOW ONE
THAT'S OUR CENTRAL IN OUR MIND
IT REALLY DOES TAKE DISCUSSIONS
LIKE TODAY WHERE WE SEE SORT OF.
CRIME PEOPLE ON THE GROUNDS ARE
DELIVERING SERVICES AND
RECIPIENTS OF THE SERVICES JUST
SOUTH OF WHERE THE SUCCESSES AND
pCAN THE STATE CAN CONTINUE TO OF
ALL ITS RESPONSE- WE YOU KNOW WE
HAVE AN ELECTRIC CHALLENGES
WITH. HAVING TO CLEAR PLAN IN
THE PAST AND HAVING STRONG
OVERSIGHT. WE DO NOTING THAT THE
STATE IS NO LONGER IN THE SAME
PLACE THAT WAS IN IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN WHEN IT
STARTED TO TAKE A MORE ACTIVE
ROLE- THERE HAS BEEN PROGRESS IN
THE STATE'S INFRASTRUCTURE IN IN
AND DEVELOPING A PORTFOLIO OF
PROGRAMS IT'S A REALLY
AFFECTING. WHERE THE SUCCESSES
WHERE THE CHALLENGES AND HOW TO
MORE CLEARLY. IN INVEST IN. THE
SUCCESSFUL WILL BE IMPORTANT
FORWARD. IN LINE WITH THAT.
MAKING SURE. THE STATE IS A
COUPLE AND HOW IT THE BALLOT.
THE FIFTY LOCAL RELIEF. MOVING
FORWARD IN ASSESSING WHERE'S THE
RIGHT BALANCE OF. LEVERAGE STILL
LOCAL X. BUT THE STATE ALSO HAS
A IN FOR. AND BEST PRACTICE ARE
BEING. AND PACKED UP LOCAL THE
LOCAL LEVEL WILL BE IMPORTANT.
THANK YOU MISS BROWN IS AMONG
THE PASS IT OVER TO OUR VICE
CHAIR PARCO CHERISH AND
MISTAKES. I'M HAPPY TO BE YOUR
VICE CHAIR CARILLO- GET YOU LAID
OUT- FOR ELOQUENTLY HERE THE
DIFFERENT PROGRAMS THAT EXIST TO
SUPPORT OUR HOMELESS POPULATION.
AND YOUR ESTIMATION WHAT DO YOU
SEE IS THE MOST EFFECTIVE
PROGRAMS THAT MOST IMMEDIATELY
GETTING PEOPLE OFF THE STREETS
AND INTO SOME FORM OF HOUSING.
NO THAT'S A DIFFICULT QUESTION
TO ANSWER ADMINISTERED OF THE
ELITE WITH A LITTLE BIT WE THINK
SIGNIFICANT EVOLUTIONS IN THE-
DATA REQUIRED FROM HAPPENANYTHING WILL BE HELPFUL MOVING
FORWARD IN ADDRESSING THAT TYPE
OF QUESTION. BUT TO DATE THERE
IS QUITE LIMITED DATA- WE HAD
THERE'S AN ANNUAL REPORT THAT
CAPTURES- KEEP FUNDING ON THE
FIRST YEAR OF HAPPENING YOU HAVE
SOARED INITIAL UNDERSTANDING OF
HOW THAT FUNDING IS- BEING.
ENCUMBERED AND ACTUALLY YOU KNOW
STANFORD- EXITS ASSOCIATED WITH
THAT SO WHAT ARE THE OUTCOMES OF
PEOPLE BEING SERVED BY THAT
PROGRAM IT'S STILL. VERY EARLY
STAGES- AND THEN YOU DON'T
ANSWER GOOD ANSWERS AT THIS TIME
FOR THEM. BUT WE DO THINK THAT
THE ACTIONS THE LEGISLATURE HAS
TAKEN MORE SONORA RECENTLY
RELATED TO HAVE WILL HELP
ADDRESS THE QUESTIONS OVER THE
LONG TERM. AND DO YOU THINK
THERE'S A ROLE FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO- EITHER
LEGISLATIVELY OR THROUGH OTHER
MECHANISMS PUSH FORMER DAD OR
SOME SOME SORT OF POLICY
SOLUTION ON THE DATA QUESTION TO
ENSURE THAT WERE ACTUALLY-
ANALYZING THESE PROGRAMS MOST
EFFECTIVELY. ABSOLUTELY THAT
SORT OF- IN PRIOR PRIOR YEAR AND
SORT OF CONTINUE TO THAT THAT'S
TRUE THAT'S- TO LET. AND ANY
ACTIONS AT ALL TO TAKE THIS YEAR
SHOULD HAVE TO DESTROY OVERSIGHT
ENSURE THAT THERE ARE. NEW
MEASURE- OUT. THAT ARE OF TRACK
TO DOUBLE. LOCAL AND ITSELF
ACCOUNTABLE TO ENSURE THERE'S
PROPER IN THIS. THANK YOU. GOING
TO PASS IT ON TO MISS COOPER
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR. WHAT'S
THE AMOUNT OF FUN FOR TO COMBAT
HOMELESS SINCE. TWENTY EIGHTEEN.
YES THE TABLE HAVE ON PAGE TWO
OF THE HAND. HOW ABOUT NINE
POINT FOUR BILLION DOLLARS
TOTAL. AND FIFTY WOULD SQUEEZE
IF THE IF THE MAJOR INVESTMENT
IN HOMELESSNESS IS I SORT OF
MENTIONED IN MY FINAL TO PREPARE
COMMENTS. THERE IS A LOT OF
FUNDING SPREAD ACROSS A NUMBER
OF OTHER DEPARTMENTS THAT HAVE
SOME ROLE IN ADDRESSING
HOMELESSNESS. IT'S BEEN A FINAL
PICTURE OF OUR OF OUR HAND OUT
WE HAVE AN ADDITIONAL FOUR POINT
SIX. JUST A TWENTY ONE TWO.
HUNDRED TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO-
ACROSS THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES HEALTH CARE SERVICES
THE DEPARTMENT VETERANS AFFAIRS
AND SO THAT IS. PART OF THE
CHALLENGING DYNAMIC IN REALLY IS
SUFFERING THROUGH WHERE THE
THICKNESS OF THE WHERE THE
CHALLENGES RELATED TO THE
STATE'S RESPONSE IT IS A VERY
CONFUSED- SET UP ACTIONS ARE
BEING TAKEN SO. COORDINATION AND
REALLY FAST I'M NOT REALLY SURE
WHERE ALL THE DOLLARS WHICH IS A
DIFFICULT TASK TO UP TO. REALLY
FAST BUT ALSO HOW. THEY'RE BEING
USED. OKAY THANK YOU. SWARD
GREAT THANK YOU I'M THINKING FOR
THE REPORT TODAY ON TO BUILD ON
WELL- I AM A THAT WE'RE STILL
MODERNIZING I THINK WHAT IS THE
HOMELESS DATA INFORMATION
SYSTEM- SO HOPEFULLY WE'LL HAVE
SOME COMMON METRICS THAT
EVERYBODY IS REPORTING INTO IS
THAT WE CAN ANALYZE THESE AND MY
QUESTION FOR YOU IS THE L. EO IS
I'M HOPING THAT YOU KNOW WITH
THIS- IT'S GREAT TO SEE A LOOK
BACK ON HOW MUCH WE'RE INVESTING
OBVIOUSLY ALIGNS WITH OUR
CRITICAL PRIORITIES FOR
CALIFORNIA THEY WANT TO KNOW
THAT WE'RE MAKING THE
INVESTMENTS BUT THEY ALSO WANT
TO KNOW WHAT THE OUTCOMES ARE.
AND SO I'M WONDERING FOR THE L.
IT WAS OFFICE GOING FORWARD FOR
MANY OF THESE SPENDING ACTIONS
THAT ARE HERE YOU KNOW HOW MANY
FAMILIES WERE ANSWERED BY THE
FAMILY HOMELESS CHALLENGE GRANT-
HOW MANY BEDS WERE EXPANDED
UNDER THE ACUTE BED CAPACITY
EXPANSION SO FOR EACH OF THESE
PROGRAMS- MAYBE AND IN
SUBSEQUENT REPORTS GOING FORWARD
IN FUTURE YEARS AND I WILL ASK
THIS IN MY TIME IN THE
LEGISLATURE BECAUSE I DO I DO
WANT TO SEE ALL THE DOTS CONNECT
- HOW ARE WHAT IS THE IMPACT
WHAT IS THE EFFECT AND THAT'S
WHERE THE OUTCOMES. OF SO MANY
OF THESE PROGRAMS BECAUSE WE'RE
GOING TO CONTINUE TO PRIORITIZE
AND MAKE THESE INVESTMENTS OVER
TIME BUT WE HAVE TO TAKE BACK
HOME IN SHORT CONSTITUENTS THAT
WE ARE MONITORING AND EVALUATING
AND RE DIRECTING A PUBLIC RECORD
REVENUES. TOWARDS THE MOST
EFFECTIVE PROGRAMS. SO MY
QUESTION IS COULD ELLY ELLS
OFFICE TENTATIVELY COMMIT. TO
POSSIBLY EXPAND SOME OF YOUR
ANALYSIS IN FUTURE REPORTS TO
REALLY GET INTO THE OUTCOMES.
NOT JUST THE DOLLARS SPENT BUT
THE OTCOMES. AND I'D ALSO LIKE
TO KNOW IF YOU'RE NOT ABLE TO-
MEASURE THOSE OUTCOMES BECAUSE-
YOU JUST DON'T HAVE THE
SUFFICIENT DATA FROM FROM THE
DEPARTMENTS. THAT'S RIGHT TO OUR
ABILITY TO PROVIDE AN OUTCOME
THAT IS LIMITED BY SAID WHAT THE
ADMINISTRATION COLLECTS THE IN
THEIR PROGRAMS AND SO WE'RE
HAPPY TO SORT OF WORK WITH THE
LEGISLATURE. THROUGHOUT THIS
BUDGET CYCLE TO HELP INFORM WHAT
I'M DATA REQUEST MAY BE
ASSOCIATED WITH ANY ACTIONS OF
LEGISLATURE ULTIMATELY TAKES TO
FILL. THAT MOVING FORWARD- BUT
WE ALWAYS SORT OF ENGAGING ON
PLANS PROPOSALS WITH AN EYE
TOWARD. WHAT IS AVAILABLE AND
WHAT IS THE LEGISLATURE SORT OF
SEEN AS A RESULT OF ITS- MAJOR.
CHANNELS THANK YOU M. AND
THERE'S A NOTE THE NEXT PANEL IS
A DEPARTMENT WE CAN ACTUALLY-
MAKES MORE QUESTIONS. FROM DATA
INFORMATION AS WELL. YES WE'RE
GETTING THERE AND MISTER LUCKY.
I WASN'T SURE IF IT WAS MR
LANCASTER FARGO MISTER LACKING.
THANK YOU. HOW MUCH OF THE
AMOUNT RESHOOT IT- HERE'S HERE'S
ONE OF MY BIGGEST. WHAT WE START
TALKING ABOUT HOMELESSNESS IS
THERE'S SUCH A HEAVILY OF SUCH A
HEAVY FOCUS ON HOUSING ONLY
WHEN. THINGS HIT A CRISIS POINT
WITH WITH THE HOMELESS. OUR
INTERVENTION SYSTEM RIGHT NOW IS
LAW ENFORCEMENT. AND I'M TELLING
YOU BEING FROM THAT PROFESSION.
IT'S VERY INEFFECTIVE AND IT IS
THE WORST PROBABLY SET OF
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT WE HAVE.
EVOLVED INTO BECAUSE IT SEEMS TO
ME THAT ONE OF OUR BIGGEST
CHALLENGES IS TO ADDRESS. THE
DRIVING FORCES THAT LEAD TO
HOMELESSNESS AND I DON'T KNOW
WHAT THE PERCENTAGES ARE. BUT
IT'S GOT TO BE VERY HIGH
PERCENTAGE OF THOSE WHO SUFFER
FROM MENTAL ILLNESS OR SOME TYPE
OF ADDICTION. UNTIL WE FOCUS ON
SERVICES AVAILABLE FOR. THESE
KINDS OF DIFFICULTIES WE'RE
GOING TO CONTINUE TO SEE THIS
GROWING POPULATION IN MY
OPINION- AND SO. IF YOU COULD
JUST HELP ME SEE THAT WERE
ACTUALLY FOCUSING ON. SERVICES
FOR MENTAL ILLNESS AND
ADDICTIONS. AS WE DISCOVER
THESE. PEOPLE AND IN THESE
CONDITIONS I'LL BE A LOT MORE
CONFIDENT AND- THE REMEDIES
THAT- OR BEING. SPENT THE THAT
THE DOLLARS ARE BEING SPENT SO
HEAVILY TOWARDS. SO I GUESS MY
ONLY QUESTION IS ARE WE
ADDRESSING THE SERVICES ASPECT
OF THESE HOMELESSNESS PEOPLE.
SOME PROGRAM- WHICH IS TO COME
BACK TO IT A NUMBER OF TIMES IS
A VERY FLEXIBLE SOURCE OF
REVENUE FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
THE SERVICES AND CERTAINLY
INELIGIBLE USE- TO THIS IS
WITHIN THE BROAD HOMELESSNESS
SPACE I WOULD SAY THAT THERE'S
ALSO SORT OF MORE TARGETED
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES AVAILABLE
DESERVED AND- OUTSIDE MY DIRECT
PORTFOLIO. BUT I AM AWARE OF THE
BEHAVIOR HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE-
PROPOSAL THAT WAS ALLOCATED AS
PART OF A TRIPLE LAST YEAR THAT
ALLOCATED BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
TOWARDS PROVIDING INFRASTRUCTURE
OVER THE LONG TERM AND SERVICES
ASSOCIATED WITH THAT TO ADDRESS
THE NEEDS OF PEOPLE WITH SEVERE
BEHAVIOR HEALTH CONDITIONS. AND
OUR RESOURCES IN OTHER AREAS OF
THE BUDGET AND COMES BACK TO THE
ISSUES WE'VE BEEN DISCUSSING
WHICH IS HOW WE SHOULD
COORDINATE INTEGRATE ALL OF THE
STATE ACTIONS THAT SORT SERVE TO
HAVE A ROLE IN ADDRESSING- THIS
OF THE MANY REASONS WHY SOMEONE. MAY BE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS. A MY LAST COLUMN
HAS TO DO IF IT'S OKAY WITH THE
CHAIR IS. PREVENT NEEDS TO BE OF
OUR- OUR REMEDY- SET OF
CIRCUMSTANCES AND I FEEL LIKE.
IT'S UNDER EMPHASIZED. THE END
OF IT THE SERVICE COMPONENT OF.
MENTAL HEALTH. AT AT LARGE I
MEAN WE UNTIL WE REALLY FIGURE
THIS OUT BECAUSE I THINK WE
HAVE. SUCH A LARGE SEGMENT OF
OUR POPULATION THAT DEALS WITH
THIS CHALLENGE IN THEIR LIFE-
WE'RE GONNA BE MISSING THE VOTE
AND I REALLY FEEL LIKE THIS
FOCUS ON. ON ON THE MENTAL
HEALTH AND ADDICTIONS. IS A
REALLY REALLY POWERFUL PIECE OF
THE SOLUTION. COMMENT THANK YOU
MISTER TWISTER FONG. I THANK YOU
CHECK RIO- I WANTED TO BUILD OFF
OF A QUESTION THAT- I CALLED
FROM SAN DIEGO ASKED ON THE LAST
PAGE OF YOUR- YOUR- REPORT- IT
INDICATES THAT THERE WAS FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS IN THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO- BUDGET-
FOR UP THE HOMELESS THAT DATA
INTEGRATION SYSTEM AS THERE HAVE
HAVE YOU DONE ANY ANALYSIS IN
TERMS OF. WHAT THE CURRENT
STATUS OF IT IS IT BEING
EFFECTIVE IS IT IS THERE A
COORDINATION IS THE DAY THAT
THERE. GOOD OR BAD. SO THE
HOMELESS SEVEN INTEGRATION
SYSTEM IS AVAILABLE ONLINE
TODAY- FOCUS YOUR ACCESS THAT
THROUGH THE COUNCIL'S WEBSITE-
AT THIS POINT OF THE INFORMATION
AVAILABLE IS STILL IT'S STILL
QUITE LIMITED IT'S MOSTLY SORT
OF AN INVENTORY AS FAR AS WE
SORT OF UNDERSTAND OF SERVICES
ARE DELIVERED ACROSS THE STATE
AND WHERE THE SERVICES WERE
DELIVERED WHETHER IT WAS NO LESS
S. C. O. C. LOS ANGELES OR NO
OKAY ARE YOU COUNTY AND SOME
DEMOGRAPHIC INFORMATION ABOUT
THE PEOPLE SERVED. OUR
UNDERSTANDING WITH BEGINNING
WITH THE RESTORATION MUCH
INTEREST AND I WELCOME YOU TO
ASK THEM MORE ABOUT AS THEY
SPEAK IN THE NEXT IS AT THE
CEMEX EXPECT X. PRODUCTION ME
THAT SYSTEM OVER TIME THERE IS
MORE INFORMATION THAT COULD BE
USEFUL IF THE LEGISLATURE MAKE
SORT OF POLICY AND FUNDING
DECISIONS BUT IT SEEMS LIKE THAT
IS- YOU KNOW WELL SORT OF
CONTROVERSY OVER TIME SHARE. IT
IN AND I GUESS THAT THAT LEADS
TO THIS THAT THE SECOND QUESTION
I HAVE WHICH IS THE U. EMPHASIZE
COORDINATION AND CERTAINLY
WOULDN'T WE NEED THE DATA- TO
FACILITATE THAT BUT IT FROM YOUR
PERSPECTIVE EVALUATING THIS
LAUNDRY LIST OF- PROGRAMS ME HOW
WOULD YOU GRADE THE INTERACTION
AND COORDINATION. RIGHT NOW
THAT'S CURRENTLY HAPPENING. I
THE- COUNCIL IS REALLY ADEPT.
POINT THERE IS WE- JUST. THAT
NOT ONLY READ THE COUNCIL-
COUNCIL HOME BUT I'LL SORT OF
REGIS- IT- IT'S- TO ALLOW FOR
THEIR TO BE A- CHAIR. WITH
HOUSING AND HUMAN EACH AS WELL
AS A LITTLE SOME OF THE OTHER
PARTICIPANTS. FROM JUST
REPRESENT OF THE DEPARTMENTS
THAT ACTUALLY SORT OF THE HASN'T
DIRECTORS OF DEPARTMENTS. AND
HOW THAT'LL WORK IN PRACTICE AND
ENCOURAGING GREATER COORDINATION
IS YET TO BE SEEN. BUT THEY'RE
CERTAINLY NOT A FACTOR- IS A
RECOGNITION AND EFFORT TO MAKE.
HEADWAY THERE. SO WE I'M- A IT'S
KIND OF AN INCOME AT THE MOMENT
THAT EVERYTHING IS STILL BEING
FLESHED OUT. YEAH YEAH I THINK
THIS IS A VERY COMPLEX PROBLEM
AND THEY'RE SORT OF BUSINESS-
ADDRESS SOME ASPECTS OF THE
STATE RESPONSE BUT CERTAINLY
GIVEN THE COMPLEXITY- MORE
RESOURCES AND TIME I'M AN EFFORT
WILL SORT OF BE REALLY NECESSARY
TO ADDRESS. THE COMPLEX
CHALLENGES BEFORE THE STATE
HERE. AND IF I MAY MR FONG I
THINK THAT MIGHT BE A GOOD A
GOOD POINT OF REFERENCE TO PIVOT
TO THE NEXT PANELS- ESPECIALLY
CONSIDERING THE DATA QUESTIONS
ABSOLUTELY AND I DO SO I ONE
LAST QUESTION WHICH IS I AND I'M
JUST TRYING TO GET AYE I GUESS
FROM MY PERSPECTIVE MILLION- I'M
JUST TRYING TO GET KIND OF A
THREE THOUSAND FOOT LEVEL TO
KIND OF. FRAME MY QUESTIONS TO
THE MINISTRATION IS. IS IT FROM
YOUR PERSPECTIVE DO YOU SEE A
STRATEGY THAT'S FORMULATING A
WIN WHAT IS DO YOU BELIEVE IN
YOUR MIND IS THE
ADMINISTRATION'S STRATEGY. FOR
FORTY THAT HOMELESSNESS I MEAN I
SEE A LAUNDRY LIST OF. A
PROPOSALS THAT ARE BEING FUNDED.
BY OUT IT DO YOU FEEL THAT THERE
IS COORDINATION OR DO YOU
BELIEVE THAT THE MISSION IS
JUST. THROWING YOU KNOW A BUNCH
OF MONEY INTO AGAINST THE WALL
AND TRYING TO FIGURE OUT. HOW TO
DEAL WITH A BUNCH OF THINGS.
INSTEAD OF. FINDING A MORE.
COHESIVE WAY OF- ADDRESSING.
HOMELESSNESS IN AN INSIGNIFICANT
WAY. AND I AND THAT WE MUST
QUESTION. SO IN OUR KNOWLEDGE OF
THE SORT OF BROAD PORTFOLIO OF
PROJECTS I'M SORRY OF A PROGRAM
THAT HAVE BEEN FUNDED. I'M TO
ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS IT SEEMS
PRETTY CLEAR. US THAT ACTUALLY
TWO MAIN PILLARS OF ACTION ONE
IS INFRASTRUCTURE. DO YOU SEE
THAT THROUGH ROOM KEY AND HOME
KEY SO THAT PROVIDING RESOURCES
TO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS. THAT THEY
CAN BUILD THEIR INFRASTRUCTURE-
PORTFOLIO SO THAT THERE ARE
OPTIONS TO BOTH YOUR SHORT TERM
AND LONG TERM OPTIONS. FOR
PEOPLE EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS
AND THE OTHER SHOULD MEET TAYLOR
THE STATE'S RESPONSE HAS BEEN
THIS FLEXIBLE EIGHT DIRECTLY TO
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS THROUGH THE
HOUSE PROGRAMS IT REALLY SEEMS
LIKE THERE'S A PIECE TO ALL
ACTION AT THIS POINT- THAT MAKE.
MAKE THE SORT OF CENTRAL
RESPONSE INTO THAT THE I THINK
THAT'S A MAJOR POLICY QUESTION
FOR THE LEGISLATURE MOVING
FORWARD. BECAUSE YOU KNOW TO
THESE TWO COLORS SHOULD'VE SEEM
LIKE THE RIGHT STEPS MOVING
FORWARD- THE LEGISLATURE.
CONTINUE TO THINK THAT THE BEST
POSITION PER TO DELIVER. SAYS
WITH SOME SOME PERHAPS GUIDANCE
AND POLICY DIRECTION THE STATE.
OR IS THERE TO MORE IN. IN A-
CERTAIN FRESH. TO THAT THROUGH
THE WAY THE STATE WILL- HOMELESS
CERTAINLY FORWARD. OR COME OF
THE TWO WEEKS IN THE PAST ABOUT
. HOW COMPLEX. IS A- THERE
REASONS WHY SOMEONE MAY FIND
HIMSELF HOMELESS SO AFFECTING
WHAT IS THE RIGHT WRIST. GET
BACK VERY WAYS IN WHICH MAYBE ON
. EXPERIENCING HOMELESS AND
ADDRESS ARE SHE DOES RECALL.
WHAT IT CAUSES QUITE COMPLETE. A
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
ANOTHER HUNTER QUESTION YEAH MY
ASK YET THAT'S NOT GOOD I'M
NOTHING GENERAL. THEY'RE ON THE
HEALTH. IN FOR PRO SO SEVEN
HUNDRED FIFTY SIX MIN DOLLAR.
YEAH WHAT DOES THAT ENTAIL WHAT
WHAT ARE THEY GETTING FROM THAT
PROGRAM THAT SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY
SIX MILLION DOLLARS. DURING L.
I'M NOT THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
ANALYST WITH THE L. A. S. AND
HAPPY TO TRY TO CONNECT ARE
SUBJECT MATTER EXPERTS WITH YOU
TO MAKE SURE YOU HAVE. A FULL
UNDERSTANDING OF IT. RIGHT- BUT
I NAY THAT GENERALLY THAT THE
PROGRAM IS. PRETTY EARLY ON IN
ITS DEVELOPMENT- IS THAT- I
GUESS MY QUESTION IS ARE THEY
ARE THEY PROVIDING. FUNDING FOR
EXISTING MENTAL HEALTH CLINICS
ARE THEY TRYING TO PRODUCE NEW
ONES OR BRING MORE PEOPLE AND
ARE THEY TRYING TO EDUCATED
WORKFORCE THAT WILL DO THAT OR
ALL OF THE ABOVE BECAUSE WHAT
THIS GOES TO IS WHAT MY
COLLEAGUE WAS TALKING ABOUT WAS
THE MENTAL HEALTH ASPECT OF
HOMELESSNESS- SOME OF THE HOME
KEY PROJECTS THAT HAVE BEEN DONE
OUT AND ARE. IN IN MY REGION-
HAVE HAD MARGINAL SUCCESS
BECAUSE WHAT THEY'RE DOING IS
THEY'RE PUT PUTTING PEOPLE INTO
HOUSING. AND THERE NEVER WHILE
THEY'RE THERE AND THEY TARA AND
THEN THEY'RE OUT. IN AFTER
AROUND HIM UP AND TRY TO GET
THEM BACK IN. AND THEN AFTER
MOVE EVERYBODY OUT SO THEY CAN
RE HAVE THE WHOLE THING AGAIN.
AND THEY MOVE PEOPLE THEN
BECAUSE WE HAVE GIVEN THE VERY
SERIOUS ISSUE. ON BOTH SIDES
THAT HAVE TO BE TREATED
DIFFERENTLY. WHEN YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT PEOPLE LOSING HOMES AND
FAMILIES BEING DISPLAYED. THAT'S
ONE THING. BUTTHIS THIS MENTAL
HEALTH PART OF IT IS HUGE
BECAUSE WE HAVE AN I'VE
EXPERIENCED THIS. WHERE WE THINK
SOMEBODY IS A HOMELESS PERSON.
AND ACTUALLY THE GUY REMEMBER
HAVING A WE USED TO ALWAYS GONE
JEFF SEIZURES. SHE WORE BAGS SHE
SLEPT ON THE WORK ON THE BENCH
SHE PUSHED A CART AROUND. JET
ALL THE- ALL THE APPEARANCE OF
BEING HOME WITH. WHICH SHE DID
SHE ACTUALLY HAD A HOUSE AND WAS
ACTIVE. IN A DECENT
NEIGHBORHOOD. IT WILL TORN UP
BUT SHE HAD A HOUSE. IN IT WAS
THE MENTAL HEALTH HEALTH ASPECT
OF THIS. AND THAT'S WHERE I FEEL
LIKE WE'RE MORE TO LEAVE AND
WE'RE GETTING LEFT BEHIND IS WE
REFUSE TO DEAL WITH. THE MENTAL
HEALTH ASPECT OF IT. AND THAT'LL
HELP A LONG WAY SO THAT WE CAN
ACTUALLY FOCUS SOME OF THIS. YOU
KNOW TWELVE BILLIONS AND
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS THAT WE WERE
SPENDING. ON ON ON PEOPLE THAT
CAN BE HELPED- THE- HAVING SHORT
TERM ISSUES AND JOB ISSUES. AND
THINGS LIKE THAT. SO THAT'S WHY
THAT'S WHY I WAS ASKING ABOUT
THIS THE- BEHAVIOR HEALTH ASPECT
OF THIS. IT'S SEVEN HUNDRED
FIFTY SIX MILLION DOLLARS. BUT
WHAT'S IT GOING TO HOUSE AND
ATTACKING THE PROBLEM AND AS YOU
SAID BEFORE YOU CAN GET ME THAT
INFORMATION FROM THE BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH FOLKS. SO THAT WOULD I
WOULD LIKE TO SEE THAT BECAUSE
THAT HELPS ME UNDERSTAND WHAT
MORE WE NEED TO DO TO TRY TO GET
A GRIP ON THIS MNTAL HEALTH
ASPECT OF THE HOMELESSNESS
POPULATION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MRS HERE TO AN AND I WOULD SAY
OUT 1100% IN AGREEMENT WITH YOUR
COMMENTS AND MR LACKEYS WITH
REGARDS TO. MENTAL HEALTH AND
SEEN THE BEHAVIORAL DOLLARS AND
HOW THEY'RE USED WE'VE HAD A
CONVERSATION BEFORE US TO
POTENTIALLY HAVING. ADDITIONAL
HEARINGS. AND COMBINING THOSE
ISSUES AND JUST A GENTLE
REMINDER THAT WE DON'T HAVE THE
EXPERTS AND STUFF FOR THOSE
PARTICULAR QUESTIONS BUT THAT'S
CERTAINLY. SOMETHING I THINK
THAT WE ARE ALL VERY MUCH
INTERESTED IN. SO UP WITH NO
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISS MONA LOSS
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO-
PETALUMA THREE PASS IT ON TO OUR
CULTURE. THANK YOU THE NEXT
PANELS IMPLEMENTING THE STATE'S
HOMELESSNESS PROGRAM. WILL BE
HEARING FROM THREE FOLKS THEN
WE'LL TAKE QUESTIONS AFTER THEY
PRESENT. THE FIRST AS SECRETARY
CASTRO AMERICA'S FROM THE
BUSINESS HOUSING AND CONSUMER.
SERVICES AGENCY AND CALIFORNIA
INTERAGENCY COUNCIL ON
HOMELESSNESS. COCHAIR SECRETARY
THERE. IT'S BEEN AFTERNOON YOU
AND ME OKAY YEAH WE CAN HEAR YOU
. VERY GOOD. ALL RIGHT WELL GOOD
AFTERNOON AT YOUR BABY YOU'LL
CHAIR WICKS AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY TODAY
AND THANK YOU ALSO TO- JOE
BARRETT FOR SHARING HER STORY I
THINK IT'S- IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT TO BE GROUNDED IN THE
EXPERIENCE OF AN INDIVIDUAL THAT
HAS NAVIGATED THROUGH THE
SYSTEMS TO HELP INFORM OUR
PARTY. OR POLICY MAKING. I AM
PLEASED TO TALK TO YOU TODAY
ABOUT THE STATE'S OVERALL
EFFORTS- INCLUDING
IMPLEMENTATION AND THEN THE
APPROACH. A TO GREATER
COORDINATION COLLABORATION AND
ACCOUNTABILITY. OF OUR SHARED
WORK TO PREVENT REDUCE AND
HOMELESSNESS. TWENTY TWENTY ONE
THE ADMINISTRATION DAVID STORK
INVESTMENTS TO ADDRESS.
HOMELESSNESS WITH TWENTY TWO
BILLION DOLLARS IN THE
CALIFORNIA THAT PLAN. OF THE
TWENTY TWO BILLION TWELVE
BILLION DOLLARS WAS ALLOCATED TO
IMPLEMENT SEVERAL HOMELESSNESS
SOLUTIONS OVER TWO YEARS
INCLUDING. FOR SUPPORT OR IN
TERM HOUSING PROGRAMS FLEXIBLE
EIGHT CITIES COUNTIES AND
CONTINUE ONCE IN CAMPAIGN
RESOLUTION GRANTS AND CAPITAL
AND OPERATING FUNDING TO EXPAND
THE NATIONALLY RECOGNIZED HOME
HE PROGRAM. THAT TO DATE HAS
FUNDED NEARLY SEVEN THOUSAND
HOUSING UNITS FOR PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS. OR AT
RISK OF BECOMING HOMELESS. WE
ALSO. THE NATION'S LARGEST
RENTAL ASSISTANCE PROGRAM ALONG
WITH THE STRONGEST EVICTION
PROTECTION MEASURES THUS FAR
WE'VE ASSISTED AND PREVENTED A
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY TWO THOUSAND
LOW INCOME RENTER HOUSEHOLDS.
FROM BEING ADDICTED BY
MOBILIZING TWO BILLION DOLLARS
AND RENTAL ASSISTANCE. ALSO THE
PORTABILITY IS THE MAJOR DRIVER
TO HOMELESSNESS HENCE WE
CONTINUE MOVING WITH SPEED TO
DEPLOY OVER TEN BILLION DOLLARS
TO PRODUCE MORE UNITS AND TO
EXPAND AFFORDABLE HOUSING
OPTIONS. COLLECTIVELY THESE
HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS
INVESTMENTS REFLECT AN
UNPRECEDENTED PARTNERSHIP
BETWEEN THE ADMINISTRATION THE
LEGISLATURE ARE FEDERAL AND
LOCAL PARTNERS TO TACKLE WHAT IS
ARGUABLY THE STATE'S MORE FOR
THE MOST FORMIDABLE CHALLENGE. I
COMMEND THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET SUB
COMMITTEE FOR AND ALSO THE
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE FOR YOUR
CONTINUED LEADERSHIP INCLUDING
YOUR SUPPORT OF THIS HISTORIC
LEVEL OF FUNDING. AND FOR OF
COURSE COMPLAINING TO THEY HAVE
TO LOOK AT WAYS TO FURTHER THE
EFFORTS. WELL FUNDING
INVESTMENTS ARE CRITICAL- IN
COORDINATION AMONG STATE
ENTITIES- IS ALSO A CRITICAL TO
THEIR PLAN TO JUST SHARE A
LITTLE MORE- ABOUT WHAT THE
STATE IS DOING IN TERMS OF.
COORDINATING ACROSS. STATE
AGENCIES AND STATE DEPARTMENTS.
AS A RESULT OF THE ENHANCEMENTS
POSSIBLE BY THE LEGISLATURE
THROUGH AT TWELVE TWENTY THE
HOMELESS COORDINATING AND
FINANCING COUNCIL WAS RE
LAUNCHED ON JANUARY FIRST OF
THIS YEAR. AS THE CALIFORNIA
INTERAGENCY COUNCIL ON
HOMELESSNESS OVER CAL I C. H. I
SERVICE THE CULTURE OF KELLY C.
H. ALONG WITH MY COLLEAGUE DR
MARTIN KELLY A SECRETARY OF THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH. AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY. THIS NEW
COUNCIL WILL ENABLE US TO
DEVELOP AND IMPLEMENT A ROBUST
MULTI PRONG SET OF STRATEGIES TO
PREVENT REDUCED AND HOMELESSNESS
. AS THE STATE CONTINUES TO MOVE
QUICKLY AND URGENTLY TO MAKE UP
GROUND OKAY EXPANSION OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING WE MUST NOT
FORGET THAT WE ARE A HOUSING FOR
STATE THIS IS NOT MEAN THAT WE
ARE A HOUSING ONLY STATE. WE
MUST ASSURE THE LINKAGE OF
HOUSING TO THE KINDS OF SERVICES
AND SUPPORT THAT PEOPLE NEED TO
THRIVE INCLUDING FELT IN
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES AND
SUPPORTS. ESCROWED SHARES
SECRETARY KELLY AND I ARE
WORKING WITH COUNCIL MEMBERS TO
INTEGRATE HEALTH HUMAN SERVICES
AND HOUSING. INTO ARTS STATES
HOMELESSNESS RESPONSE SYSTEM
WITH A HOLISTIC PEOPLE CENTERED
APPROACH THAT NOT ONLY SERVES
THE IMMEDIATE NEEDS THAT ALSO
PUBLICLY TEMPLES IMPORTANT
CROUTONS IS A PUBLIC. AT OUR
FIRST MEETING- OUR FIRST-
ACCOUNT I C. H. MEETING ON
JANUARY THE TWENTY SEVENTH WE
WERE FORTUNATE TO HAVE DR MARGOT
KUSHEL SHARE HER INSIGHT AND
RESEARCH. AMONG OTHER THINGS SHE
CRYSTALLIZED THE IMPORTANCE OF
FOCUSING ON BOTH HEALTH AND
HOUSING BY REMINDING US THAT THE
MOST POWERFUL MEDICINE TO
ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS IS HOUSING
. AND THAT HOMELESSNESS IS ONE
OF THE MOST DEVASTATING THINGS
THAT CAN HAPPEN TO SOMEONE TO
HELP. WE KNOW THAT HEALTH
CHALLENGES CONTRIBUTED TO THE
REST OF HOMELESSNESS AND
HOMELESSNESS DRAMATICALLY
WORSENS HEALTH. THEREFORE WE
MUST WORK TO INTEGRATE OUR
HOUSING AND HEALTH STRATEGIES
AND RESOURCES. IN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE WE CREATED A STRONG
FOUNDATION WITH THE STATE'S
FIRST COMPREHENSIVE ACTION PLAN
TO PREVENT AND END HOMELESSNESS.
ACTION PLAN SETS TANGIBLE AND
MEASURABLE GOALS AND BENCHMARKS
FOR PROGRESS. THE PLAN WAS
DEVELOPED IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
OUR STAKEHOLDERS IN PEOPLE WITH
LIVED EXPERIENCE. ACTION PLAN
SUCH AS RACIAL EQUITY AND
EVERYTHING THAT WE DO. AS A
RESULT THIS PLAN- THAT WAS
CREATED IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE I
WILL BE USED BY THE CAL I SEE
AGE AS A ROAD MAP TO GUIDE OUR
COLLECTIVE PROSTATE INTO WORK TO
ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS SYSTEM WIDE
. TO MEASURE PROGRESS THE STATE
HOUSE FOR THE FIRST TIME AN
INTEGRATED AND COMPREHENSIVE
DATA COLLECTION SYSTEM. CALLED
THE HOMELESS DATA INTEGRATION
SYSTEM OR H. THE I. S. THIS
SYSTEM ALLOWS US TO COLLECT AND
ACCESS DATA FROM LOCAL
HOMELESSNESS RESPONSE SYSTEMS.
ALL FORTY FOUR CONTINUE CONTINUE
ONCE ACROSS THE STATE HAVE
PROVIDED DATA TO THE STATE.
TRACKING HIS PROGRESS TO THE
COLLECTED DATA AND THE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE THAT WE ARE
DELIVERING REQUIRED ALSO RIVER
IN FOCUS ON ACCOUNTABILITY. WITH
THE ENACTMENT OF ANOTHER MANAGER. EIGHTY NINE SEVEN SEVEN NINE
SEVEN SEVEN ALL STATE FUNDED
HOMELESSNESS PROGRAMS ARE NOW
REQUIRED TO REPORT CONSISTENT
CLIENT DATA INTO THEIR LOCAL
HOMELESS MANAGEMENT INFORMATION
SYSTEMS. THIS ENSURES THAT THE
STATE'S INTEGRATED HOMELESS DATA
SYSTEM WILL CONTAIN COMPLETE
CONSISTENT AND COMPREHENSIVE
DATA ON ALL STATE AND FEDERAL
HOMELESSNESS PROGRAMS. STAFF IS
ALSO WORKING WITH LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TOWARDS OF THE
APPROVAL TO WORK IN APPROVAL OF
OUR- OF THEIR OWN AND LOCAL
HOMELESS ACTION PLANS THIS IS A
NEW REQUIREMENT UNDER HALF THREE
POINT NO ONE FOUR POINT NOW. ARE
THESE LOCAL ACTION PLANS ARE
REQUIRED TO BE SUBMITTED TO THE
STATE BUDGET AT THIS YEAR END OF
THE CAL I CH STAFF IS WORKING
CLOSELY TO. ENSURE THAT
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE-IS
PROVIDED AND ALSO THE COUNCIL
WILL BE RESPONSIBLE. FOR THE
EFFECTIVE OVERSIGHT OF THOSE
PLANS. BUT AS WE KNOW THE WORK
IS NOT DONE THE LAST MONTH- THE
GOVERNOR- NEWSOM RELEASED THE
CALIFORNIA. BUDGET WHICH-
REAFFIRMS HIS COMMITMENT TO
FUNDING HOMELESSNESS RESOURCES
TO WEEK HOUSE AND SHELTERED
INDIVIDUALS. SPECIFICALLY IT
INCLUDES A SET OF PROPOSED
ACTIONS THAT INCORPORATE HOUSING
. HUMAN SUPPORTS AND HEALTH
SERVICES WITH AN ADDITIONAL TWO
BILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT
INCLUDING FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS TO THE COWLIKE C. H. A
COUNCIL TO EXPAND BEING HAPPEN
RESOLUTION GRANT PROGRAM. IT IS
ESSENTIAL THAT THESE INVESTMENTS
ALSO BE MET BY INVESTMENTS IN
HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS FROM
OUR FEDERAL PARTNERS. WE KNOW
THAT THE HOMELESSNESS CRISIS
PREDATES THE PANDEMIC IN THAT
THE FEDERAL INVESTMENTS TO DATE
HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE TO FULLY
ADDRESSED THE CRISIS THAT
FAMILIES AND INDIVIDUALS ACROSS
OR STAYED IN THE PROCESS OF
COUNTRY CONTINUE TO FACE. WE
ALSO NOTE THAT- THIS WILL
PERSIST AND CONTINUE TO
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACT BLACK
INDIGENOUS PEOPLE OF COLOR
COMMUNITIES. OF WITHOUT MORE
FUNDING FROM OUR FEDERAL
PARTNERS IN THE FORM OF HOUSING
VOUCHERS TAX CREDITS AND FUNDING
FOR HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES.
WE ARE COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH
YOU TO CONTINUE TO IDENTIFY
EQUITABLE SOLUTIONS TO ASSIST
OUR HOMELESS NEIGHBORS. TODAY
YOU WILL ALSO HEAR FROM JULIE
LOW INTO SOME OF THE LAST CHANCE
JULIE IS THE EXECUTIVE OFFICER
OF TELL MY C. H. AND TOGETHER
WITH A TEAM OF FIFTY STAFF
MEMBERS IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
RUNNING THE DAY TO DAY
OPERATIONS OF THE COUNCIL. AND
ALSO OVERSEES THE DISTRIBUTION
OF FLEXIBLE HOMELESS FUNDING AND
CAPTAIN RESOLUTION FRANCE. WE'LL
START WILL THAT ARE OF HOUSING
AND COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT
CONSISTING OF ALMOST THIRTEEN
HUNDRED STAFF MEMBERS. WITH
RESPONSIBILITY FOR MANAGING
TWELVE POINT TWO BILLION DOLLARS
IN FUNDING. DIRECTOR VELASQUEZ
ALSO IS A MEMBER OF THE L. A. C.
H. I THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME AND HAVE A NEED- JOINT
TODAY'S HEARING. THANK YOU
SECRETARY AMERICAN IF YOU COULD
HANG TIGHT IN OUR PANEL HAVE
QUESTIONS FOR YOU AND YOU DID A
GOOD JOB I THINK OF INTRODUCING.
YOUR COLLEAGUES WHO WILL BE ON
THE PANEL OF MISS LOWER YOU
AVAILABLE AND CAN YOU HEAR US I
AM GREAT THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
WONDERFUL GOOD MORNING CHAIR
CARILLO CHAIR WICKS OR GOOD
AFTERNOON RATHER. AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS TRULY
LOVE AND I AM THE EXECUTIVE
OFFICER. OF THE CALIFORNIA
INTERAGENCY COUNCIL ON
HOMELESSNESS. I ALSO PRESENT YOU
WITH THE CALIFORNIAN WHO HAS
DIRECTED SUBSTANTIVE EXPERIENCES
OF HOMELESSNESS. WHERE FOR TWO
DECADES I LIVED IN TEMPORARY
SETTINGS INSIDE AND OUTSIDE OF
SHELTERS WITH MUCH OF MY TIME IN
A SHELTERED SETTINGS AS A CHILD
AND YOUNG ADULTS. IT IS MY HONOR
TO ADDRESS YOU TODAY IN MY
CAPACITY LEADING THE STATE'S
ENTITY THAT IS CHARGED WITH
GREATER COORDINATION. AND
COLLABORATION OF THE STATE'S
RESPONSE TO HOMELESSNESS. AND I
THANK YOU FOR PROVIDING ME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESSES
COMMITTEE. WELL THE PAST TWO
YEARS HAVE PRESENTED PANORMUS
CHALLENGES WITH THE ONGOING
COMMIT PANDEMIC AND PUBLIC
HEALTH CRISIS. IT HAS ALSO BEEN
A TIME OF SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS
TOWARDS GREATER COORDINATION
AMONG THE STATE'S EFFORTS FOR
PREVENTING AND ENDING
HOMELESSNESS. IN MY ROLE I HELP
DIRECT THE EFFORTS OF NEARLY
FIFTY CAL I C. H. STAFF. SO I'M
GRATEFUL TO BE HERE TO SHARE
WITH YOU SOME OF THE CRITICAL
WORK WE'VE DONE THROUGHOUT THE
PAST YEAR IN PARTICULAR. MOST OF
OUR EFFORTS ARE MADE POSSIBLE BY
THE LEGISLATURE AND I WOULD LIKE
TO EXPRESS GRATITUDE FOR.
ATTENTION FOCUSED ON THIS ISSUE
. FIRST I'LL TALK ABOUT HOW I.
C. H.'S ACTION PLAN FOR
PREVENTING AND ENDING
HOMELESSNESS LAST SPRING CAL A
SEAT AT THAT TIME THE HOMELESS
COORDINATING AND FINANCING
COUNCIL ADOPTED CALIFORNIA'S
ACTION PLAN FOR PREVENTING AND
ENDING HOMELESSNESS THIS PLAN
CENTERS AROUND FIVE CORE AREAS
WE COMMITTED TO TAKING ACTION.
SYSTEM STRENGTHENING UNSHELTERED
HOMELESSNESS INTERVENTIONS
SHELTERING PERMANENT HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS PREVENTION FOR THE
FIVE ACTION AREAS. UNDER THOSE
FIVE ACTION AREAS THERE ARE
FIFTEEN OBJECTIVES AND NEARLY
NINETY NINETY ACTIVITIES THAT
THIRTEEN STATE DEPARTMENTS HAVE
COMMITTED TO ACCOMPLISHING EACH
WITH CLEAR TIME FRAMES AND
PERFORMANCE MEASURES TO ENSURE
WE HOLD OURSELVES ACCOUNTABLE.
AND WORK TOWARDS PREVENTING AND
ENDING HOMELESSNESS IN AN
INTEGRATED WAY. THE ACTION PLAN
PRINCIPLES WE CENTER IN OUR
SHARED WORK AND OUR PRINCIPLES
ARE AS FOLLOWS. SHARE
RESPONSIBILITY ACCOUNTABILITY
AND EFFICIENCY ACROSS STATE
DEPARTMENTS AND PROGRAMS IN
CLOSE COORDINATION WITH LOCAL
COMMUNITIES. WE ALSO CENTER
PURSUING RACIAL EQUITY AND
JUSTICE THE HISTORIC AND VERY
CURRENT CAUSES OF RACIAL
INJUSTICE AND INEQUITIES AND
HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS AND THE
RACIALLY DISPARATE IMPACTS OF
HOUSING INSTABILITY AND
HOMELESSNESS. ARE CLEAR START
AND AS THE PANDEMIC MADE CLEAR
EVEN DEADLY HCFC AND ITS MEMBER
AGENCIES ARE COMMITTED TO
DEEPENING THEIR KNOWLEDGE AND
UNDERSTANDING OF THESE ISSUES
AND TAKING ACTION THROUGH THE
IMPLEMENTATION. OF THIS ACTUALLY
WITH A FOCUS ON RACIAL JUSTICE
AND EQUITY AND THE FORMATION OF
AN INTER AGENCY WORKING GROUP
FOCUSED ON RACIAL EQUITY AND
HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS. WE'RE
ALSO FOCUSED ON CREATING
SOLUTIONS FOR THE FULL DIVERSITY
OF PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS. THIS INCLUDES
ACTIVITIES WHICH RECOGNIZE THE
STRATEGIC ACTIVITIES AND
PROGRAMS MUST BE TRAUMA INFORMED
AND TAILORED TO ADDRESS THE
SPECIFIC NEDS OF PEOPLE WITH
DIFFERENT EXPERIENCES AND
IDENTITIES. INCLUDING YOUTH AND
YOUNG ADULTS FAMILIES WITH
CHILDREN ADULTS OLDER ADULTS
BUT- PEOPLE ARE GONNA FIGHT AS
L. G. B. T. Q. PLUS ARE.
NONCONFORMING VETERANS PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES SURVIVORS OF
DOMESTIC AND INTIMATE PARTNER
VIOLENCE AND OTHER PEOPLE. WE
ALSO KNOW THAT WE NEED TO
BALANCE CRISIS RESPONSE AND
PERMANENT HOUSING SOLUTIONS TO
MEET URGENT AND IMMEDIATE CRISIS
NEEDS OF PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS THEIR SUPPORTIVE
NON PUNITIVE APPROACHES. WITH
EFFORTS TO CREATE THE NECESSARY
PERMANENT HOUSING OPTIONS AT
SCALE NEEDED. AND IMPORTANTLY WE
MUST CONTINUE TO SEEK AND VALUE
THE EXPERTISE OF PEOPLE WITH
LIVED EXPERIENCES OF
HOMELESSNESS SO THAT THEIR INPUT
IS NOT JUST TAKE IT BUT
RECOGNIZE AND MEANINGFULLY
REFLECTED IN THE SOLUTIONS
PROPOSED. AT THIS PAST NOVEMBER
HELLO I. CH ADOPTED THE FISCAL
YEAR TWENTY TWENTY ONE ACTION
PLAN IMPLEMENTATION PROGRESS
REPORT WHICH PROVIDES DATA
HIGHLIGHTS AND DETAILS ABOUT OUR
COLLECTIVE PROGRESS IN THESE
ACTIVITIES. OUR CURRENT FOCUS
WITH THE ACTION PLAN IS UPDATING
IT TO REFLECT THE CHANGES TO OUR
COUNCIL ENABLE THREE AB TWELVE
TWENTY. WE WILL UPDATE OUR
ACTUAL PLAN LATER THIS YEAR TO
BE INCLUSIVE OF THE NEW COUNCIL
MEMBER DEPARTMENTS AS WELL AS
ANY UPDATES TO ACTIVISION
DEPARTMENTS ALREADY REPRESENTED
IN THE COUNCIL. THIS WILL HELP
US ENSURE THE ACTION PLAN
REFLECTS THE FULL SCOPE OF OUR
WORK. KELLY C. H. CONTINUES TO
TOWARD LAUNCHING THE INTERAGENCY
WORKING GROUP CALLED FOR IN THE
ACTION PLAN. WE DID CONVENE OUR
FIRST WORKING GROUP LAST QUARTER
FOCUSED ON MAXIMIZING THE IMPACT
OF STATE FUNDING AND PROGRAMS
ADDRESSING HOMELESSNESS. ALONG
WITH ACT CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR
ZAC OLMSTED AND H. H. ASK THE
SECRETARY FOR POLICY. CURRENT
YOU CAN AND I SERVICE THE
TRICARE OF THE STATE WORKING
GROUP. THIS GROUP HAS BEEN
MEETING MONTHLY BRINGING
TOGETHER LEADERS FROM THIRTEEN
STATE DEPARTMENTS AND AGENCIES
TO WORK TO COORDINATE AND
STREAMLINE OUR DISTINCT FUNDING
PROGRAMS. CHALICE EACH STAFFER
NOW IN THE PROCESS OF PLANNING
AND LAUNCHING THE NEXT WORKING
GROUPS FOCUSED ON RACIAL EQUITY. IN OUR HOME ASSIST RESPONSE
SYSTEM. L. I. C. H. AS BEEN OF
YOU KNOW OUR ENABLING CHARGES TO
OVERSEE THE IMPLEMENTATION
CALIFORNIA'S HOUSING FIRST
GUIDELINES AND REGULATIONS. IN
OUR ROLE MONITORING HOUSING
FIRST IMPLEMENTATION ACROSS THE
STATE HELLO I SEE THAT YOU
RECENTLY RELEASED A SURVEY TO
UNDERSTAND HOW STATE PROGRAMS
COMPLY WITH THE REQUIREMENTS OF
HOUSING FIRST. THE PURPOSE OF
THE SURVEY IS TO OBTAIN
INFORMATION ON THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF HOUSING FIRST
AND PROGRAMS THAT SERVE PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS WITH
AN ALL STATE AGENCIES AND
DEPARTMENTS. THE RESULTS OF THE
SURVEY WILL ALLOW COUNTY C. H.
TO BETTER UNDERSTAND HOW HOUSING
FIRST IS BEING IMPLEMENTED
ACROSS THE STATE AND HELP US
PROVIDE SUPPORT TO OUR STATE
PARTNERS. IN TANDEM. WITH THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE STATE MIGHT
ACTUAL PLAN. IN APRIL CAL I. CH
LAUNCHED ANOTHER IN TROUBLE PART
OF OUR STATE COORDINATION
NETWORK. THE HOMELESS DATA
INTEGRATION SYSTEM OR H. D. I.
S. H. E. I. S. OF THE STATE
MIGHT GET A DATA WAREHOUSE WORK
ALL FORTY FOUR CONTINUES OF CARE
REPORT DATA. MAKING IT THE MOST
COMPREHENSIVE VIEW OF THE
STATE'S THOMAS'S SERVICE
PROVISION TO DATE. DEVELOPMENT
OF H. G. I. S. AS GROUNDBREAKING
FOR CALIFORNIA IT IMPROVES OUR
ABILITY TO MAKE DATA INFORMED
POLICY FISCAL DECISIONS ABOUT
OUR STATEWIDE APPROACH TO ENDING
HOMELESSNESS. H. E. R. YES
ALLOWS THE STATE TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND THE SCOPE AND NATURE
OF HOMELESSNESS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE IT ALSO ALLOWS US TO TRACK
PROGRESS TOWARDS ENSURING ALL
CALIFORNIANS ARE PERMANENTLY AND
STABLY HOUSED AND TO EVALUATE.
THE IMPACTS OF OR INVESTMENTS.
FURTHER WE KNOW FOR ONE TIME TO.
IS NIGHT INTO TWENTY TWENTY AND
ONE PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS HOMELESSNESS
HOWEVER EACH YEAR YES IT'S
ALLOWED US TO UNDERSTAND THAT
THE ROUTE TWENTY TWENTY BEYOND
JUST A ONE NIGHT COUNT. OVER TWO
HUNDRED AND FORTY THOUSAND
PEOPLE EXPERIENCING EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS ACCESS SERVICE. IT
IS CRITICAL IN HELPING US
UNDERSTAND HOW TO ALLOCATE
RESOURCES THAT ADDRESS RACIAL
DISPARITIES AND TRACK INDIVIDUAL
LEVEL OUTCOMES FOR PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS. IT IS
ALSO STRENGTHENED OUR WORK WITH
THE STATE TO CONTINUE. AS WE
PROVIDED FONDLING TOOLS AND DATA
CAPACITY BUILDING THROUGH H. G.
I. S. THAT WILL IMPROVE THE
QUALITY OF THE DATA COLLECTED
LOCALLY. REMOTE COLLABORATION
AND SHARED UNDERSTANDING OF
TRENDS ACROSS THE STATE AND
ULTIMATELY TO PUT LOCAL EFFORTS
TO PREVENT AND END HOMELESSNESS
. DURING THE FIRST HALF OF
TWENTY TWENTY CALORIES EACH WILL
BE WORKING TO ESTABLISH SYSTEM
WIDE PERFORMANCE MEASURES. THAT
WILL COOK THE STATE AND LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS BETTER ASSESS THE
PROGRESS TOWARDS PREVENTING AND
ENDING HOMELESSNESS ONCE
FINALIZED WE WILL BE UPDATING
THE H. G. I. S. WEBSITE TO FOCUS
MORE ON THE OUTCOMES OF PEOPLE
ACCESSING SERVICES TO THE
CALIFORNIA. ALMOST RESPONSE
SYSTEM. ANOTHER AREA WHERE H. G.
I. S. WILL BE HE- IS THE
EXECUTION OF THE STATE WIDE
LANDSCAPE ASSESSMENT THAT THE
LEGISLATURE HAS AUTHORIZED
CALLOUS EACH TO CONDUCT.
CALORIES YES AGE IS CONDUCTING A
LANDSCAPE ASSESSMENT TO PROVIDE
A HOLISTIC UNDERSTANDING HOW
STATE FUNDS WORK TOGETHER TO
ADVANCE OUR GOALS OF PREVENTING
AND ENDING HOMELESSNESS. THE
STUDY WAS AUTHORIZED BY AB ONE
FORTY WHICH REQUIRES KELLY SIEGE
TO SUBMIT AN INTERIM RPORT TO
THE LEGISLATURE BY JULY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY TWO. AND A FINAL
ASSESSMENT BY DECEMBER THIRTY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY TWO. THIS IS
A NOBLE OF COMPREHEND. ESTATE
FUNDING TO QUANTIFY THE
RESOURCES DEVELOPED INCLUDING
DATA ON THE SERVICES FUNDED THE
INVENTORY CREATED SUCH AS
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING OR
EMERGENCY SHELTER BEDS FOR
EXAMPLE. AND HOW LOCAL
HOMELESSNESS SERVICE SYSTEMS
CREATED FUNDING WITH OTHER
SERVICE DELIVERY SYSTEMS. WE ARE
ALSO WORKING WITH THE VENDOR TO
EXTEND THE STATE'S UNDERSTANDING
OF WHAT TYPES OF INTERVENTIONS
LEAD TO WHAT RESULTS IN FOR HOME. THE SITUATION THE TEAM LED BY
CAROLINE C. H. GRANTS DIRECTOR.
RON WHO WAS ALSO PRESENT TODAY
HAS MADE SIGNIFICANT MILESTONES
IN THE IMPLEMENTATION OF OUR
GRANT PROGRAMS. FIRST ARE
HOMELESS EMERGENCY AID
PROGRAMMER HE- ENDED ON JUNE
THIRTIETH. OF THIS PAST YEAR
THIS WAS THE V. FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR BLOCK PRACTICES
LOCALITIES ACROSS CALIFORNIA IN
IMPROVING THEIR RESPONSES TO
HOMELESSNESS. AND HE SPENT EVERY
CENT ALLOCATED TO THE PROGRAM
AND WERE ABLE TO USE THE FUNDS
TO DEVELOP INNOVATIVE STRATEGIES
FOR ADDRESSING HOMELESSNESS. A
FORTHCOMING REPORT WILL EXPAND
UPON THE IMPACT OF HEAT AND AT A
VERY HIGH LEVEL HE CONTRIBUTED
FUNDING TO MORE THAN NINE
HUNDRED DIFFERENT PROGRAMS
PROJECTS THAT SERVE OVER EIGHTY
SEVEN THOUSAND PEOPLE.
FURTHERMORE A REPORT BY THE
DIVISION OF SOCIAL WORK AND SAT
AND THE CENTER FOR HEALTH
PRACTICE. POLICY AND RESEARCH AT
CAL CSU SACRAMENTO DEPICTED THE
WAYS IN WHICH HE SUPPORTED
COMMUNITIES. TO ADDRESS
UNSHELTERED HOMELESSNESS THE
PROGRAM SUCH AS COMPREHENSIVE
SAFE PARKING. INTEGRATED NOT
REACHING AND NAVIGATION CENTERS
TO NAME A FEW. THERE IS A SECOND
REPORT FORTHCOMING DESCRIBING
HOW HE WAS LEVERAGES TO SERVE
YOUTH EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS
TO BE PUBLISHED THIS MONTH. RT
IS WORKING ON A FINAL REPORT FOR
HEAT THAT WILL BE SUBMITTED TO
THE LEGISLATURE NEXT MONTH.
ADDITIONALLY CALATHES HAS BEEN
BUSY ADMINISTERING OUR UNLESS
HOUSING ASSISTANCE AND
PREVENTION PROGRAM WHAT HAPPENED
MISBACH MISTER LOTUS MISS LOW
APOLOGIES WE ARE RUNNING A
LITTLE SHORT ON TIME AND JUST
WONDERING HOW MUCH LONGER FOR
YOUR PRESENTATION. SO I'VE GOT
PROBABLY MINUTES I COULD
POSSIBLY GREAT THANK YOU PLEASE
GO AHEAD. WHERE WE'VE BEEN BUSY
WE'VE BEEN A BUSY BUNCH SO
APOLOGIES. SO IN ADDITION TO
KEEPING HAVE TELL I THINK IT'S
REALLY. PROPOSALS WERE
COMPETITIVE GRANT PROGRAM BEING
KEVIN RESOLUTION GRANT THIS IS A
NEW PROGRAM INTENDED TO DRIVE
INNOVATION INNOVATIVE
DEMONSTRATION PROJECTS FOR
SUPPORTING PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
UNSHELTERED HOMELESSNESS AND
ENCAMPMENTS. THE RATIONALE FOR
FUNDING IS ROOTED IN THE BROADER
KNOWLEDGE OF THE GROWING ISSUE
OF UNSHELTERED HOMELESSNESS. AND
IN THE BROADER KNOWLEDGE AROUND
UNSHELTERED HOMELESSNESS WHICH
INITIATED THE FIRST FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS I DON'T. IN
CLOSING THE STATE HOMELESSNESS
RESPONSE EFFORTS DURING THIS
PAST YEAR HAVE ALLOWED US TO
MORE EFFECTIVELY COORDINATE OUR
COLLECTIVE WORK TO PREVENT AND
END HOMELESSNESS INCREASED OUR
CAPACITY FOR DEVELOPING AND
IMPLEMENTING INNOVATIVE
SOLUTIONS. THE YEAR AHEAD
PROMISES EVEN MORE PROGRESS WITH
THE B. WATCH OF OUR COUNCIL
BRINGS IN FIVE NEW PURSE
DEPARTMENT. FIVE NEW MEMBER
DEPARTMENTS THE UPDATE OF OUR
ACTION PLAN AND OUR CONTINUED
WORK. ON H. G. I. S. THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
INVITING ME TO TESTIFY TODAY AND
I'LL TURN IT BACK OVER. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
TODAY NEXT WE'LL HEAR FROM
DIRECTOR GUSTAVO VELASQUEZ. THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT DIRECTOR.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR WOMEN WICKS
AND CUDDLY YOGA MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEES THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY TODAY I
AM WILL STUMBLE BELASCO'S
DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT OR A CD. WITH ME
TODAY STOP ALMOST SAID ARCHIE
DEPUTY WHO WILL ALSO BE
AVAILABLE DURING THE Q. AND A
SESSION. I'M HAPPY TO TALK WITH
YOU ALL TODAY ABOUT EIGHT CITIES
CONTINUED COMMITMENT TO SOLVING
THE HOMELESSNESS CRISIS. THIS
STATE IS PASSED THE TIPPING
POINT SO OUR CALL TO ACTION
NEEDS TO BE QUICK INNOVATIVE
COLLABORATIVE AND I'M GOING TO
TELL YOU HOW WE MADE THAT CALL.
EQUITEC CUSTOMER NEED AS
MENTIONED WE HAVE BEEN FORTUNATE
ENOUGH TO BE STILL WORST OF
UNPRECEDENTED RESOURCES STATE
AND FEDERAL. AND WE CONTINUE TO
WORK EXPEDITIOUSLY TO PUT THOSE
DOLLARS TO WORK IN A NUMBER OF
MEANINGFUL WICKS. THE ABUNDANCE
OF RESOURCES ENABLE US TO CREATE
MORE INTERIM AND PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING UNITS FOR OUR
HOUSE PEOPLE AND FAMILIES. AND
MEET THIS CHALLENGE THROUGH VERY
SUCCESSFUL PROGRAMS LIKE CLUNKY
NO PLACE LIKE HOME THE VETERANS
HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS
PREVENTION PROGRAM THE EMERGENCY
SOLUTIONS GRANT. AND MANY MORE.
EIGHT CDS YOU MAY KNOW IS
CURRENTLY IN THE SECOND
ITERATION OF HOME KEY AND IN
JUST THE LAST TWO MONTHS WE'VE
MADE AWARDS THAT WILL. YIELD
MORE THAN TWELVE HUNDRED UNITS
OF HOUSING WHEN ADDED TO THE
UNITS THAT WILL BE CREATED ON
THEIR THE FIRST ROUND OF CLUNKY.
THAT'S A PROBLEM AND SEVEN
THOUSAND UNITS IN THE HOME KEYS
AND NATIONAL MODEL NOT ONLY
BECAUSE IT HAS PROVEN TO BE
EXTREMELY COST EFFECTIVE BUT
BECAUSE HE EXEMPLIFIED THE
HOUSING FIRST. IS NOT SEEN ONLY
WE NEED MORE PERMANENT HOUSING
THAT INCLUDES SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES WITH ACCESS TO
TRANSPORTATION JOBS AMENITIES.
JUST TODAY WE OFFICIALLY
LAUNCHED A PUBLIC HOME KEEP DASH
WHERE I HOPE YOU'LL HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO SEE IT ON OUR
WEBSITE. TO PROVIDE STATISTICS
ABOUT ALL ASPECTS OF THE
PROGRAM. THIS DASHBOARD WILL
HELP ENSURE THAT WE CONTINUE TO
PRIORITIZE GEOGRAPHIC EQUITY
SUSTAINABILITY TRANSPARENCY AND
URGENCY IT WILL ALSO SHOWCASE
HOW WELL WE'RE DOING WOULD SET
ASIDE FOR REGION'S TRIBES
HOMELESS. YOUTH AND FAMILIES.
ARE NOT PLEASE LIKE HOME PRO.
WHICH FUNDS IS HOW UNITS IT'S
GOOD. FOR HIM TO BE LIVING A
SEER. MENTAL ILLNESS WHO ARE
HOMELESS OR EXITING INSTITUTIONS
TO DATE THE STATE HAS AWARDED
MORE THAN ONE POINT THREE
BILLION DOLLARS. HELPING TO
CREATE MORE THAN THIRTEEN
THOUSAND UNITS. ANOTHER PROGRAM
THE VETERANS HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS PREVENTION PROGRAM
THAT EIGHT CD. AT ADMINISTERS IN
COLLABORATION WITH CALVET THIS
PROGRAM FINANCES THE DEVELOPMENT
OF A VARIETY OF RENTAL HOUSING
FOR VETERANS AND THEIR FAMILIES.
THIS BUT IT'S BETTER AND THEY
WERE ABLE TO ANNOUNCE A HUNDRED
AND TWENTY FIVE MILLION IN
FUNDING. FOR STATEWIDE
ORGANIZATIONS TO CONSTRUCT
AFFORDABLE HOUSING ACROSS THE
STATE TO SERVE VETERANS AD
THEIR FAMILIES IN ALL THROUGH
SIX ROUNDS. OF FUNDING THIS
PROGRAM HAS. NOT PRODUCED ANY A
PROJECTS MORE THAN FIFTY SIX
HUNDRED UNITS. M. R. EMERGE SORT
BUT KILEY RECEIVED OVER THREE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION IN ESG
FUNDS THROUGH THE CARE ACT TO
RESPOND TO ALL OF IT. THIS WAS
ON TOP OF THE TWELVE MILLION THE
CALIFORNIA RECEIVED EVERY YEAR
ON THEIR ESG RAPID RE HOUSING
HOMELESSNESS PREVENTION HISTORY
OUR REGION MARGINS THE SHELTER
WITH THE NUMBER OFF AT THE BACK
RELATED INDICATORS THAT WE- HAVE
A RESULT THE FROM THIS PROGRAM
TWENTY TWO. HUNDRED HOUSEHOLDS
TO GET WRAPPED BE RE HOUSE EIGHT
THOUSAND PERSONS PROVIDED
EMERGENCY SHELTER SIX THOUSAND
EMERGENCY SHELTER BEDS AVAILABLE
THROUGHOUT THE YEAR. DID I
MENTION THE RENT RELIEF PROGRAM
FIVE POINT TWO BILLION DOLLARS
TO PROTECT PANDEMICRELATED.
BRAND BELIEVE IN THIS A STATE.
THE TIME- I WILL JUST GO JUST
MENTIONED THAT WE CONTINUE TO
WAR WITH THE U. S. TREASURY TO
GET FARTHER ASSISTANCE FOR OUR
STATE'S RESIDENTS AS WE ARE
WORKING ON. ANOTHER FOUR HUNDRED
THOUSAND PLUS ACTIVE CASES IN
ADDITION TO HAVING STRUCK THE
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY TWO THOUSAND
HOUSEHOLDS FROM. HELP THEM
ABLATED BEECHEN AS OF THIS WEEK.
ARE NOT. INCLUDING IT IS BOTH
THE UNPRECEDENTED LEVEL OF
INVESTMENTS THE STATE AND
FEDERAL GOVERNMENTS ARE
PROVIDING END. PLANS WITH THE
STATE LAW BY LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
TO DISMANTLE BARRIERS TO HOUSING
PRODUCTION BOTH OF THESE THINGS
THAT WILL AMELIORATE HOPEFULLY
ONE THAT YOU READY CAKES
HOMELESSNESS AND PREVENT THAT
MORE PEOPLE IN POVERTY ENTER.
THE DEVASTATED CYCLE OF
HOMELESSNESS WE MUST HOLD LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS ACCOUNTABLE SHOULD
THEY NOT HONOR THEIR HOUSING
COMMITMENTS. ARE HOUSING
ACCOUNTABILITY UNIT WITHIN EIGHT
CD PLAYS A CRITICAL ROLE IN
ENSURING THE LOCAL LEADERS WILL
FEEL THEIR LEGAL
RESPONSIBILITIES TO PLAN ZONE
FOUR AND PER MEETING SHARE OF
THE STATE'S HOUSING NEEDS.
INDY'S UNITY CENTURION BUT THE
HUNDREDS OF HOUSING ELEMENTS
HEVS CURRENTLY REVIEWING ON THE
RENO SIX CYCLE INCLUDE THE
REQUIRE SHARE OF HOUSING. ACROSS
THE INCOME SPECTRUM BUT
ESPECIALLY YOU NEED FOR
INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES A
GREATER RISK OF BECOMING
HOMELESS THIS UNIT TAKES A
HOLISTIC APPROACH THAT COMBINES
PERHAPS INCENTIVES PLANNING
GRANTS EDUCATION. TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO HELP JURISDICTIONS
UNDERSTAND THE LAW. AND ALSO
STRONG ACCOUNTABILITY ACTIONS
FOR NON COMPLIANCE ON VARIOUS
STATE HOUSE IN LOS. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME AND SUPPORT AND WE
LOOK FORWARD. TO THE REST OF THE
BASIS WHICH- THANK YOU TO OUR-
THIRD PANEL HERE WE WILL IT BACK
HERE THE DIS AND I START WITH MR
COOPER. THANK MILLION SHARES FOR
THE- QUESTIONS THAT- DO WE
CHANGES TO THE L. WENT LETTERMAN
PATRICIA ACT ARE NEEDED TO HELP
REDUCE HOMELESSNESS. AND WHAT
CHANGES YOU THINK ARE NEEDED. AS
A MEMBER DO YOU MIND REPEATING
THAT QUESTION I DIDN'T GET THAT
THIS PART SURE DO YOU BELIEVE
THAT CHANGES TO THE LAN
LETTERMAN PETROUS SHORT ACT-
NEEDED. ANNA SO WHAT CHANGES ARE
NEEDED. YES OF THE LEGISLATURE
X. THINK ABOUT SPENDING
CONSERVATORSHIP. THANK YOU SO
MUCH ASSEMBLY MEMBER COOPER FOR
THAT QUESTION AND I- WOOD
WELCOME THE OPPORTUNITY TO
FOLLOW UP WITH YOU AND I THINK
THAT THE HARDEST QUESTION ABOUT
. INSTERBURG CONSERVATOR SHIP-
EIGHT AND- THAT THE ROLE THAT HE
PLAYS IN TERMS OF OUR OVERALL
BULLISHNESS RESPONSE SYSTEM IS
ONE THAT. REQUIRES YOU KNOW FOR
FURTHER DISCUSSION AND SO I
WOULD LOVE TO FOLLOW UP WITH THE
OFFICE ON THAT OKAY WELL ON HIS
BELLY OF THREE MEMBERS. FROM
FORMALLY PUBLIC SAFETY IS REALLY
A BIG ISSUE AND WE KNOW THAT THE
STATE'S HOMELESS POPULATION
SUFFERS A PORTION OF IT FROM
SOME FORM OF MENTAL ILLNESS. AND
BUT I DON'T WE HAVE A LOT OF
DEBT OF THE STATE DOESN'T RIGHT
NOW WHAT THAT IS. AND IT IS WE
KNOW I WAS A FORMER JAIL
COMMANDER HER SECOND COUNTY WITH
PROPER ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE
MEDICATIONS PEOPLE NOT JUST
THOSE THAT ARE THERE HOUSING
AND- CHRISTIAN FACILITIES CAN
DESTABILIZE A MEASURE
CONDITIONS. BUT A FORCING THE
STATE MAKES IT DIFFICULT FOR
THIS POPULATION WHO ARE OVERLY A
MEDIC CAL. OF WIND IS ONE OF THE
STATE AND SPECIFICALLY
DEPARTMENT HEALTH CARE SERVICES
REQUIRE PRIOR AUTHORIZATION FOR
MEDICATIONS USED TO TREAT
INDIVIDUALS WITH SEVERE MENTAL
ILLNESS. MANY OF WHOM. ARE THE
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE ON HEALTH.
THANK GOODNESS SOMEONE IDEA I
THINK THIS IS A VERY. QUESTION
AND- AS I MENTIONED WITH THE
LAUNCH OF THE- A CALIFORNIA
INTERAGENCY COUNCIL CLOSER TO
SAID THIS COLD ED WITH. US
SECRETARY KELLY AND MYSELF- WE
ARE- GOING TO. CONTINUE LOOKING
AT WAYS TO- INTEGRATE NOT JUST
OUR HOUSING- APPROACH BUT ALSO
OF GREATER UNDERSTANDING OF THE
HEALTH AND BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AND
SUPPORTS THAT ARE NECESSARY. TO
ENSURE THAT INDIVIDUALS THAT
ARE- EXPERIENCING- HEALTH OR
MENTAL HEALTH- CHALLENGES RIGHT
THAT THAT THERE IS THE RIGHT
LEVEL OF SUPPORT- THE GOVERNOR
SKINNER PROPOSED- BUDGET
INCLUDES TWO BILLION DOLLARS- OF
THE TWO BILLION DOLLARS ONE
POINT FIVE BILLION WILL BE
ADMINISTERED BY HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES. WITH A SPECIFIC FOCUS
ON HOUSING- AND SERVICES
SPECIALIZED SERVICES TO ADDRESS
AND MENTAL HEALTH- AT CONCERTS
IN IN IN ISSUES IN AND SO MAYBE
I IT WOULD INVITE- ALSO ACTIVELY
LOW TO SPEAK. FURTHER TO HOW
WE'RE ALSO LOOKING TO I
GATHERED- DELAYED UNTIL SEPT
OVERALL THE THROUGH AND. THROUGH
THE WORK OF CALYX EACH. THANK
YOU SECRETARY SO COUPLE OF THAT
I YOU KNOW I THINK SPEAKING MORE
BROADLY ABOUT SORT OF WHAT
SERVICE NEEDS AREN'T PARTICULAR
JURISDICTIONS ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WE RECOMMEND DAHLE
JURISDICTIONS AS THEY GET A
STRONG UNDERSTANDING OF WHO
EXACTLY THEY'RE SERVING. AND
WHAT THOSE NEEDS MIGHT BE AND IT
SOUNDS LIKE YOU'RE REFERENCING
YOU KNOW THE PROPORTION OF
PEOPLE WITH IN A JURISDICTION
THAT MIGHT HAVE- BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH- NEEDS AND WE DO
ENCOURAGE THROUGH A COUPLE
THINGS. ON OUR FORTHCOMING LOCAL
ACTION PLANNING PROCESS REQUIRES
THAT LOCAL JURISDICTIONS PROVIDE
US WITH A TANGIBLE PLAN OF THE
WAYS THAT THEY WILL SERVE THOSE
WITHIN THEIR PARTICULAR
JURISDICTIONS AND THE WAYS IN
WHICH THEY WILL INTEGRATE THE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AND
HOMELESSNESS SERVICES. AND SO I
WOULD SAY YOU KNOW THAT THAT
WOULD BE A CANNIBAL WAY THAT WE
CAN START TO ADDRESS THIS
QUESTION IN A MEANINGFUL WAY BUT
AGAIN AS OUR SECRETARY STATED.
I'M AYE AYE I WOULD DEFER TO OUR
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
PARTNERS TO PROVIDE A MORE
ROBUST ANSWER AS AS- I I'M NOT A
I'M NOT AN EXPERT A BEHAVIOR
HEALTH SERVICES SO THANK YOU
SURE AND IT'S NOT YOUR FAULT
THIS IS AN ONGOING PROBLEM TO
GET OUR ARMS WRAPPED AROUND AND-
THAT'S THE NUMBER ONE ISSUE THE
PUBLIC IS HOMELESSNESS THAT IS.
I'VE SEEN THE POLLS PEOPLE
CONCERNED ABOUT IT AND EXPECT
GOVERNMENT TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT
IT BUT THE PROBLEM IS THERE'S NO
ADULT IN THE ROOM SAYING HEY.
THESE FOLKS CAN'T CARE FOR
THEMSELVES WE NEED TO CARE FOR
THEM YOU HAVE ON PEOPLE IF YOU
FEEL YOU THAT WOULD PREFER TO
HAVE SOMEONE OUT WALKING AROUND
AND CLOSED. IN 32 DEGREES
WEATHER THEN DO A
CONSERVATORSHIP ON THEM AT SOME
POINT WE HAVE TO HAVE AN ADULT
THE ROOM AND SAID HEY LOOK WE'RE
GONNA TAKE CARE OF THESE PEOPLE
AND REALLY DO IT. AND FOR THE
HOUSING STUFF ON THE
HOMELESSNESS- ON HAL'S IT'S BEEN
VERY VERY HEAVY ON HOUSING AND
THEY TALK ABOUT REFERENCE
SERVICES BUT WRAPAROUND SERVICES
ARE LIGHT. ON THE MENTAL HEALTH
PART AND THEN ALSO SUBSTANCE
ABUSE PART AND I'LL GIVE YOU A
JOB IN THE HEALTH OF YOUR ROOF
OVER YOUR HEAD IT'S HARD TO GET
OFF DRUGS. IF YOU COMBINE THE
TWO IT'S FOR BED REST HE STILL-
I. I'VE HEARD MAYBE MITCH THE
GOVERNOR TALKING CONSERVE. I
WOULD ENCOURAGE THAT. BECAUSE
WHAT WE'VE BEEN DOING ITS OWN
WORK. WE SPENT A LOT MONEY OVER.
BILLION THE PROBLEM HAS GOTTEN
WORSE. SO IT. IS A SOMEONE A
SPENT YOU PROBABLY GOT CLOSE TO
NINETY YEARS OF. PUBLIC SAFETY
SERVICE. RIGHT HERE IN THIS
ROOM. AND FOR FOLKS THAT ARE ON
THE GROUND DOES THIS AND NOT
BEING. POLITICIANS SITTING IN A
CHAIR SOMEWHERE BUT I ACTUALLY
SAW THE RESULTS AND WHAT COULD
HAPPEN. YOU HAVE TO THE SERVICES
YOU HAVE TO HAVE A
CONSERVATORSHIP IN A SOME POINT
I HOPE SOMEONE. DOES THAT I'VE
BEEN HERE EIGHT YEARS I BOUGHT
IT MANY MANY TIMES. AND IT NEVER
GETS ANY TRACTION FROM ANYONE'S
OVER THE GOVERNOR'S STAFF IS
LISTENING IT'S TIME TO BE THE
BILL THE ROOM AND SOLVE THIS
PROBLEM. THANK YOU MISTER COOPER
WHENEVER MISTER WARD. RIGHT I
WANT TO THANK EVERYBODY FROM THE
pADMINISTRATION FOR YOUR
PRESENTATIONS HERE TODAY AND-
PARTICULARLY MISS LOW THANK YOU
FOR YOUR INTRODUCTIONS AND- YOU
KNOW AT A COMPREHENSIVE OVERVIEW
OF THE WORK YOU'RE DOING I'M
SURE YOU ALL I HEARD SOME OF MY
COMMENTS TO THE LA- WHICH- YOU
KNOW I WILL I WILL SAY GOING
FORWARD ARE THINGS I'M GOING TO
BE- BEATING THE DRUM ON- TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE ARE LOOKING AT
OUTCOMES AND THAT WE ARE
COUNTING PROGRAMS THAT OUR WORK.
AND THEN REDIRECTING RESOURCES-
YOU KNOW AWAY FROM PROGRAMS THAT
MAY NOT WORK IT SOUNDS LIKE
YOU'RE ON THE SAME TRACK MISS
LOS A THANK YOU FOR SETTING THAT
UP WILL FOLLOW UP WITH YOU IN
TIME- I HAD QUESTIONS FOR
DIRECTOR VELASQUEZ- I A IN- WAS
REMINDED OF THE- STATE AUDITOR'S
REPORT FROM LAST FALL THAT
ACKNOWLEDGED ON JUST THE
DIFFICULTIES ABOUT GETTING ESG
FUNDS OUT TO LOCAL COMMUNITIES
AND- YOU KNOW REALLY KNOWLEDGE
IN THAT SOME OF THAT WAS COMING
FROM JUST PROCESS CONSTRAINTS
AND- JUST- CALIFORNIA'S
INABILITY TO REALLY SPEND ON
THAT MONEY AND GET IT TO LOCAL
COMMUNITIES AND WHEN I. HEAR
FROM OUR CEO SEES IN OUR CITIES
AND THEY WANT TO RECEIVE THAT
THEY WANT TO SCALE UP ON SO MANY
OF THESE PROJECTS- I WANTED FOR
YOU AND IT'S PARTICULARLY-
IMPORTANT HERE IN A BUDGET
CONVERSATION CAN YOU ELABORATE A
LITTLE BIT MORE ON THE STAFFING
LEVELS THE RIGHT SIZING THAT YOU
NEED FOR TRAINING FOR ON PROCESS
IMPROVEMENTS- TO BE ABLE TO
REALLY BUILD UP WE PUT SO MUCH
ON YOU IN THE FORMS OF BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS TO GET OUT THE DOOR.
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT AS AN
ADMINISTRATION YOU CAN ACTUALLY
MOVE THAT FORWARD AND DOWN TO
OUR COCS IN OUR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO BILL AT THAT
HOUSING TO BUILD UP THE
SERVICES- AND MAKE SURE THAT THE
STATE GOVERNMENT IS AND-
DELAYING- HOW DO YOU FEEL ABOUT
YOUR NEEDS- AND BASED ON THAT
REPORT- BUT NOT SPECIFICALLY FOR
ESG FUNDS MORE BROADLY FOR ALL
FUNDS. WHAT IS THE
ADMINISTRATION'S ABILITY TO
REALLY PROCESS FIVE FLOW THESE.
DOLLARS DOWN TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. SOME MEMBER I. VERY
MUCH UP. THAT LESS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I T. THE TO GROW AT A
VERY RAPID- OUT WE CONTINUED TO
BUILD UP OUR INFRASTRUCTURE FROM
A STAFFING TO OUR DATA
INFRASTRUCTURE TWO DIFFERENT
TOOLS THAT WILL HELP US TO
STREAMLINE EXPENSE I RESOURCES
WILL BUILD RESOURCES TO USE
QUICKLY THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT
WE'RE DOING- IT JUST I EAT I
KNOW IT IS YOU POINTED OUT THE
AUDIT AND THE ESG. CARE ACT
PROGRAM I WANT YOU TO KNOW THAT
WE ARE WELL ON OUR WAY TO SPEND
A 100% OF THE DOCTORS FROM THE
ESG CARE ACT MORE THAN THREE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS- WHEN
THESE AUDIT ACT AND CAME UP WE
WERE CLOSE 220% OFF EXPENDITURES
WERE CLOSED UP 70% OF
EXPENDITURES AND WHICH HAVE A
TOTAL EXPENDITURE DEADLINE BY
THE END. OF THE YEAR AND WE WILL
ABSOLUTELY MEET THAT DEADLINE
AND ALL THE EXPENDITURES WILL BE
THERE WILL BE MADE AND ALL OF
THIS AT IMPORTANT DOLLARS TO
ADDRESS AT THE EMERGENCY THE
HEALTH EMERGENCY WILL BE- AT
WILL BE COVERED ICE. AND LOCAL
JURISDICTION FROM HOMELESSNESS
PREVENTION TO RAPID RE HOUSING
THE STREET OUTREACH EMERGENCY
SHELTER EVERYTHING THAT THE ESG
CARE ACT PROGRAMMING THE ESP
PROGRAMMING GENERAL FUND SO WE-
YOU KNOW WE CONTINUE- TO PAY
ATTENTION TO ALL OF THESE
INCREDIBLE HISTORIC RESOURCES
THANKS TO THE GOVERNOR AND THE
LEGISLATURE THAT WE'RE RECEIVING
AND WE'RE NOT A STOCK AND WE ARE
BUILDING UP OUR INFRASTRUCTURE
WE- WE HAVE AN AMAZING STAFF-
THAT. WORK DAY IN AND DAY OUT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THESE RESOURCES
ARE PUT TO GOOD USE AND THEIR
PARTY GIVES A GOOD USE- VERY
QUICKLY ALL. THANK YOU DIRECTOR
. MADAM CHAIR. THANK YOU- A
QUESTION A COUPLE FOR MS LOW
THEN BUT FIRST- I'LL STAY WITH
YOU MISTER OF ALASKA'S WOULD YOU
BE ABLE TO PER THE REPORT OUR
DATA WITH SOME OF THE THAT YOU
BEEN. SPEAKING ABOUT TODAY SO
THAT WE CAN BETTER UNDERSTAND OF
MEASUREMENTS OF SUCCESS AND
WHERE SOME OF THOSE
OPPORTUNITIES MAYBE. ABSOLUTELY
I'M HCV HAVE BEEN- RECENTLY
ENDED IN THE LAST YEAR- CREATING
A DEDICATED DATA PORTAL ON OUR
WEBSITE YOU WILL FIND-
INTERESTING- AT THE AT IMPORT
RELATED DATA ON A NUMBER OF
PROGRAMS- NO PLACE LIKE HOME-
CERTAINLY ARE HUNKY PROGRAM I
MENTIONE- TODAY THAT AS OF THIS
MORNING AND WE HAVE A LIVE
DASHBOARD- WE HELP YOU LOOK AT
IT IT SHOULD SHOWS AND A NUMBER
OF INDICATORS IN TERMS OF HOW
THE HOME KEY PROGRAM IS
DEVELOPING TWO TYPES OF. THE
NEEDS THAT IS CREATING OUT FOR
WHOM- AND SO WE- WE HAVE- A
NUMBER OFF- INDICATORS IMPACT
RELATED INDICATORS FROM THE
VETERANS PROGRAM TO NO PLACE
LIKE HOME TO OUR FEDERAL
PROGRAMS. SUCH AS THE EMERGENCY
SOLUTIONS GRANT PROGRAM THAT
ASSEMBLY IN THE WORD MENTION
UNCERTAINTY CLUNKY SO WE'LL BE
HAPPY TO PROVIDE YOU AND
INFORMATION THAT YOU NEED ON
UNITS ON THE PEOPLE SERVED ON
THE CAMPUS SPEND TOWARDS
WHATEVER YOU NEED ALL THANK YOU
SO MUCH AND BY WHEN WILL WE BE
ABLE. TO RECEIVE THAT- DEPENDING
THE REQUESTS WE CAN- IT
IMMEDIATELY PROVIDE THAT TRIED
TO BE DILIGENT AND WITHIN A FEW
DAYS JUST PROVIDE THAT TO YOU.
OKAY THANK YOU WILL BE SURE TO.
MAKE SURE TO FOLLOW UP WITH THE
MEMBERS OF BOTH COMMITTEES TO
RECEIVE THAT INFORMATION FOR
DATA EVALUATION THANK YOU. MISS
LOW WHAT IS THE WAS THE STATE
PREVIOUSLY COORDINATING IN
RESPONSE ACROSS AGENCIES TO
HOMELESSNESS PRIOR TO CREATING
WHAT WE NOW CALL. A CAL I SEE
AGE. OR WHAT IS NOW CAL I C. H.
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION- WE
IN OUR- IN OUR- EXISTENCE AS THE
HOMELESS COORDINATING AND
FINANCING COUNCIL DID PLACE
SIGNIFICANT GROUND- THE ACTUAL
PLAN FOR PREVENTING AND ENDING
HOMELESSNESS FOR EXAMPLE WHICH
WAS ESTABLISHED LAST YEAR
THROUGH A VERY ROBUST I'M
STAKEHOLDER INPUT PROCESS BOTH
WITH OUR LOCAL PARTNERS ACROSS
OUR STATE ENTITIES AND-
ADVOCATES AND RESEARCHERS WAS
ESTABLISHED PRIOR TO THE LAUNCH
OF CAL ICIJ FOR EXAMPLE. I WILL
SAY THAT THE WORK THAT WE DO NOW
BECAUSE OF THE INTEGRATION- OF
OUR HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
PARTNERS WITH- OUR OUR AGENCY
DOES ENABLE JUST TO GREATER- FOR
LACK OF BETTER TERM REACH AND
ABILITY TO COORDINATE AND
PARTNER I THINK OUR CULTURE
STRUCTURE- WHICH WAS I BELIEVE
THIS SORT OF IMPETUS FOR THAT
BILL- ENABLES US TO BETTER
COORDINATE OUR WORK AND SO I
WOULD SAY. WHILE THAT EXISTED WE
CONTINUE TO MAKE PROGRESS. AND
IMPROVE THE WAYS WE CAN DO SO.
AND THANK YOU JUST A FOLLOW UP.
WHAT IS THE- OF CAL I CA IN
COORDINATING THE STATE RESPONSE
TO HOMELESSNESS AND ARE THERE
OPPORTUNITIES TO COORDINATE. AND
STREAMLINE THOSE PROGRAMS ACROSS
AGENCIES. AND I THINK THE VISION
OF WHERE WE ARE IT'S THE VISION
OF WHERE CAL ICY H. AS HAD IT IS
THAT WE- BRING FORTH A CONTINUUM
OF SERVICES AND CHARITIES THAT
WORK. AND THAT'S VERY BROADLY
SPEAKING AS VISION TEND TO BE-
BUT ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE
I'M CONTINUE TO DO IS TO USE OUR
ACTION PLAN FOR PREVENTING
ENDING PREVENTING AND ENDING
HOMELESSNESS. THROUGH THE
INFRASTRUCTURE TO HELP US THINK
THROUGH HOW THE FOURTEENTH STATE
DEPARTMENTS CAN CONTRIBUTE
ACTIONS AND- WORK TOGETHER TO
COORDINATE A BETTER RESPONSE ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT I THINK HAS
BEEN MADE VERY CLEAR- THROUGH
THE QUESTIONS IN THE COMMENTS
MADE IN THIS- PARTICULAR HEARING
IS THAT- HOMELESSNESS IS A MULTI
FACETED ISSUE. AND THERE IS NO
ONE SOLUTION AND THERE IS NO ONE
PERSON EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS
AND DO WE VERY MUCH BELIEVE
THAT. ON THE ROAD TO INCREASE
COORDINATION HAS TO DO WITH
SHARED GOVERNANCE SHARED WORK
AND- THAT'S SORT OF A SHARED
VENUE TO BE ABLE TO. TO MAKE
DECISIONS AROUND WHERE WHERE WE
HEAD NEXT I DO THINK THINGS LIKE
THE HOMELESS DATA INTEGRATION
SYSTEM WHICH TO PROVIDE THE DATA
TO ENABLE US TO ENABLE US TO.
OUR ANSWERED INTO THE STATUS OF
OUR EFFORTS AND HOPE WAS PROJECT
OUR FUTURE EFFORTS WILL BE
CRITICAL IN THAT WORK. I ALSO
APPLIED AGAIN THE HAP MOBILE
ACTION PLANS I'M WE YOU'RE- HAVE
BEEN SAYING WE DON'T THINK OF IT
AS THE HAPPY LOCAL ACTION PLAN
WE THINK OF IT AS A LOCAL ACTION
PLAN. THAT JURISDICTIONS WILL BE
WORKING ACROSS THEIR PARTICULAR
SYSTEMS. TO BE ABLE TO FULLY
INTEGRATE. THANK YOU MISTER
LUCKY. YEAH JUST REAL QUICKLY I
WOULD LIKE TO- BELLA THE REMARK
BY MY COLLEAGUE SAN AND PURSUE.
ACT IN OUR I THAT THAT IS A-
LONG AND COMING AND I AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO. THOSE CONSIDERATIONS
BUT I HAD JUST ONE. REALLY
BURNING QUESTION WHICH OF THE-
THE RECENT ROUTE OF FUNDED
PROGRAMS SERVE INDIVIDUALS WHO
ARE INCAPABLE OF ASKING FOR HELP. LET'S TO ANYBODY ON THE PANEL
. OR ARE THERE ANY ANY OF THE
PROGRAMS ARE DESIGNED DIRECTLY
TO US SERVE THOSE WHO ARE
INCAPABLE OF ASKING FOR HELP.
I'M HAPPY TO TAKE THAT QUESTION-
SO I THINK YOU'RE REFERRING TO
PROGRAMS THAT MAY SERVE THE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH NEEDS OF
PEOPLE EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS
AND AGAIN- I WOULD DIRECT. BUT
COME WITH BROADER INTERPRETATION
OF MY QUESTION I DON'T MEAN TO
CUT YOU OFF. BUT I'M VERY
SPECIFICALLY TARGETING. A GROUP
OF PEOPLE THAT ARE QUITE LARGE-
AND I JUST WONDER AT IS THERE A
PROGRAM DESIGNED TO REACH THAT
POPULATION. THAT'S A VERY DIRECT
QUESTION. AND AGAIN I WOULD I
WOULD SAY THEY'RE HOPEFUL THAT
OUR PARTNERS AT HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES TO DO OVERSEE THE
BEHAVIOR HEALTH CONTINUUM WOULD
BE BEST EQUIPPED TO PROVIDE AN
ANSWER TO THAT. OKAY THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS. I GUESS NOT
OKAY- I WANT TO THANK THE PANEL
AND I KNOW MISTER KING AS
QUESTIONS TOO BUT I JUST HAVE
TO- I DON'T KNOW IF YOU'LL SAW
ON THE SACRAMENTO BEE- EDITORIAL
BOARD- AT EDWARD OPINION TODAY-
DISCUSSING THE CHALLENGES OF
COORDINATING HOMELESSNESS
SERVICES- AT LEAST IN SACRAMENTO
COUNTY THERE ARE SIXTY ONE
DISTINCT ACCESS POINTS FOR
HUNDRED FOURTEEN DIFFERENT
PROGRAMS IN THE REGION. WHICH
MAKES IT VERY DIFFICULT TO
NAVIGATE FOR OUR AND HOUSED
FOLKS IN OUR COMMUNITY AND
SACRAMENTO IS TRYING TO WITH THE
LEADERSHIP OF JAIL STEINBERG
LEAD THE WAY HERE FOR WHAT A
SINGLE POINT OF ACCESS SINGLE
POINT OF ENTRY FOR FOLKS WHO
NEED SERVICES- YOU KNOW WE
DISCUSSED HERE  THINK THE
CHALLENGES AROUND COORDINATING
SERVICES- TUTTO I ANY OF THE
PANELISTS YOU KNOW WHAT CAN THE
STATE DO TO HELP ENSURE THE
SERVICE SERVICES ARE BEING
COORDINATED ON THE GROUND THAT
ACCESSING THESE. BENEFITS AND
RESOURCES ARE MADE EASY BY FOLKS
WHO NEED IT- AND THEN WE ARE
COORDINATING EFFECTIVELYLOCALLY
AND FOR THOSE WHO NEED CARE.
CHAIRWOMAN AT ALL- STARTED IN
AND- IN THE DEFINITELY WENT ASK
JULIAN AND- POSSIBLE THEY HAVE
ADDITIONAL REMARKS BIT. IN A I
CAN THINK THROUGH VERY IMPORTANT
DRAW- THAT WEEK. TO PROVIDE THE
LEVEL OF- VISION AND CLARITY IN
TERMS OF THAT THE STATE'S- OVER
ARCHING GOALS AS WE INVEST-
HOMELESSNESS FUNDING BUT THAT WE
ALSO PROVIDE THE LEVEL OF-
JACKSON BUILDING AT THE- LEVEL
TO HAVE CITIES AND COUNTIES AND
COMMUNITIES- I UNDERSTAND THE
POSITION THAT THEY'RE SERVING IN
PRIORITIZE- THE BILL'S DOLLARS
TO INSURE. THAT ADULTS DOLLARS
OR AND MEETING THE PRIORITIES
ESTABLISHED BY THE COMMUNITY
ENHANCE- WHY IT'S BEEN VERY
IMPORTANT TO PROVIDE THAT
HOMELESS HOUSING ASSISTANCE-
PROGRAM FUNDS FLEXIBLE EIGHT TO
CITIES AND COUNTIES AND CONTINUE
ON. OUR END ANALYSTS YOU KNOW-
SHOULD BE MENTIONED- THE ONGOING
SUPPORT THAT WE'RE PROVIDING TO
LOCAL COMMUNITIES AT TO DEVELOP
A COMPREHENSIVE LOCAL ACTION
PLANS- THAT GET TO A ADDRESSING
SOME OF THE GAPS IN SERVICE
DELIVERY THAT WE SEE IN SOME
COMMUNITIES. SO AT I THANK YOUNG
DEFINITELY THINK THAT- AND-
SACRAMENTO IN THEIR APPROACH- IN
THE WORK THAT THEY'RE DOING. IS
IN APPROACH- IN THE SERVICE
DELIVERY- EFFORT THAT WE WOULD
WANT TO LEARN MORE ABOUT AND
ALSO LIFT UP TO SHARE WITH
OTHER- COMMUNITIES- BUT- AGAIN I
THINK YOU'RE REINFORCING THE
IMPORTANCE OF HAVING A COUNTY
LOCAL- COMMUNITIES TAKE MORE OF
THE OWNERSHIP IN THE LEADERSHIP
FOR- AND DETERMINING. WHAT THOSE
SERVICE DELIVERY SYSTEMS
BOOKMARK ARE IN AT THE STATE AB
WITH BEING AT THE TOP DOLLARS-
THREE POINT NO AND FOR NO WE ARE
. VERY MUCH TO BE AT. OF THOSE
ACTUALLY AND THOSE EFFORTS ARE
MOVING TO NEW ON SIX HI
INDICATORS THAT- HELP US BETTER
GAUGE AND THE OF IN THE- FOR
EXAMPLE THAT ARE EXTRA HOME. AND
INTO HOW. AND THE NUMBER OF IN
THE- THAT ARE- NOT YOU KNOW RE
ENTERING THE HOMELESSNESS SYSTEM
FOR EXAMPLE. AND SO IN A JULIET
IF YOU'D LIKE TO ADD ANY
ADDITIONAL DETAILS. SO I WOULD
AGREE WITH ONE THING THAT WILL
FLAG AS I'M AWARE THAT THE LOCAL
THE FEDERAL LAW PROVIDE IS TO
FOLLOW OURS AND I WOULD- NOTHING
I KNOW I DON'T WANT ANSWER THE
QUESTION I DO THINK THAT THEY
MIGHT BE. MORE APPROPRIATELY TO
SORT OF TALK THROUGH WHAT
INDIVIDUAL AND SYSTEMS NEED I
THINK THIS DOES FIND A COUPLE
THINGS THAT WE OFTEN LIKE TO
SHARE WHICH IS EVERY COMMUNITY
IS GOING TO BE VERY DIFFERENT
THAN THE WAY THE RESOURCES COME
TOGETHER NEED TO SHOOT BUT THE
PURPOSE AND NEED ABOUT
PARTICULAR COMMUNITY. WE HAVE
THE STATE ESPECIALLY COUNY SEAT
STAND AT THE READY TO SUPPORT
OUR LOCAL PARTNERS WITH
REPROGRAMMING FUNDS IF IT IS
ABOUT- OTHER RESOURCES FOR
EXAMPLE BUT WE DO BELIEVE THAT
THAT IS A LOCAL DECISION. TO BE
MADE BY THOSE WHO ARE. THE
DIRECTLY IN CHARGE OF THE
SERVICE. WITHIN AT CHURCH. IF I
JUST MAY ADEQUATE BECAUSE YOUR-
GERMAN H. A WOMAN AT WHICH YOUR
YOUR QUESTION WAS CAN'T CAN'T
WHAT CAN THE STATE DO WELL IN
THE- DIDN'T. INFRSTR THE WAY IN
WHICH JURISDICTIONS PROVIDE.
INTO SERVICES FOR THE HOMELESS
IS VERY MUCH A LOCAL DECISION
BUT- AT A AYE I INTERPRET THAT
QUESTION- INTERNALIZE THAT
QUESTION AS AN H. C. V. AS
SERIOUS THE PROGRAMS THAT WE
HAVE. TO SUPPORT LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS REALLY ABOUT THE
FLEXIBILITY WHEN THESE PROGRAMS
ARE CREATED ARE WE NEED THE
INTENT OF THE LEGISLATURE-
WIFE'S FUNKY BANDS SUCH A
SUCCESSFUL PROGRAM THAT'S BEEN
DEPLOYING. YOU KNOW EIGHT
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN
RECORD TIME AND RECORD COST
BECAUSE OF THE FLEXIBILITY IN
WHICH THE PROGRAM WAS DESIGNED
TODAY IS MONDAY WAS ON AN
ARTICLE IN POLITICAL ABOUT VERY
SIMILAR PROGRAM. AND THAT THE
STATE OF NEW YORK TRIED TO
IMPLEMENT IT HASN'T IT HASN'T M.
EVEN PROVIDE AT AB M. A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS IN FUNDING ONLY
ONE APPLICATION WAS RECEIVED BY
THE STATE OF NEW YORK AS AT
CONTRARY TO NEARLY SEVEN
THOUSAND UNITS EE I HAVE ALREADY
CREATED UNDER CLUNKY HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. THE ANSWER IS SIMPLE
FLEXIBILITY FLEXIBILITY THAT TE
CONCORD PROGRAM ALLOWS FOR LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS- FOR THE STATE TO
MEET LOCAL JURISDICTIONS WHERE
THEY ARE AND THE COMMUNITIES
WHERE THEY ARE I THINK THAT'S
JUST THAT THE MOST IMPORTANT I
THINK ROLE. AS A STATE WE CAN'T
. THANK YOU MISTER. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR JUST WANTED. START
WITH A C. Q. THROUGH ALL MY
NUMBER HERE AGO YOU ISSUES
REGARDING- VACANCY AND SORT OF
WAY YOU'RE AT- YOU KNOW WE ARE
HEAD COUNT IS NOW IN WHERE YOUR
FAITH ARE NOW. YEAH WE A AYE
THANK YOU FOR THAT. IS MEMBER WE
MEDICAL MILES. AT THE END OF-
YEAR WEBER WE WERE VERY. TO HAVE
- WE WOULD TO BE WELL THE LAW OF
THIS STATE WIDE AVERAGE- JUST
APPROXIMATELY TWO THIRD NINETEEN
THIRTEEN. PERCENT VACANCY RATE
WELL UNDER 10% RIGHT NOW ARE WE
CONSIDERING HAS GONE UP BECAUSE-
A LOT OF ADDITIONAL RESOURCES TO
STOPPING LEVELS THAT WE HAVE TO
INCREASE WE I THINK THAT WE ARE
CLOSE TO SIXTEEN PERCENT. BY WE
WILL NOT SEE THE DAIS AT BACK IN
THE OLD DAYS WHERE HCV WAS
CONFRONTED WITH YOU KNOW- 2530%
VACANCY RATE WE WILL MAINTAIN
THAT MAY CONSIDER A LINE WHAT
WOULD TRACK WE'RE GOING TO TRY
BY THE END OF THE YEAR TO BRING
IT. BACK TO UNDER 10% THAT'S
GREAT NEWS CONGRATULATIONS AND.
WHAT WHAT YOUR ROUGH F. T. HOW
CAN I KNOW WE'VE GROW YOUR TO
QUITE IF. I QUITE A BIT OF THE
LAST FEW YEARS. BOB A CHIP DAY
IS HERE- SECOND I WE ARE-
HUNDRED- MR ALMOST ALMOST CAN
YOU VERIFY THAT I THINK AROUND
TWELVE HUNDRED. YEAH WE ARE JUST
A SHADE UNDER TWELVE HUNDRED
RIGHT NOW- TO SOME OF THE
EARLIER POINTS- SOME OF THE
FEDERAL AUTHORIZATION WE GET
PURPOSES OF PETITIONS FOR SOME
OF OUR FEDERAL OUR RESOURCE WILL
PROVIDE EXTENSIVE DON'T ALWAYS
COME THE PROPOSAL ON THE SCENE.
CABLES AT THE STATE THE
POSITIONS IN THE BUDGET YEAR SO
WE VERY RECENTLY GOT APPROVAL
PERSONALLY FEDERAL POSITION SO
THAT WILL GROW UP BASED ON SOME
OF OUR OUR FEDERAL RESOURCES
THAT SYSTEM THE ITEM. JUST
BECAUSE OF SOME QUESTIONS ABOUT
OUR CAPABILITIES THERE SO WE
HAVE VERY MUCH FOCUSED ON THE
FEDERAL SIDE TO CREATE A NEW
FEDERAL BRANCH AS YOU MAY RECALL
THE BEGINNING OF TWENTY TWENTY
ONE IS TO EXCLUSIVELY DEAL WITH
FEDERAL RESOURCES SO- AS OTHER
RECOGNITION YOU KNOW WE'RE WELL
ON OUR WAY TO GET THAT NUMBER
BACK DOWN WE'VE BEEN QUITE
PLEASED. THAT THE TALENT FRANKLY
THAT WANTS TO COME WORK FOR THE
STATE- IN THE INTEREST BECAUSE-
I THINK PEOPLE SEE IT AS ME IN A
MOMENT OF THE DISGRACING ITSELF
IT'LL SO- PORTION UNDER TWELVE
HUNDRED IT WILL GO UP A LITTLE
BIT. ADDS UP AS NEW FEDERAL.
AUTHORIZATION GREAT THANK YOU- I
KNOW THIS. MISLED TALKED ABOUT.
FLEXIBILITY TO A LOCAL AND
THAT'S THAT. I THINK FROM YOU
KNOW CA. BANKING WITH. I THINK
ONE OF THE CHALLENGE. AS AB.
WHILE I GUARD CURRENT WE NEED TO
CONTINUE TO HAVE. TO THE
CHALLENGES HAS BEEN DEVELOPING.
BENCHMARKS AND MEASUREMENTS TO
ENSURE THAT THE LOCALS ARE
ACTUALLY- THE JUDGE ACHIEVING
GOALS- WALL RECEIVING FLEXIBLE
FUNDING FOR CAN YOU CAN YOU WALK
ME THROUGH SOME OF THE- SOME OF
THE KEY BENCHMARKS THAT YOUR
AGENCIES OR MISS LOW YOU KNOW
YOU'RE LOOKING AT- TO- TRACK
SUCCESS ON BEHALF OF THE- ON
BEHALF OF THE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
AND THE COCS RIVER CITIES
COUNTIES. YOU'RE HAPPY TO DIVE
INTO THAT- I WILL SAY A COUPLE
THINGS THAT WE ARE WORKING ON
SIMULTANEOUSLY BOTH ENABLED BY
THE LEGISLATURE FIRST IS THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE EIGHTY
NINE SEVEN SEVEN WHICH EXPANDS
THE NUMBER OF HOMELESSNESS
PROGRAMS STATEWIDE WHICH ARE
REQUIRED TO ENTER DATA INTO EACH
OF MY **** WHAT THAT WILL LOOK
CHEAP ON OUR END. IS THAT WILL
MAKE UP WHAT IS ADHD I AS MUCH
MORE COMPREHENSIVE- AND WILL BE
INCLUSIVE OF I'M TO THE FULL
RANGE OF HOMELESSNESS PROGRAMS
THAT ARE FUNDED BY THE STATE AS
YOU CAN IMAGINE AN INCREASE IN
THE NUMBER OF BUT IF THE
INCREASE IN DATA AND RECORDS
THAT ARE INJURED. MEANS MORE
ACCURATE INFORMATION AND AGAIN-
WE ARE COLLECTED. ON A QUARTERLY
BASIS MENTIONS. GIVEN SIZE AND
SCOPE OF PROGRAM. SAID THAT.
EACH YEAR YES AND THE BECOME
VERY IMPORTANT IN OUR PURSUIT OF
UNDERSTANDING OUT COMES. UP
FIRST WE WILL BE IMPLEMENTING
WHAT ARE KNOWN AS THE SYSTEM
PERFORMANCE MEASURES I THINK IN.
OUR PRIVATE SECTOR THEY MIGHT
CALL THEM- LEADING INDICATORS
PERHAPS- AND IN THOSE SIX
INDICATORS. INVOLVED EVERYTHING
FROM- THE NUMBER OF PERSONS
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS WITHIN
A JURISDICTION. I'M TO THE NEW
LENGTH OF TIME PEOPLE REMAIN
HOMELESS FOR EXAMPLE. AND
REDUCING THE RETURNS TO
HOMELESSNESS THERE ARE SIX FOUR
MEASURES THAT I'M HAPPY TO
SHARE- WITH THIS COMMITTEE AND
THAT WILL BE DIRECTLY TIED. TO
OUR HOUSE PROGRAM AND ATTACHED
TO THE HOUSE LOCAL. ACTION PLAN
PROCESS. DOES NOT. ANSWER YOUR
QUESTION- OUR SERVER FOR LITTLE
MORE SPECIFICITY THAN THAT. SO
THOSE SO THOSE SYSTEM
PERFORMANCE MEASURES WILL BE
USED TO SET GOALS- WHAT ROLES
ESSENTIAL PRETTY COULD YOU WALK
US THROUGH THE MEASURES. SURE
THING. IT'S A SENSE OF HOW
SUCCESSFUL YOU ARE GATHERING ANY
DATA TO TRUCKERS MEASURES. SO WE
CAN TRACK THOSE MEASURES NOW
THROUGH THE HOMELESS DATA
INTEGRATION SYSTEM. I'M THOSE
SIX MEASURES ARE REDUCING THE
NUMBER OF PERSONS EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS REDUCING THE NUMBER
OF PERSON TO BECOME HOMELESS FOR
THE FIRST TIME. INCREASING THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE EXITING
HOMELESS INTO PERMANENT HOUSING
REDUCING THE LENGTH OF TIME
PERSONS REMAIN HOMELESS.
REDUCING THE NUMBER OF PERSONS
TO RETURN HOMELESSNESS AFTER
EXITING. INCREASING SUCCESSFUL
PLACEMENTS FROM STREET OUTREACH
AND ALL OF THESE GOALS WILL BE
DISAGGREGATED TO IDENTIFY
UNDERSERVED POPULATIONS. I DO
YOU HAVE OUR GRANTS DIRECTOR
VICTOR TO RUN TO TALK ABOUT WHAT
THAT GOAL SETTING PROCESS WILL
BE. AS I THINK YOU'RE ASKING FOR
A MUCH MORE DETAILED QUESTIONS
AROUND SORT OF WHAT OUR PROCESS
WITH OUR PARTNERS WILL BE. WHAT
WHAT IS THE BIG. I THINK THOSE
BEFORE GOING TO. YOUR GRANDSON.
THE GRANTS PERSON THE CYST SIX
INDICATORS- SEEM TO BE VERY
APPROPRIATE COULD CAN YOU WALK
US THROUGH- YOU'RE THE FIRST
MONTH YOU GOT A DATA SAID AND TO
WHERE WE ARE NOW AND ALSO WHAT
TRENDS YOU'RE SEEING WITH THE TO
THOSE INDICATES TO THINK THAT'S
INDICATING VERY APPROPRIATE. SO
I'M GIVEN THE HIRING SORT OF THE
HIGH VISIBILITY OF THESE WE
ACTUALLY ARE WORKING WITH THAT
VENDOR NOW. TO ASSURE BOTH- THAT
WE'RE SORT OF DOING OUR DUE
DILIGENCE ON THE ON THE
CALCULATIONS OF THOSE AND WE
WILL BE USING THEM- WE ARE
CURRENTLY USING AB. SO THAT WE
CAN. UNDERGO THE PLANNING
PROCESS IN YOUR CD POTS BECAUSE
IT'S SORT OF A BIG IT'S A BIG
SIX MONTHS FOR US HERE KELLY C.
H. WE ARE DUE TO SUBMIT THOSE
PLANS AND THE GOALS BY I BELIEVE
THE END OF JUNE AND SO WE'RE
CURRENTLY UNDER WAY IN
DEVELOPING BOTH THE MEASURES AND
WORKING TO SCHEDULE THE
APPROPRIATE MEETINGS WITH EACH
OF THE SEVENTY SEVEN GRANTEES.
TO THAT USE THOSE FIGURES TO SET
GOALS. OKAY SO AT THIS POINT
YOU'RE HAVING DATA YOU CAN SHARE
WITH US. SO WE DON'T HAVE DATA
UNTIL WE WILL BE SUBMITTING THE
FULL PACKAGE. I'M IN THAT WILL
BE A PUBLIC PROCESS BY I BELIEVE
IS THE END OF JUNE. SO AFTER THE
BUDGET PROCESS IS DONE. SO HOW
HOW COULD WE GET DATA HEAD OF
THE BUDGET PROCESS WHICH WILL
HELP INFORM US OF. WHERE WE
SHOULD BE SPENDING OUR MONEY. I
THINK THAT MIGHT BE A DEEPER
QUESTION THEN I'M PREPARED TO
ANSWER NOW IN THE SENSE THAT WE
DO HAVE EXISTING. DATA AROUND
HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE BEING SERVED
FOR EXAMPLE I WILL SAY THAT WE
CONTINUE TO COLLECT DATA ON A
QUARTERLY BASIS FROM OUR CEO
SEES THAT START TO GIVE US. A
SENSE FOR HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE
BEING SERVED FIVE WE HAVE MADE
THE DECISION THAT WE'RE GOING TO
FOCUS ON THESE. I'M SYSTEM
PERFORMANCE MEASURES BECAUSE
THEY ARE THE COMMON MEASURES BUT
I THINK FOLKS HAVE BEEN LOOKING
FOR ASKING FOR ANSWER TO DIVERT
BY USING OTHER METRICS. WOULD BE
YOU KNOW WOULD BE WHICH WOULD
BREAK A ACTUALLY ARE INTENDED
FOCUS ABUSING THE SYSTEM
PERFORMANCE. MEASURES WELL
PERHAPS. YEP FOR. SOMEONE ELSE
WAS SENT TO THE PARTICULAR MORE
THAN WELCOME TO JUMP IN.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER THIS IS A LOTUS-
ACOSTA FROM IT IS THAT AGENCY
AND THEN IT MIGHT BE HELPFUL FOR
ME TO JUST- CAN YOU TAKE A STEP
BACK IN IN. IN TERMS OF. AND
THAT THE PROCESS AND WEBER ATTY
IN TERMS OF GETTING TO MEASURING
OF THE OVERALL AND- I PROGRESS
IN OUTCOMES TIED TO THE SIX
MANAGERS SO THE FIRST TWO ROUNDS
OF HAP FUNDS AT THAT WENT OUT TO
CITIES COUNTIES AND COMMUNITIES.
FRANKLY DID NOT HAVE AND THEY
WERE NOT TIED TO THE SIX
INDICATORS THESE WERE DOLLARS
THAT WERE DISTRIBUTED. ACROSS
THE STATE AND TO PROVIDE LOCAL
COMMUNITIES THE GREATEST LEVEL
FLEXIBILITY- STILL ASKS AND THE
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO BUDGET WAS
ADOPTED- A TWO YEAR BUDGET WITH-
HISTORICALLY HIGH LEVELS OF
HOMELESSNESS DOLLARS. AND THAT
THE FUNDING REQUIRES THAT
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE GOING TO BE
SEEN HAPPEN FUNDING- GO THROUGH
A LOCAL- PLANNING PROCESS TO
ESTABLISH LOCAL ACTION PLANS
THAT ARE DUE TO THE STATE BY THE
END OF JUNE OF THIS YEAR. AND
THOSE LOCAL ACTION PLANS MUST
DESCRIBE THE SIX INDICATORS AND
THE GOALS THAT THEY'RE
ESTABLISHING. AND HOW ALL THIS
WILL BE UTILIZED. ONCE THOSE
PLANS ARE SUBMITTED TO THE STATE
OR TEAM WILL BE ASSESSING- THE
PLANS OF ASSESSING AT THE- HOW
REASONABLE THESE GOALS ARE. AND
THEN ALSO USING THE DATA THAT WE
HAVE- GATHERED AND COLLECTED IN
AND FRANKLY AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
I WOULD SAY THAT. WE ARE IN MANY
WAYS OVER THE LAST TWO YEARS
PLAYING SORT OF CATCH UP FOR
DEVELOPING INFRASTRUCTURES IN
THE SYSTEMS. OUT TO ENSURE NOT
ONLY THAT THERE'S GREATER
COORDINATION BUT THAT WERE ALSO
GATHERING THE DATA- THAT WILL
HELP INFORM HOW DOLLARS ARE
BEING SPENT WHAT STRATEGIES AND
SERVICES AND SOLUTIONS ARE
EFFECTIVE OR NOT EFFECTIVE. AND
THEN ALSO CONNECTING THOSE
INVESTMENTS AND THE SOLUTIONS TO
WHAT THE FEDERAL FUNDING- AT THE
END OF THE FUNDING COMING FROM
HI THROUGH EITHER VOUCHERS ESG-
YOU NAME RIGHT. AND SO. I THINK
THAT ONE OF THE REAL- WE'RE NOT
AT A POINT OF BEING ABLE TO
PROVIDE CONCRETE DATA IN TERMS
OF THE SIX INDICATORS IS BECAUSE
WE ARE CURRENTLY MOVING THE
SYSTEM TO ENSURE THAT BILL SIX
INDICATORS BECOME THE WAY OF
MEASURING- PERFORMANCE AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL. BUT WE DO HAVE IN
THE BILL YOU KNOW WHAT THE-
PLACE TO FOLLOW UP AND ENSURE
THIS WITH YOUR YOUR OFFICE ONE
WE DO HAPPEN NOW IS THE HOMELESS
DATA INTEGRATION SYSTEM THAT IS-
BASICALLY A COLLECTION OF DATA
FROM FORTY FOUR CONTINUE ONCE
THE PROCESS STATE. THAT IS
CENTRALLY AGREED TO SHARE THIS
DATA WITH THE STATE THE STATE IT
ABLE SAYS TO UNDERSTAND. WHO
THESE CONTINUOUS ARE STARTING ON
THE TYPES OF SERVICES THAT ARE
BEING PROVIDED AND THE TYPES OF
EXITS OUT OF THE SYSTEM OR. OR
THE TYPES OF- INTRIGUED THIS.
AND NOT AB SHOULD NEVER BEEN
DONE BEFORE THE STATE THIS IS
THE FIRST. THAT THE STATE HAS A
COMPREHENSIVE VIEW OF WHAT IS
HAPPENING ACROSS THE STATE WHEN
IT COMES TO HOMELESSNESS. WHEN
IT COMES TO OUR HOMELESSNESS
RESPONSE SYSTEM AND THAT THE
DISPATCH AND HELP SORT OF
PROVIDE CONTEXT AND ANSWER YOUR
QUESTIONS NO IT IF IT DOESN'T
HAPPEN I APPRECIATE THAT NIGHT
OF DEFINITELY PLUG YOU IN YOUR
AGENCY ON THE- THE H. T. I. S.
DATABASE I THINK THAT'S A GREAT
FIRST STEP PICKING. CAN YOU GIVE
ME A SENSE OF WHAT. DATA YOU'VE
BEEN ABLE TO COLLECT IN H. D. I.
S. A WHEN IT'S WHEN IT'S TELLING
US. JULIE DO YOU WANT TO GO
AHEAD AND GO THROUGH SOME OF THE
DATA. SURE THING SO WHAT IS-
COLLECTED IN THE GCIS. R. ONE
I'M COME FROM LOCAL HOMELESS
MANAGEMENT INFORMATION SYSTEM
AND THEY'RE KNOWN AS OUR-
UNIVERSAL ELEMENTS INTO THOSE
INCLUDE DATA THAT ARE TAKEN IN.
AT AT THE TIME MR WHEN SERVICES
ARE PROVIDED TO PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS THE
SORT OF DATA THAT WE HAVE OUR-
THE- DEMOGRAPHIC CHARACTERISTICS
OF THOSE WHO WERE BEING SERVED-
THE- THEY CALL THEM PROJECTS BUT
ESSENTIALLY THE TYPES OF
SERVICES. THAT PEOPLE- ARE
UTILIZING INCLUDING- OUTREACH-
TEMPORARY SHELTER AND. PERMANENT
HOUSING FOR EXAMPLE. N WITH
THAT IS SORT OF A PRIVATE OF HOW
WHEN THEY MIGHT HAVE SOUGHT
SERVICES WHERE THEY MAKE NOT
WHERE THEY THOUGHT THERE RISEN
IN TERMS OF JURISDICTIONS. I'M
AS WELL AS SORT OF A- A TREND
OVER TIME WE ARE COLLECTING DATA
FROM TWENTY EIGHTEEN ON AND WE
CONTINUE TO REFRESH DATA ON A
QUARTERLY BASIS. THAT'S GREAT TO
HEAR CAF DATA STARTING IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN WHAT WHAT WHAT TRENDS
ARE YOU. SAYING SO SOMETIMES
LIKE PRIMARILY THE DATA IS.
DEMOGRAPHIC AND SURVEYS AND
ABOUT THE SERVICE IS BEING
SOUGHT GOT IT AND IN THAT
THERE'S NOT AS MUCH SO I WOULD
SAY- ARE YOU ABLE TO DETERMINE
SORT OF HOW. HOW HOW LONG PEOPLE
HAVE BEEN HOMELESS- SORT OF
CAUSE AND EFFECT WHAT WHAT PUT
THEM OUT THERE DO YOU ARE YOU
SEEING. THE DEMOGRAPHICALLY WHAT
TRENDS ARE YOU SAYING WITHIN
THAT WITHIN THAT DATA SET. HELLO
AND I'LL DISTINGUISH TWO THINGS
SO AT THE LOCAL LEVEL. AND
FUTURE RESTRICTION WILL COLLECT
DATA ABOVE AND BEYOND WHAT IS
TRANSMITTED TO THE STATE- AND SO
WITHOUT ANY JURISDICTION SAN
FRANCISCO FOR EXAMPLE MAIN
COLLECT MOVED FAR MORE ROBUST
AND I'M I'M LIKE I'M SURE THEY-
I WOULD GUESS THEY ARE- THAT WE
DON'T HAVE TRANSMITTED TO US AND
THAT'S- PARTIALLY- SO THAT WE
CAN HAVE A STANDARDIZED SYSTEM
ACROSS THE STATE AS YOU CAN
IMAGINE WHAT LOCAL SPECIFY. LIKE
SORT OF SPECIFIC DATA TO LOCAL
JURISDICTION MY VERY ACROSS THE
FORTY FOR CONTINUANCE OF CARE.
WHAT WE ARE SEEING- IS SORT OF
THAT THE TREND THAT I THINK THIS
IS WELL IT'S SORT OF WELL
DOCUMENTED AND ROUND WELL
RECOGNIZED AROUND. THE RACIAL
DISPARITIES AMONG- THOSE. RACIAL
SUBGROUPS THAT ARE OVER
REPRESENTED COMPARED TO THE
POPULATION AT HOLD ON ON A
WHOLE- THE SWORDS- THE DEMOCRAT
GRAPHIC CHARACTERISTICS OF THOSE
SEEKING SERVICES. AND AT THE
DATA DEMONSTRATED ANYWHERE
WITHIN BAY PROGRESS. AND ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT I THINK IS WHY
WE ARE SO EAGER FOR THE SYSTEM
PERFORMANCE MEASURES AS I THINK
YOU KNOW AT THE DATA PERSON AND
IN FORMALLY I WAS RESEARCHER
SORT OF WHAT HOW DO WE DEFINE
PROGRESS- IS WHAT WE ARE DEALING
WITH NOW WHICH IS AROUND THE
SYSTEM PERFORMANCE MEASURES SO
WE ARE EAGER. TO GET THOSE OUT
WE ARE EAGER TO TEND TO
ESTABLISH THEM AND TO
COMMUNICATE THEM IN A VERY CLEAR
WAY SO PEOPLE UNDERSTAND THEM.
GOT A TOP OFFICER CRITTER THIS
SO WITHOUT THE- DATA. WITHOUT
BROAD AGREEMENT AS TO HOW WE CAN
DETERMINE PROGRESS HOW WOULD YOU
ADVISE US. TO LOOK AT THE
GOVERNOR'S JANUARY HOMELESSNESS
PROPOSAL BECAUSE IT DOESN'T- YOU
KNOW I KNOW HE'S FRUSTRATED I
KNOW THE LEGISLATURE'S
FRUSTRATED THE PUBLIC'S
FRUSTRATED- WE HAVE APPROPRIATE-
BILLIONS I FEEL LIKE CARL SAGAN
WITH APPROPRIATE BILLIONS AND
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS TO THIS
ISSUE. AND IT'S NOT CLEAR WHERE
WE'VE MADE. PROGRESS SO WHAT
ADVICE WOULD YOU GIVE TO US AND
HOW TO EVALUATE THE JANUARY
PROPOSAL BASED ON- LACK OF
BENCHMARKS- BUT A LOT OF.
FRUSTRATION. THE. THURMOND
SECRETARY SO THERE. JEREMY IT'S
WRITTEN OKAY. YOU'RE YOU'RE
STILL ON MUTE SECRETARY. OKAY
THERE WE GO I APOLOGIZE NOT AT
ALL AND- YES THAT SOON ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WHEN I WOULD SAY IS THE
FOLLOWING SO H. C. A. S. OF
LET'S SAY THE REGRESSION SYSTEM
IS A VERY IMPORTANT TOOL IN
TERMS OF GATHERING INFORMATION
ABOUT WHAT IS HAPPENING ACROSS
THE STATE. WE KNOW THAT WE HAVE
OVER A HUNDRED AND SIXTY
THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS WE
ALSO KNOW THAT WE HAVE NEARLY
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
PEOPLE THAT HAVE BEEN SERVED BY
THESE CONTINUE IT'S ACROSS THE
BOARD AND- WE ARE AWARE OF THE
TYPES OF SERVICES THAT THEY'RE
ACCESSING AND SO THAT HELPED US.
OF BATTERY AND- THE BILL
INFORMED OF THE- OF NOT JUST
INVEST IN HOUSE BUT ALSO CAN. TO
INVEST IN HUMAN SERVICES AND
HEALTH SERVICES THIS IS WHY-
THIS IS. A CRITICAL PILLAR OF
THE GOVERNOR'S HOMELESSNESS
BUDGET TWO BILLION DOLLARS TO
FURTHER HOUSING HUMAN SERVICES
AND HEALTH. OF THE TWO BILLION
DOLLARS THERE'S FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS THAT HAS BEEN
ALLOCATED FOR EXPRESS TEAM
ENCAMPMENTS RESOLUTION- REALLY
ADDRESSING ENCAMPMENTS- THAT
ARE- UNSAFE- AND NOT DIGNIFIED-
PLACES OF LIVING. OUT THIS YEAR
WE LAUNCHED UP FOR THE FIRST
TIME THE INCUMBENT RESOLUTION
GRANDMOTHER BROWN. LOOK WE'VE
WE'VE ALL READ THE BUDGET
PROPOSAL WE'RE INTIMATELY
FAMILIAR WITH ANYONE FAMILIAR
WITH THE LAST COUPLE YEARS I
GUESS. HOW WOULD YOU. ASK US TO
EVALUATE. THE JANUARY. PROPOSAL
WHICH IS BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE-
WHICH WILL HAVE TO EVALUATE-
WITHOUT UNDERSTAND. WE'RE WE'RE
HAVING SUCCESS WHAT'S WORKING.
AND WHAT'S NOT FOR SURE PERHAPS
WE JUST HOLD THIS. BUDGET ITEM
OVER THE NEXT YEAR TO WE HAVE
MORE DATA. THAT'S AN OPTION TO.
YEAH EIGHT I WOULD SAY- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER AND- I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO EVALUATE HOW WE'RE
DOING AS A STATE IMPLEMENTING
THE FUNDS THAT WERE ALLOCATED IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. HOW ARE WE
GETTING DOLLARS OUT TO BUILD
MORE HOUSING AND THAT INCLUDES A
COMPLETE IN JUST THREE MONTHS
WE'VE AWARDED A THREE HUNDRED
AND TWENTY TWO MILLION DOLLARS
TO PRODUCE FOUR HUNDRED UNITS.
WHEN I WOULD SAY ALSO IS- HOW
ARE YOU DOING AS A STATE AND
SETTING UP THE SYSTEMS OF
ACCOUNTABILITY AND ARE WE MAKING
PROGRESS TOWARDS THAT END I'M
GOOD AT IT I WOULD SAY THAT AND
WE'RE IN THE MIDST F YOU KNOW
CONTINUING TO BUILD A SYSTEM.
AND YOU KNOW THAT THE- YEAR
POINT ASSEMBLY MEMBER THAT I
WOULD MAKE IN TERMS OF HOW THE
EVALUATE THE PROPOSAL. IS- MANY
LOOKING AT WHETHER THAT THE TWO
BILLION DOLLARS THAT IS BETTER
THAN THE BUDGET RIGHT- IF THESE
ARE THE TOP PRIORITIES WE
BELIEVE THAT THESE ARE THE
PRIORITIES- THAT. COMMUNITIES
ARE. ADDRESSING THE GRAPPLING
WITH. IN THAT WILL BE BUILT ON
THE PRIORITIES THAT WE'VE
ESTABLISHED TOGETHER WITH THE
LEGISLATURE IN TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO THROUGH. FOR THE OVERALL-
CALIFORNIA COME BACK THE PLAN.
OKAY- BUT I GUESS. WHAT WOULD BE
HELPFUL IS UNDERSTANDING- WHAT
WHAT WE ANTICIPATE AND I THINK
THAT'S PART OF A DISCUSSED AND I
THINK THAT'S PART OF OUR
DISCUSSION BETWEEN BETWEEN NOW
AND JUNE IS WHAT WE ANTICIPATE
BEING ABLE TO ACCOMPLISH BASED
ON THAT. FUNDING. SO I THINK
THAT'S THE PART THAT'S NOT.
CLEAR. SO ON. I AM NOT I'M GLAD
YOU MENTIONED HOME KILLS LAST
QUESTION ABOUT HOME KEY- I GUESS
BASED ON THE STAFF ANALYSIS IS
SAYS I'M SORRY THIS IS FOR ROOM
KEY- THAT THERE WERE
APPROXIMATELY FOURTEEN THOUSAND.
SEVEN HUNDRED ROOMS WHICH WERE
SECURED BY ROOM K. THAT SOUND
APPROXIMATELY RIGHTS STATEWIDE.
CAN YOU REPEAT THAT NUMBER-
BUSHER I HAVE BEEN IN THE STAFF
ANALYSIS ON PAGE FOUR. IT SAYS
THAT APPROXIMATELY FOURTEEN
THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED ROOMS
WERE SECURED BY ROOM K. THAT
SOUNDS RIGHT. NOT JUST A
PROBABLY RIGHT IN AND- I'LL JUST
LIKE THAT WE WORK WITH BIG
RECEIVER CORRECTION OUR PARTNERS
AT THE IT SAYS IT WAS CLOSER TO
SIXTEEN THOUSAND JUST OVER
SIXTEEN THOUSAND. GOT IT OKAY
I'M SORRY THANK YOU STOP JUST
GIVE ME THE REVISED NUMBER
SIXTEEN THOUSAND. FOR SEVEN- IT
IS SAID THAT THE 73% ARE
OCCUPIED. THAT IS THE PROGRAM IN
AUGUST YEAH THANK YOU- HOW WE
DOING ON OUR DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES ASSEMBLYMEMBERS
YOU NOT MINISTERS THE ROOM GIVE
THE PARLIAMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES AND I THINK I HEARD YOU
SAY THAT WITH THE WAR A CHOIR
BUT I JUST WANTED TO CLARIFY
THAT THE WOULD BE ROOM KEEP
PROGRAM WAS BASED ON- THE- AT
LEAST SAYS- AT. IT WAS WAS
LEASING REFORMS FOR QUICK ACCESS
SUPPORT EXPRESS. GAGA IT AND
THEN FIFTY THANK YOU FOR THINK
IT FOR THE CRAFT CARE. SO- IT
SAID THAT SO 3% OF THOSE ARE
OCCUPIED AND I THINK I THINK
MISS. MISS LOW MENTIONED. SO
AGAIN DSS ADMINISTERS THESE
PROGRAMS BUT WHAT I WHAT THEY
PROVIDED IN TERMS OF INFORMATION
ON THIS A 73% WERE OCCUPIED AT
THE HEIGHT OF THE PROGRAM IN
AUGUST TWENTY TWENTY. OKAY SO
WHERE WHERE WE WITH OCCUPANCY
TODAY. I WOULD SAY A COUPLE
THINGS I WOULD DEFERRED TO RDS
ASK PARTNERS TO PROVIDE SORT OF
AN UPDATE ON WHERE ON WHAT
OCCUPANCY LEVELS ARE. I AM AWARE
THAT THEY YOU KNOW THEY'RE
THEY'RE GOING TO BE BASED ON UP
THAT PROGRAM SO QUICKLY- AND
SORT OF TO YOUR EARLIER POINT
ABOUT WHAT WAS ACHIEVED YOU KNOW
IT WAS. THAT MANY PEOPLE BIG
HOUSE DURING A PANDEMIC AND SO I
THINK YOU KNOW THEY'RE THEY'RE
THEY CONTINUE TO DO WORK ACT AND
I DON'T WANT TO ANSWER ON THE
BEHALF BUT I WILL SAY THAT. I
THINK I'M A THEY WOULD YOU WOULD
DEFINITELY HAVE TO CHECK WITH
THEM ON I THINK THEY WOULD BEST
ADDRESS THAT QUESTION BUT- ALSO.
SECOND MAC I THINK. SORT OF THE
FLUID NATURE OF WHO'S IN AND
WHO'S OUT ON ANY GIVEN DAY IS
YOU KNOW IT IS JUST ONE OF THE
COMPLEXITY OF ALMOST ONE OF THE
COMPLEXITIES OF THE START OF THE
STATE OF THE FLUID NATURE OF
HOMELESSNESS. ON ANY GIVEN DAY.
NO NO UNDERSTOOD THAT BUT BUT
AGAIN IT SEEMS- YOU KNOW WE HAVE
WE HAVE UNITS WE HAVE PEOPLE WHO
WANT TO BE IN UNITS AND WE'RE
JUST TRYING TO MAKE SURE THAT.
I'M JUST TRYING UNDERSTAND WHY
THERE'S EMPTY UNITS. IT IS
SOMETHING THAT SOUNDS LIKE
YOU'RE NOT ABLE TO ANSWER AND
ANSWER THE QUESTIONS WILL HAVE
TO ADDRESS AT. A DIFFERENT
HEARING. THAT WAS OUR FIRST SIR
. YEAH. ARMED. THERE WAS.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AYE AYE. WHEN I
MAKE SURE YEAH YOU'RE NOT
REFERRING TO THE HOME KEEP
PROGRAM YOU YOU STARTED TALKING
ABOUT POSITION OF UNITS WELL I
WAS GOING TO GET THE HOME KEY I
JUST STARTED WITH ROOM HERE BUT
I'M HAPPY TO DO. OF UP. HI
FORGET LIKE WITH- I GUESS WITH
HOME KIT AND YOU COULD MAYBE YOU
COULD TALK ABOUT DIRECTOR JUST
YOU KNOW WHAT YOUR- WHAT YOU'RE
VACANCY RATE IS I DID HAVE A
QUESTION WHICH I HOPE I HEARD
YOU CORRECTLY THAT WITH THE- NO
PLACE LIKE HOME. WITH THE ONE
POINT THREE BILLION DOLLAR
ALLOCATION IT WAS ABOUT THIRTEEN
THOUSAND UNITS. RIGHT AND IS
THAT WITH WITH THAT ONE POINT
THREE BILLION SPENT ONLY ON THE
UNITS OR WAS IT ALSO A SPENT ON
SERVICES OF ALL. THAT INCLUDES
AT ABOUT NOT IS THE MEASUREMENT
OF UNITS THAT WILL BE CREATED BY
THIS PROGRAM BUT AS YOU KNOW.
THE NO PLACE LIKE HOME- HAS A
VERY ROBUST- OPTION FOR
CAPITALIZE OPERATING RESERVES-
UP TO TWENTY YEARS FOR THESE
UNITS TO BE- PROPERLY YOU KNOW
SERVED A YOU KNOW THESE THESE
ARE UNITS THAT SERVE. PERSONS
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS THAT
HAD EXPERIENCE HOMELESS
HOMELESSNESS IT WITH MENTAL
ILLNESS SO THE INTENSE NATURE OF
THE SERVICES AVAILABLE FOR THESE
RESIDENTS- HE'S IS VERY STRONG
SO WE IT IT IS THE- IT IS ONE
POINT THREE BILLION DOLLARS
THAT. INCLUDES AB BOTH UNITS IN
OPERATIONS OF. PERFECT FOR A
QUICK FOR THAT BECAUSE I THINK
THAT MAKES THAT NUMBER MAKES
SENSE IF IT'S CONSTRUCTION AS
WELL AS YOU'RE SAYING THE PART
THAT MONEY SET ASIDE IN RESERVE.
LONG TERM FOR THOSE SERVICES FOR
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING. THAT'S
CORRECT OKAY GREAT I WELCOME
YEAH- CHAPEL SHE WANTS TO BE
JUST- ADD ANYTHING TO THAT.
MODEL OF PERMITS SUPPORT HOUSING
WERE YOU HAVING WHAT WOULD BE
CALLED CAPITALIZE OPERATING
SUBSIDIES- YOU AWARD THAT TIME
OF THE WAR IN STRONG DOWN OVER
TIME SO THAT DOES HELP SUBSIDIZE
NOT ONLY OPERATIONS OF THE
PROPERTY WHICH HELPS KEEP THE
RUN FLOW AS WELL AS SOME OF THE
SERVICES. NO PLACE LIKE HOME IS
QUITE UNIQUE AS WELL BECAUSE THE
COUNTIES ARE GREEN AFTER TWENTY
YEARS OF PER THE STATUTE TO
PROVIDE AUGMENTS SERVICES MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES ON TOP OR IN
CONJUNCTION WITH THAT. SO IT'S
UNIQUE IN THAT WAY- OKAY
ABSOLUTELY. NO PRESSURE THANK
YOU AND FOR ONE FINAL NUMBER WE
GOT. COMING FROM PANEL. I'M JUST
GOING BACK TO KEY. I SEE SAYS
THAT HOME HE'S PRODUCED ABOUT-
ABOUT FIFTY NINE HUNDRED.
UNISOURCE ROUGHLY SO- FOCUSED ON
THAT THAT'S THE OLD NUMBER I
THINK I. KNOW THAT'S A NEW
NUMBER- WELL WITH. DIFFERENT
IMAGES CLARIFIED THAT DIFFERS
INTEGRATION OF FLUNKY HEY
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS- PROFUSE
A LITTLE OVER SIX THOUSAND
UNITS- AND WE ARE IN THE
IMPLEMENTED THE SECOND ITERATION
OF CLUNKY ONE POINT FOUR BILLION
DOLLARS WITH JUSTICE STARTED
MAKING AWARDS. A COUPLE MONTHS
AGO AND THAT HAS ADDED AN
ADDITIONAL TWELVE HUNDRED UNITS
FOR A TOTAL OF A- YOU KNOW OVER
SEVEN THOUSAND UNITS THE- ONES
HOME KEY. IS AB. HELPED
COMPLETELY DEPLOYED FOR HOME Q.
ONE POINT ONE KEEP TO PLAN A WE
ESTIMATE. OPGEN CLOSE TO
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN THOUSAND
UNITS IN TOTAL AND I THINK
THAT'S GREAT I THINK IT'S
WONDERFUL THAT BOTH THESE
PROGRAMS ROOM KEY AND HOME KEY.
FOR TOTAL UP UNDER PANDEMIC WITH
FEDERAL SMALL RESOURCES IT'S A
IT'S- AMAZING FEAT- MY QUESTION
WHICH IS GOING BACK TO THE
VACANCY WAS THE PROXIMATE
VACANCY FOR THOSE. UNITS
SEPARATE FROM THE TWELVE
THOUSAND A YEAR ON. BOARDING SO
THAT AND I'M NOT. I DON'T STILL
THE PRICE OF BURKE AT THE ONLINE
- MITCHELL TWENTY ONE HUNDRED
AND- VETERANS REQUIREMENT HOPE
YOU THAT ALL PROPERTIES AFTER
WORD OF OCCUPIED AFTER NINETY
DAYS TO WORK FULLY OCCUPIED OF
COURSE IS ALWAYS VERY ABILITY
AND PROPERTIES- BEGINNING GIVEN
DAY SO I WANNA MAKE THAT
DISTINCTION BETWEEN ROOM CAN
HELP YOU GROUP HE WAS A
TEMPORARY PROGRAM WE DID NOT
ADMINISTER THAT YEAH THAT WASN'T
A POINT IN TIME AS A PUBLIC
HEALTH RESPONSE THEY WERE NOT
EVER. SO MAKING THREE MIGHT BE
LEGITIMATE BUT THEY WERE NOT
PERMANENT UNITS THAT WE'RE GOING
TO KEEP IN THE PORTFOLIO. I IT'S
SO. HAPPENS THEY JUST DID T BE
CLEAR WERE PROVOKING AND IN OCT
REQUIRE AFTER NINETY DAYS SO ON
THAT FIRST ITERATION OF HUNKY.
YOU CONSIDER US FULLY OCCUPIED
RIGHT IN THE SENSE OF. IT ALWAYS
COULD BE CENTER OVER HERE AND
THEY'RE JUST LIKE WITHIN THE
APARTMENT COMPLEX. THE ONLY
DISTINCTION I WOULD ASK YOU SOME
OF THE USES WITHIN HOME HE-
ILLEGIBLE INTERIM. AND PERMANENT
UNITS IS ACTUALLY WHAT THAT
BREAKDOWN WAS IF THAT'S HELPFUL
AND THERE ALSO ARE NUMBER OF
UNITS THAT ARE IN A ROOM AT
FIRST AND THEN WILL BE
CONVERTING TO PERMIT OVER TIME
DEPENDING UPON THE COMMUNITY-
THE CONDITIONS IRATE SO THEY MAY
HAVE. YOUR TAKE FOR EXAMPLE YOU
MAY HAVE A COUPLE OF
ACQUISITIONS AND THE RUNNING
SOME OF THAT WAS GETTING THROWN.
AND THEN AS THEY GET OTHER UNIS
ONLINE WILL MOVE THOSE FOLKS IN
THE CURRENT HOUSING MANY REHAB
THAT AND AROUND. TRYING NOT TO
PERMIT THAT SORT OF THING SO YOU
SEE A COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH AT
A LOCAL. LEVEL AND THE ABILITY
TO HAVE THAT FLEXIBILITY AT TOP
RUNNING EITHER INTERIM. INTERIM
TO PERMANENT OR PERMANENT
HOUSING SO YOU STOP PRETTY- A
LOT OF A LOT OF VARIETY IN TERMS
OF LOOKING HE'S PURSUED. AND
PRESERVATION AND CONTINUE TO
PURSUE. OTHER INTERESTS
ACCORDING HOUSING GOT. AN IDEA
AND I THINK THAT THAT'S GREAT TO
HEAR THEIR FULLY OCCUPIED AND
NOT LOOK AT FULL OCCUPANCY LIKE
BETWEEN. LIKE. 9295% THERE'S
ALWAYS SOME. ON ANY GIVEN DAY.
MOVE BY PER. THAT THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR YOUR- THANK YOU
FOR YOUR- PERCENT. THANK YOU
MUCH HAD PANEL NUMBER THREE
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE FORWARD WITH
PANEL NUMBER FOUR. I KNOW THE
SOME FOLKS MAY HAVE HAD TO DROP
OFF AND- JUST FOR- TIME LIKE
TIME WISE WE ARE ALSO A STILL
EXPECTING PUBLIC COMMENT. SO
WE'RE GONNA IT LET'S MOVE
FORWARD WITH THE PENDULUM BEFORE
IT WILL START WITH THAT MINUTES
HEIDI MARSTON. WITH THEM B. LOS
ANGELES HOMELESSNESS- SERVICES
AUTHORITY LHASA. THIS MARCIN YOU
THERE. YES I'M HERE CAN YOU HEAR
ME YES PLEASE BEGIN. WONDERFUL
THANK YOU THANK YOU COMMITTEE
MEMBERS CHECK CREATE YOUR WAX-
IN THE COMMITTEE FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH YOU
TODAY AS WAS MENTIONED I'M HEIDI
MAHER SAID I AM THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE LOS ANGELES
HOMELESS SERVICES AUTHORITY OR
LHASA. WE ARE THE LEADING ENTITY
FOR HOMELESSNESS AND ACROSS L.
A. COUNTY ANALLY CITY AS WELL AS
THE CONTINUUM OF CARE. I KNOW
WE'RE HOLDING THIS HEARING TODAY
TWO YEARS INTO A GLOBAL PANDEMIC
THAT HAS REALLY TESTED ARE
HOMELESS RESPONSE SYSTEM. AND
LEFT MANY HOUSEHOLDS MORE
VULNERABLE THAN WE'VE EVER SEEN
INTERRUPTING THE ECONOMY LEAVING
PEOPLE SICK- THE CARE FOR THEIR
LOVED ONES WITH A LOT OF
INTERVENTIONS BEING NEEDED BUT-
THANKFULLY WITH THE SUPPORT AND
RESPONSIVENESS FROM THE STATE
OUR WHOLE SERVICES SYSTEMS HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO RESPOND AND-
INNOVATE. AND REALLY TO FIND NEW
WAYS TO SERVE OUR MOST
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS WHICH I
KNOW HAS BEEN A TOPIC OF
CONVERSATION HERE TODAY- BUT
BEFORE I TALK ABOUT THAT I DO
WANT TO TAKE A QUICK STEP BACK
AND SHARE SOME OF THE FACTORS
THAT. THREATEN OUR HOMELESSNESS
CRISIS FOR YEARS NAMELY THE LACK
OF HOUSING AND AFFORDABLE
HOUSING FOR VULNERABLE
NEIGHBORS. I BE AN ADEQUATE
PROTECTIONS FOR VULNERABLE
TENANTS. COURSE INSUFFICIENT
INCOMES AND THE STRUCTURAL
RACISM THAT CONTINUES TO
PERMEATE ALL OF OUR SYSTEMS.
THOSE FACTORS CERTAINLY PROCESS
AND WE REALLY CAN'T TALK ABOUT
HOMELESSNESS- WITHOUT TALKING
ABOUT THOSE ELEMENTS. I JUST
SUPPORT SOME NUMBERS TO IT FOR
EVERY. ONE HUNDRED. LOW INCOME
RENTER HOUSEHOLDS IN JUST IN
CALIFORNIA. THERE ARE ONLY
TWENTY FOUR AVAILABLE APARTMENTS
OUT FOR THOSE HOUSEHOLDS THAT
THEY CAN AFFORD SO THIS IS AGAIN
LIKE A REALLY BAD GAME OF
MUSICAL CHAIRS- THAT NOBODY
SHOULD HAVE TO PLAY IT LEAVES
OUR MOST VULNERABLE WITHOUT MANY
OPTIONS. AS WELL AS LONG AS THAT
IMBALANCE PROCESS WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE TO CONTINUE TO SEE WHAT WE
SEE IN PLACES LIKE LA WHERE
PEOPLE BECOME HOMELESS AND FALL
INTO HOMELESSNESS FASTER THAN WE
CAN HOUSE THEM. IN LOS ANGELES-
BASED ON OUR TWENTY TWENTY
INFORMATION TWO HUNDRED AND FIVE
PEOPLE EXITING HOMELESSNESS
EVERY SINGLE DAY. AND TWO
HUNDRED AND TWENTY FIVE PEOPLE
FELL INTO HOMELESSNESS EVERY
SINGLE DAY SO WE HAVE TO FIX
THAT IMBALANCE AND TURN OFF THE. FAUCET OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
FALLING AND- BUT DESPITE ALL THE
REALITY ARE HOMELESS SERVICES IS
DOWN OUR OUTREACH TEAMS OUR
COMMUNITY PROVIDERS. HAVE BEEN
ENORMOUSLY RESILIENT DURING THE
CAN'T THAT MAC. AND WITH SUPPORT
FROM THE STATE LOSS SAID THE
CITY OF L. A. COUNTY FLA AND OUR
COMMUNITY REALLY CAME TOGETHER
TO SET A COLLECTIVE TARGET ON
HOW DO WE GET AS MANY PEOPLE
INSIDE IF POSSIBLE WHEN THE
COVERED NINETEEN PANDEMIC CAT.
AND IN A MATTER OF WEEKS OUR
COLLECTIVE EFFORTS ALL COMING
TOGETHER BROUGHT OVER THIRTY
HOTELS AND MOTELS ONLINE YOUR
PROJECT BRING KEY. AT ITS PEAK
THERE WERE THIRTY SEVEN PRIVATE
ROOM KEY SITES ACROSS THE LEE
COUNTY REPRESENTING MORE THAN
THIRTY SIX HUNDRED HOTEL ROOMS.
AND THAT'S MORE THAN. ANY OTHER
REGION IN THE COUNTRY. OKAY
LEARNED A LOT FROM THE ROOM HE
MÀ- MOST IMPORTANTLY IT'S THAT
WHEN WE ALL COME TOGETHER FROM
ALL LEVELS OF GOVERNMENT
GOVERNMENT AND PARTNERS. WE CAN
MOVE FASTER THAN WE EVER THOUGHT
WE COULD- WE RAN FOR IT ALSO
REPORTS THAT WE NEED TO BUILD UP
THE WAYS THAT WE'RE THINKING
ABOUT SHELTER- VIETNAM
CONGREGATE SPACES WHERE PEOPLE
HAVE THEIR OWN ROOM THEY HAVE A
DOOR THAT LOCKS THE BATHROOM. AT
THAT DIGNITY AND PRIVACY HAS
DEMONSTRATED AT LONG TERM
OUTCOMES THAT ARE MUCH BETTER
THAN WHAT WE SEE AND THE REST OF
OUR PORTFOLIO. PEOPLE STAY
LONGER AND THEY'RE MORE LIKELY
TO MOVE INTO PERMANENT HOUSING-
BUT ALSO NOT SURPRISINGLY PEOPLE
WHO ARE MORE LIKELY TO ACCEPT
THE SHELTER- BECAUSE A LOT OF
TIMES FOLKS HAVE RESERVATIONS OR
CONCERNS. ABOUT GOING TO
CONGREGATE SETTINGS. SO DOING
THAT OUT SINCE THE BEGINNING A
PROJECT ROOM HE OVER TEN
THOUSAND PEOPLE HAVE BEEN SERVED
AT IN THOSE SITES JUST IN L. A.
COUNTY. AND THE REAL SUCCESS TO
ME IN FACT ARE OVER THREE
THOUSAND OF THOSE PEOPLE HAVE
MOVED FROM THE PROJECT BRING
KEYSIGHT INTO PERMANENT HOUSING.
AND LESS THAN 10% OF THEM ARE
RETURNING TO THE STREET THESE
NUMBERS REALLY FLOW AWAY WHAT WE
SEE ACROSS THE REST OF THE
SYSTEM- I'M REALLY CRITICAL
COMPONENTS THAT IS THE HAVE.
FUNDING FROM THE STATE EXPANDED
AND SPECIAL INGREDIENT MAKING
THIS WORK- WE HAVE YOU'D HAVE TO
SUPPORT OUR HOMELESS PREVENTION
PROGRAMS INCLUDING OUR PROBLEM
SOLVING PROGRAM WHICH PROVIDES
COUNSELING AND FLEXIBLE
ASSISTANCE TO PEOPLE IN CRISIS.
WHO ARE NOT YET HOMELESS- ARE
NOT YET FALL INTO HOMELESSNESS.
BUT WE DO RECOGNIZE THAT FOR
MANY PEOPLE WE COULD HAVE
PREVENTED THEIR HOMELESSNESS
WITH SOME SORT OF WELL TIME
FLEXIBLE INTERVENTION UP FRONT
AND THAT'S WHAT OUR PROBLEM
SOLVING IS REALLY DEMONSTRATING
. AND THEN FOR THE PEOPLE WHO DO
FALL INTO HOMELESSNESS WE ALSO
USE HAVE TO FUND INTERIM HOUSING
INTERVENTIONS THAT BRING PEOPLE
INSIDE FROM THE ELEMENTS. I'M
CREATING A SAFE SPACE WHERE THEY
CAN WORK WITH THE CASE MANAGER
TO START PLANNING FOR
TRANSITIONING INTO HOUSING. WE
ALSO USE HALF FOR A RENTAL
SUBSIDIES- AND AGAIN WE'VE BEEN
ABLE TO DO ALL THIS BECAUSE OF
THE FLEXIBILITY THAT HAPPENS
AFFORDED TO US- AND GIVING US A
RANGE OF INTERVENTIONS TO
ADDRESS HOMELESS THAT'S BECAUSE
YOU ALL HAVE BEEN DISCUSSING
TODAY IT'S REALLY NOT ONE SIZE
FITS ALL. LOOKING FORWARD WE DO
NEED TO DO MORE AND AS THESE
COMMITTEES WORK TOWARDS CRAFTING
A BUDGET FOR TWENTY TO TWENTY
THREE AND BUILDING ON A STARK
INVESTMENT IN LAST YEAR'S BUDGET
THERE ARE COUPLE OF CORE
PRINCIPLES THE BEATING COURAGE
YOU ALSO KEEP AT THE FRONT OF
THE CONVERSATIONS. THE FIRST IS
THE NEED FOR ONGOING FUNDING.
FOR THE BILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT IN THAT THE STUDY CAP
BOTH IN THE CURRENT BUDGET YEAR
AND NEXT YEAR IS SO VITAL IN
ENSURING WE HAVE THE RESOURCES
WE NEED TO MOVE PEOPLE OFF THE
STREET- AND HELP. CREATE THAT
LONG TERM PLANNING THAT NEEDS TO
HAPPEN AROUND STOPPING UP CASE
MANAGEMENT SHELTER BEDS. THE
CONSISTENCY IS REALLY KEY AND WE
NEED THE LEGISLATURE TO PROVIDE
AT TO PRIORITIZE MAKING THE
FUNDING PERMANENT SO WE CAN
ENSURE OUR SERVICE PROVIDERS ARE
NOT PROFIT. I HAVE THAT ABILITY
AND STABILITY SO THEY CAN SCALE
UP THEIR ORGANIZATIONS. AT THE
STATE ALSO BEGAN EXACTING
FLEXIBLE DOLLARS FOR LOCAL
PROVIDERS IN THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN BUDGET YEAR- BUT HAS
CHANGED THE PROGRAM SINCE THEN-
BUT THAT WAS A PROMISING PROGRAM
SO JUST PUTTING IT IN ANOTHER
CONTACT. WE WOULD NEVER EXPECT
THE FACT IT PICKS ASK FOR MARK
EIGHT THROUGH TWELVE SCHOOLS IF
THEY HAD TO GO TO SACRAMENTO
EACH YEAR TO MAKE SURE THEY HAVE
THE NEEDED FUNDING TO CONTINUE
THEIR SCHOOLING PROGRAMS. AND
EXPECTING IT OF THE HOMELESSNESS
RESPONSE SYSTEM DOESN'T MAKE
SENSE- IN THE SAME CONTACTS.
ANOTHER PIECE THAT I WANT TO
EMPHASIZE INCENTIVES POLICIES
AND PROGRAMS DESIGNED THAT
REALLY ENCOURAGED LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO INVEST IN
BALANCE HOMELESS SYSTEMS. HERE
AT LOS THE EVERY YEAR WE CAN
DOCTOR WE CALL A SYSTEM ANALYSIS
AND IT DETERMINES WHERE ARE THE
GREATEST NEEDS IN OUR SYSTEM
RELATIVE TO THE POPULATION THAT
WE HAVE. AND THE ONE THING WE
FIND YEAR OVER YEAR IS THAT THE
IDEAL RATIO FOR OUR SYSTEM IS
THAT WE HAVE FIVE PERMANENT
HOUSING INTERVENTIONS FOR
EVERYONE IN A ROOM HOUSING BAD.
WITHOUT THAT WE FIND PEOPLE
MOVING INTO INTERIM OR TEMPORARY
OPTIONS STAYING THERE FOR A LONG
TIME WITH NO EXIT PATHWAY AND NO
OPTIONS TO GO TO. SO ADDED MORE
WE GET THE FLOW. AND WE CAN
ACTUALLY SERVE MORE PEOPLE IN
THOSE INTERNED HOUSING BAD. BACK
RATIO IT LOOKS A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENT IN EACH COMMUNITY BUT
WE SHOULD CERTAINLY CONTINUE TO
MAKE SURE EVERY COMMUNITY IS
USING A DATA CENTRIC APPROACH.
TO DETERMINE THAT RIGHT RAISE
THE L. AS. THE HOUSING RESOURCES
BECOME AVAILABLE. THERE'S ALSO A
IN BACK THAT WOULD YIELD RESULTS
IT IF THE STATE DOES FUND THEM
AXIAL STATEWIDE. INCLUDES RENTAL
ASSISTANCE WE'VE SEEN THAT
REALLY LARGE INFUSIONS OF RENTAL
ASSISTANCE ALLOW US TO MOVE
PEOPLE QUICKLY OFF THE STREET
AND OUT OF SHELTERS AND INTO
EXISTING HEALTH HOUSING. WITHOUT
HAVING WAITING HAVING TO WAIT
FOR MONTHS FOR HOUSING TO COME
ONLINE. WE ALSO KNOW THERE'S
FIERCE COMPETITION IN THE
HOUSING MARKET FOR WHAT UNITS
THERE ARE. SO WE WILL GET
RECOMMENDED STATE INVESTMENT
HOUSING NAVIGATION TO ENSURE
THEIR SUFFICIENT CASE MANAGEMENT
AND SERVICES STAFFING AND
CAPACITY TO ACTUALLY SUPPORT THE
PEOPLE WHO HAVE THOSE RENTAL
SUBSIDIES ENHANCE BUT NEED HELP
FINDING AN APARTMENT AND GOING
THROUGH THAT PROCESS. WE ALSO
RECOMMEND THE STATE TO CONTINUE
INVESTMENT IN HOUSING UNIT
ACQUISITION STRATEGIES SO THIS
LOOKS LIKE CONTINUING TO DOUBLE
DOWN ON STRATEGIES LIKE PROJECT
FROM KEY. BUT ALSO MASTER
LEASING THAT ALLOWS LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO USE MULTIPLE
HOUSING UNITS IN THE BUILDING
WHERE WE CAN RENT OUT ENTIRE
BUILDING- OR YOU KNOW TEN
FIFTEEN TWENTY UNITS IN THE
BUILDING THAT IS LINKED TO A
SUBSIDY SO IT'S GUARANTEED
STOCK. FOR US TWO YEARS- FOR
UNCLES NEIGHBORS. AND FINALLY
AND OF CRITICAL IMPORTANCE WE
REALLY NEED THE STATE'S
ASSISTANCE TO HELP SOLVE THE
WORK FORCE PRICES IN OUR SYSTEM.
AT THE HOMELESS RESPONSE HAS
SCALED UP AROUND THE STATE WE
ARE ULTIMATELY CONSTRAINED BY A
LACK OF CONSISTENT STAFFING
PARTICULARLY IN OUR NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION. TOO MANY OF OUR
COMMUNITY BASED PROVIDERS TOLD
US THAT IF IT'S IMPOSSIBLE TO
KEEP THEIR PROGRAMS FULLY
STAFFED THEY ARE ALWAYS DEALING
WITH AGENCIES AND TURNOVER. BUT
THERE AREN'T ENOUGH PEOPLE IN
THE HOMELESS SERVICES WORK FORCE
AND WHAT PEOPLE ARE IN THE
SYSTEM ARE OFTEN UNDERPAID
THEY'RE OVERWORKED AND THERE
HAVE BEEN CHILLY ASK TO BE
EXPOSED TO OTHER PEOPLE'S
TRAUMA. AND YOU REALLY GET A LOT
OF BACK PASSION FATIGUE AND
POTENTIALLY RE TRAUMATIZING
STAFF WHO HAVE LIVED EXPERTISE
IT'S REALLY REALLY HARD WORK-
AND WE NEED A TALENTED WORK
FORCE AND THAT'S MOTIVATED TO DO
BASS ADAM AND THAT COMES WITH
PAYING THEM WELL AND GIVING THEM
THE SUPPORT AND AFFECTING RATIOS
THEY NEED- PART OF THE FUNDS
THAT COULD BE SOLVED BY.
IMMEDIATELY PROVIDING HIGHER
ADMINISTRATOR FRANK- FOR OUR
PROVIDERS THAT THEY HAVE THAT
FLEXIBILITY TO PAY MORE
COMPETITIVE RATES AND WE CAN
KEEP THE STOCK WE HAVE- AND BILL
THAT BETTER RECRUITING AND
CAPACITY BUILDING- ACROSS OUR
SYSTEM. SO AGAIN I DO WANT TO
CHAIR RIO HERE WHERE A LOT WITH
THE MAN OF THE COMMITTEE WE ARE
SO. FOR THE IMPACT AND THE
ATTENTION YOU'RE GIVING TO THIS
ISSUE AND ARE REALLY EAGER TO
WORK TOGETHER TO MAKE THE RIGHT
INVESTMENTS MOVE THEY NEED ALL.
AROUND HOMELESS OUT HERE IN LOS
ANGELES. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISS MARCH THEN WE'RE GONNA MOVE
FORWARD WITH THE- MISS EMMELINE
HELGHAN DIRECTOR OF HOMELESS
INITIATIVES FOR THE COUNTY OF
SACRAMENTO. AND AGAIN I'LL JUST
ADD IF WE CAN- TRY TO GET
THROUGH THE PANEL- AS WE ALSO
STILL HAVE A PUBLIC COMMENT AND
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS. CAN YOU
HEAR ME. YES OKAY GREAT SORRY I
HAVEN'T SENT THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR HAVING ME AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE TIME AND
ATTENTION THE PANELISTS PROVIDED
THIS REALLY IMPORTANT ISSUE AND
A LOT OF WHAT HIGH HE SAID WAS
IN THE POINTS I'M GONNA BRING UP
SO WILL NOT BE DUPLICATIVE I'M
AND- I SAID MY NAME IS EMILY HOW
CAN I AM THE DIRECTOR OF
HOMELESS INITIATIVES FOR
SACRAMENTO COUNTY. AS I WANT TO
SAY A COUPLE OF THINGS THAT ARE
UNIQUE FROM ACCOUNTING
PERSPECTIVE AND THEN LIFT UP
SOME OF THE PLACES WHERE WE
THINK THAT THAT STATE'S VOICE
AND STATES INVESTMENT IS REALLY
IMPORTANT- AS A COUNTY WE OFTEN
WEAR TWO HATS IN ADDRESSING
HOMELESSNESS FIRST WE ARE
PROVIDING CRITICAL COUNTY WHITE
SERVICES TO FOLKS IN NEED BOTH
THOSE WHO ARE HOMELESS AND THOSE
WHO ARE ON THE PRECIPICE OF
HOMELESSNESS. IS THEIR SAFETY
NET SERVICES BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
HAS BEEN MENTIONED QUITE A BIT
TODAY ALCOHOL AND SUBSTANCE
ABUSE TREATMENT- SAFETY NET
BENEFIT PROGRAMS AND IT'S
CRITICAL THAT WE MAKE THOSE
CONNECTIONS FOR FOLKS ARE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS WHERE
THEY ARE ASKED TO INTEGRATE
THOSE TYPES OF SERVICES INTO
SHELTERS OUTREACH PROGRAMS AND
HOUSING IS ONE OF OUR KEY GOALS
AND THAT IN THE COMING YEARS
WE'VE DONE A GOOD JOB WITH THE
STATE HELP AND SUPPORT. IN A LOT
OF HOUSING PROGRAMS AND I KNOW I
HEARD A LOT OF CONVERSATION NO
PLACE LIKE HOME IN THE HOME KEEP
PROGRAMS DOESN'T REALLY GREAT
EXAMPLES OFHOW WHEN YOU OVERLAY
HE'S CRITICAL SERVICES- WHERE
PEOPLE ARE AT AND THE HOUSING
THE SUCCESS IS SO MUCH BETTER WE
NEED TO THAT SAME EFFORT AT THE
CRISIS MOMENT WITH OUTREACH
PROGRAMS AND SHELTERS I TALK A
LITTLE BIT OUT FROM THE THINGS
WE'RE TRYING TO DO TO DO THAT.
BUT THE SECOND HALF THE COUNTIES
WHERE ESPECIALLY COUNTIES LIKE
SACRAMENTO WHEN I KNOW THERE'S
OTHERS THROUGHOUT THE STATE-
WE'RE WE ALSO PLAY
JURISDICTIONAL ROLE IN
SACRAMENTO COUNTY THE SECOND
LARGEST POPULATION OF
UNSHELTERED HOMELESSNESS OUTSIDE
OF THE CITY OF SACRAMENTO OUR
RESIDENTS OF THE UNINCORPORATED
COUNTY OR RESIDENTS OF OUR
PARKWAY SYSTEM SO THESE ARE ARE
ARE CONSTITUENTS WHOSE
JURISDICTIONAL RESPONSIBILITIES
LIE ON THE COUNTY SO THIS
INCLUDES STREET MANAGEMENT. LAW
ENFORCEMENT CRISIS RESPONSE AND
OFTENTIMES WE ARE THE. FIRST
OUTREACH ENGAGEMENT- AND- AS YOU
MIGHT FIND IN A CITY. I SO FOR
US ABOUT. THOSE ROLES REALLY AND
- MAKE SURE THAT EVERYBODY IN
OUR COUNTY WHETHER THEY'RE IN
WITH WITHIN ONE OF OUR CITIES
ARE WITHIN THE COUNTY AT LARGE.
HAS ACCESS THESE SERVICES
IMPORTANT- AS WITH EVERYBODY IN
THE STATE WE ARE SEEING A RISE
IN UNSHELTERED HOMELESSNESS IN
THE VISIBILITY. EXACERBATED BY
CALLED IT AND I THINK SOME OF
THE THINGS THAT HEIDI LIFT UP
ABOUT- THE EXPERIENCE OF PROJECT
ROOM KEY ECHO CERTAINLY WITH US-
WE SERVED OVER THAT SINCE. SINCE
THE START FOR ABOUT NAY JANUARY
WE'VE SERVED OVER TWO THOUSAND
HOUSEHOLDS THAT ARE PROJECT
GREEN KEY PROGRAMME. AND EXIT
FOUR HUNDRED OVER FOUR HUNDRED
TO PERMANENT HOUSING IN ANOTHER
THREE HUNDRED AND SIXTY. TWO A
TEMPORARY HOUSING- WE STILL
HAVE- THREE HUNDRED OR FOUR
HUNDRED PEOPLE AND TODAY. AND
ARE WORKING ON RAMPING DOWN IT
HAS BEEN A CHALLENGE I HEARD
SOME QUESTIONS BUT OCCUPANCY. AT
THE PANDEMIC HAS WAXED AND WANED
AND WE'VE HAD TO HOLD ROOMS
ASIDE FOR MEDICAL ISOLATION. IT
HAS IT HAS RESULTED IN A FLOW
THAT IS DIFFICULT TO MANAGE. BUT
CERTAINLY THE LESSONS LEARNED
FROM PROJECT BRING KEEP ARE
SIMILAR TO WHAT HIGH THE
ELEVATED. IS OUR ABILITY TO
SERVE FOLKS TO BE PREVIOUSLY-
THAT WERE PREVIOUSLY THOUGHT TO
BE- I'M INTERESTED IN SERVICES
WHEN WHAT WE ARE OFFERING
OFFERING THEM AS A PRIVATE ROOM
WITH DIGNITY WITH SERVICES. WITH
SECURITY- WITH SO MUCH GREATER
AND WE ARE. WORKING NOW TO
TRANSLATE THOSE LESSONS INTO OUR
INTO OUR WORK OVERALL. SO SOME
pDOING- WE DO RUN AND ADMINISTER
SHELTERS THROUGHOUT THE COUNTY
WE HAVE. A HOST OF ABOUT SIX
HUNDRED SHELTER BEDS THAT ARE
WHAT I WOULD CALL YOUR
TRADITIONAL SHELTERS. THAT WE
ARE RUNNING ANNUALLY THEY SERVE
ALL. SORTS OF POPULATIONS I'M-
AND WE ALSO ARE AT THE DRY OF
THE OF THESE HOME PRO. THAT HAS
THAT EACH UNIQUE. TO ABOUT WE
WITH THIS ON A ON A VARIETY OF
THOSE BUT SOME OF THE NEW THINGS
THAT WE'RE TRYING TO LIFT UP.
AND IS HOW WE- HOW WE ENGAGE IN
OUTREACH ON THE STREET- AS I
THINK MANY OF YOU HAVE SAID
BEFORE- FOR A LOT OF FOLKS
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS THE
NEED FOR DEEP SERVICES IS
CRITICAL. AND SO HOW CAN WE
CONNECT THOSE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SUBSTANCE ABUSE TREATMENT
SERVICES. ON THE GROUND FOR
PEOPLE WHO ARE LIVING
UNSHELTERED RIGHT NOW. EARLY IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE WE GET A VERY
SMALL PILOT OF A MULTI
DISCIPLINARY TEAM- THAT
CONSISTED OF COUNTY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH WORKERS. AND COUNTY
SOCIAL WORKERS AND CONTRACTED
HOUSING NAVIGATORS TARGETING
CANCER WE KNEW THAT EITHER THE
CAMP HAD BEEN THERE FOR A LONG
TIME. HAD GROWN LARGE OR THE
POPULATION WAS EXTREMELY
VULNERABLE EVERYTHING FROM
LANGUAGE BARRIERS TO THE EXTREME
MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS. AND WE SAW
A SUCCESS WITH THAT APPROACH-
BREAK LEADING WITH SERVICES THAT
WERE VERY THAT WE HADN'T SEEN
AND INSERT THE- USUAL PRACTICE.
SO WE ARE ELEVATING THAT SCALING
THAT UP AND SOON WILL HAVE THREE
OF THESE TEAMS MULTI
DISCIPLINARY TEAMS WORKING
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTY RESPONDED
TO THE CABINETS. ONE OF THE
THINGS I WANTED TO LIFT UP THAT
WE'RE EXCITED ABOUT IS
SUSTAINING THAT TYPE OF TOUCH
AND INTEGRATING THAT WITH SOME
OF THE WORK AT CALTRAIN WE ARE
REALLY EXCITED AND HELP. THE
OPPORTUNITIES WITH CAROLINE AND
HOW TO LAKE MEDI CAL
REIMBURSEMENT AND FRANKLY HEALTH
PROVIDERS IN GENERAL INTO THESE
OUTREACH EFFORTS SO. LOOKING
FORWARD TO THOSE CONTINUE
CONVERSATIONS WITH DH CS AS WELL
AS OUR PARTNERS IN THE
TRADITIONAL HOUSING SIDE OF THE
STATE. I'M THE SECOND THING WE
AS OTHER COMMUNITIES ARE DOING
IS TRYING TO FIND NEW YOU WITH
NEW AND UNIQUE WAYS TO SHELTER
PEOPLE. AS I SAID HERE KAY WAS A
GREAT- A LESSON LARNED FOR US
ABOUT HOW TO- APPROACH CHILDREN
DIFFERENTLY BUT IT WAS.
EXPENSIVE AND PROBABLY NOT
SUSTAINABLE AT THAT LEVEL AND SO
THEN THE THINGS THAT WE'RE.
LOOKING AT IS STANDING UP WHAT
WE'RE CALLING STATE STAY
COMMUNITY SOME CAN. CALLED SAFE%
GROUNDS ARE SO. ENCAMPMENTS USE
POWER HOMES OTHER TO OF TIME
HOME. TO PROVIDE THAT SENSE OF
SAFETY SECURITY- AND DIGNITY TO
FOLKS WHO HAVE BEEN LIVING
OUTSIDE FOR A LONG TIME. I'M AS
WITH EVERYTHING THOSE TYPES OF
INVESTMENTS- TAKE BOTH AT ONE
TIME CAPITAL BUT IN ONGOING
OPERATING. SO AS WE LOOK TO
STATE FUNDING MOVING FORWARD AND
AS HE SAID ANYTHING- ANYTHING IS
HELPFUL THAT WE KNOW IS
PREDICTABLE. SO I'M GOING ON
CONSISTENT MONEY IS ALWAYS UP TO
PORT. AND THE FINAL THING I WANT
TO SAY BECAUSE I THINK IT'S THAT
IT'S THE MOST IMPORTANT AND WITH
AS WE KNOW THAT THE ONLY. REAL
SOLUTION TO ALL OUR WORK IS
HOUSING AND CERTAINLY-
SUPPORTING THE HARD WORK H. TWO
D. AND OTHERS TO BUILD MORE
HOUSING IS CRITICAL. BUT JUST AS
IMPORTANT WE WANT TO BE ABLE TO-
CREATE MORE ACCESS TO OUR
CLIENTS IN THE OPEN MARKET. AND
ONE OF THE AT IT WE HAD WITH THE
FIRST ROUND OF THE HAP- WE WERE
ABLE TO LAUNCH A VERY SMALL WE
HOUSING PILOT. BUT IT'S VERY
HARD TO SUSTAIN WITH ONE TIME
DOLLARS BECAUSE OFTEN THE RENTAL
NEEDS OF THESE CLIENTS LAST FOR.
FOR MANY YEARS AND CERTAINLY THE
CASE MANAGEMENT NEEDS LAST FOR
MANY MANY YEARS- OUR BOARD JUST
APPROVED A ONE TIME INVESTMENT
AGAIN ONE TIME BUT FROM OUR ARPA
FUNDS WHERE WE'RE GONNA HAVE
THREE YEARS. OF TEN MILLION
DOLLARS. TO SCALE THIS BACK UP
AND HOPEFULLY PROVE THE EFFICACY
BUT AGAIN YOU KNOW ECHOING
FRIDAY A LITTLE BIT THAT WOULD
BE. AN AMAZING INVESTMENT FOR
THE STATE TO MAKE TO HAVE. A
FLEXIBLE PROPELLERS THAT COULD
SUPPORT LOCAL RENTAL- PROGRAMS
THIS IS NOT TRYING TO I'M NOT
TRYING TO CREATE A NEW HOUSING
AUTHORITY OR OR AT AND DUPLICATE
SERVICES BUT WE FIND THAT A LOT
OF OUR REALLY GREAT HOUSING
PROGRAMS WHETHER THEY BE VOUCHER
PROGRAMS. OR THROUGH THE CEO
SEE. ARE PRETTY REGULATED THAT
THEY CAN ONLY PAY UP TO THIS-
AMOUNT OF RENT OR THEY CAN'T PAY
THE DEPOSIT OR THEY CAN'T
PROVIDE THE TENDENCY SUPPORTING
SERVICES. SO WE SEE OUR JOB AS
LOCALITY IS TO PATCH THOSE THOSE
GAPS BUT WE NEED THE. ON GOING
UP I'M GOING FUNDING SINCE IT
PROVIDE THAT- I THINK THERE'S A
MAJOR. I WANT TO UP I WANTED TO
SURE THAT MY COLLEAGUE NICK FROM
CITY HAS AN OPPORTUNITY I AGAIN
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
AND ATTENTION TO THIS EFFORT
AND- THIS. IS A CRITICAL NEED.
AND I APPRECIATE THE STATE
ELEVATING THIS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISS HOW CAN UNFORTUNATELY-
NICK HAD TO JUMP OFF. SO JUST
ONE VERY BRIEF- QUESTION FOR YOU
BOTH AND THEN WE CAN- CLOSE OUT
AND GO TO PUBLIC COMMENT. HOW
ARE YOU BOTH COORDINATING WITH
YOUR LOCAL PARTNERS AND IF YOU
CAN KEEP YOUR ANSWERS BRIEF AND
WE CAN EXPAND AT A LATER TIME
THAT BE GREAT. WELL I GUESS I'M
HAPPY THAT TO GO IN FIRST- THE
CERTAINLY- WE CAN'T DO THIS.
ALONE WE HAVE REGULAR AND- ON
GOING COMMUNICATIONS AND WITH
OTHER CONTINUE MEDICARE AND OUR
CITIES. I KNOW LISA AND NICK
WERE SUPPOSED TO BE AT CO
PRESENTING WITH ME AND YOU WOULD
HAVE I THINK HER LET MORE FROM
THEM. AND WE ARE WORKING
TOGETHER I KNOW SOME OF YOU
REFERENCE THE EDITORIAL THIS
MORNING AND UNFORTUNATELY DIDN'T
CAPTURE ALL THE WORK WE ARE
DOING. I'M TO CREATE A CORD NAY
ACCESS SYSTEM THAT REFLECTS BOTH
THE NEEDS OF THE COMMUNITY. AND
THEIR RESOURCES AND WE HAVE A
COMMITMENT BOTH A WORKING
COMMITMENT ALSO FUNDING
COMMITMENT TO SH TO PLAN ACROSS-
ACROSS THE JURISDICTIONS. AS
WE'RE APPROACHING HAP THREE AS
WE'RE APPROACHING OUR ARPA
FUNDS. AND WORKING TOGETHER TO
IDENTIFY THE GAPS AND ALSO
FRANKLY FIGURE OUT THE BEST
ROLES WHAT WHAT CAN THE CITY DO
BEST LOOKING TO KIND OF ASK
NICOTINE WITH CARE TO THAT SO.
IT'S AN ONGOING ITERATIVE
CONVERSATION- AND WE OBVIOUSLY
HAVE OUR JURISDICTIONAL HATS WE
WEAR. BUT I THINK ALL OF US ARE
COMMITTED TO TAKING THIS. OFTEN
AND REALLY DIGGING OUR HEELS AND
- MISS MARTIN ARE STILL ON THE
LINE. FROM LOS NO OKAY WELL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
APPRECIATE THAT ANSWER MISS
TALKING IF THERE ARE NO
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS FROM THE
MEMBERS OF THE DYESS- REALLY
APPRECIATE YOU AND THANK YOU FOR
STICKING AROUND FOR A LAST PANEL
AND I'M SURE WE'LL HAVE A LOT OF
FOLLOW UP MOVING FORWARD THANK
YOU SO MUCH WE'RE GONNA GO TO
PUBLIC COMMENT NOW. OPERATOR YOU
MAY BEGIN. THANK YOU DOES ON THE
PHONE. IF YOU'D LIKE TO SHARE
PUBLIC COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AGAIN USING
YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD HMI PRESS
IT ONE. AND ZERO AT THIS TIME.
WE WILL GO FIRST THE LINE OF
THIRTY NINE THIRTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YEAH GOOD AFTERNOON MRS
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION FOR YOUTH AND I JUST
WANT TO THANK THE LEGISLATURE
FOR ALWAYS PRIORITIZING THE
NEEDS OF OUR YOUNG PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS AND
ENSURING THAT THERE ARE DOLLARS
BUT BY PACIFIC WAY FOR PROGRAMS
THAT SUPPORT THEM. AND THAT
INCLUDED THE HUNKY SATISFIED- AT
8% FOR YEARS AND WHAT I'M SEEING
NOW UNFORTUNATELY WITH. THE
PROCESS BEING STRUCTURED AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL IT'S MAKING IT
REALLY CHALLENGING FOR A
PROVIDER TO REALLY BENEFIT FROM
THAT PROGRAM AND I'M HOPING THAT
WE CAN FURTHER ADDRESS SOME OF
THE CHALLENGES THE COMING YEAR
AND WOULD JUST ACCESO. MY
COMMENT BY FROM THE PANEL AND
THAT THERE IS A NEED FOR ONGOING
FUNDING TO SUPPORT OUR YOUTH
PROGRAMS TO BE ABLE TO YOU A
CHOIR INTERM HOUSING
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING WE KNOW
THAT THE OTHER PROVEN MODELS TO
WORK FOR OUR YOUNG PEOPLE. AND
AT THE BACK WITH THE PORT THEM
THOSE THAT ARE IN. ABDUCTOR CARE
AND THOSE THAT ARE NOT AND HAVE
NEVER TOUCHED THEM AND SO WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE WE'RE
DESIGNING SOLUTIONS FOR ALL
STATE THEY DO NOT BECOME. ARE
CHRONICALLY HOMELESS ADULTS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT COLOR
PLAY. LINE. THIRTY THREE. I'M
SORRY MY NAME IS MARCUS ALL THE
AND I'M A SENIOR LEGISLATIVE
ADVOCATE OF HOMELESSNESS AND
HOUSING CALIFORNIA AND I'M ALSO
PART OF THE BRING CALIFORNIA
HOME COLLECTION AS HIGHLIGHTED
THROUGHOUT THE HEARING WE NEED
TO CONNECT ONGOING STATE FUNDING
FOR HOMELESSNESS IN ORDER TO
RESTORE THIRTY PUBLIC RESPONSE
IN THE FIELD BEING BLE AN
EQUITABLE WAY AND WE CAN ALSO
REALLY LEVERAGE THIS HISTORIC
SURPLUS TO MAKE OTHER KEY
INVESTMENT TO GET PEOPLE OFF THE
STREET QUICKLY AND INTO
PERMANENT HOUSING. HOUSING
CALIFORNIA IS SUPPORTING THE
FOLLOWING BUDGET REQUEST BIRTH
FIVE BILLION DOLLARS OVER FIVE
YEARS AND RENTAL ASSISTANCE IT
QUICKLY HELD UP TO FIFTY
THOUSAND PEOPLE WHILE WE WAIT
FOR NEW AFFORDABLE HOUSING TO
COME ONLINE AND THE RENT
CONTINUE TO RISE. SECOND TWO
HUNDRED MILLION AN ONGOING
INVESTMENT IN THE RE ENTRY
HOUSING AND WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAM OUTLINES
EIGHTY EIGHTEEN SIXTEEN SUPPORT
ARE FORMERLY INCARCERATED
NEIGHBORS. A TWO HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS SUPPLEMENT INTO THE HOT
PROGRAM WHICH WAS DISCUSSED A
LOT TODAY THIS TECHNICALLY
EARMARKED FOR THE WORK FORCE
EQUITY AND JOB QUALITY CRISIS
BUT OUR LOCAL HOMELESS RESPONSE
ARE FACING- WE REALLY LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING CLOSELY WITH
EVERYONE AT THE HEARING TO DO
WHAT IT TAKES TO END
HOMELESSNESS. IN CALIFORNIA
THANKS SO MUCH. THANK YOU NEXT
COLOR. LEVINE THIRTY TWO. CAN
OPERATE CULTURE THE MEMBERS
CARLY SHELL BE CALLING ON BEHALF
OF THE OAKLAND MAYOR LIBBY
SCHAAF IT IS ALSO THE CHAIR OF
THE BIG CITY MAYORS COALITION
WANT TO THANK THE LEGISLATURE
AND THE GOVERNOR THE PAST DIRECT
ALLOCATIONS TO HELP CITIES LIKE
OAKLAND ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS
WHICH INCLUDES APPLICATION IN
THE HOME KEY PROGRAM. THE
HOUSING CRISIS CONTINUES TO BE
OAKLAND TOP PRIORITY AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU TO
ALLOCATE A PORTION OF THE BUDGET
SURPLUS FOR HOMELESSNESS
PREVENTION STRATEGIES WHICH
INCLUDES FUNDING FOR DEVELOPING
EXPORT HOUSING AND CAMPAIGN
MANAGEMENT MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES AND THE CONTINUED
FUNDING OF HAPPY. THAT FLEXIBLE
HAVE PRECURSORS FOR HOMELESS A
LOT OF BUZZ ABOUT CLOSE TO THE
GROUND TO FILL THE CRITICAL GAPS
THAT MORE TURKEY DOLLARS DO NOT
WE ALSO SUPPORT EFFORTS TOWARDS
THE CONTROLLED SUBSTANCE FOR AND
HOW HE PREVIOUSLY ON HOW TO
PROTECT. THANK YOU AND LOOKING
FOR CONTINUE COOPER. THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. PINE THIRTY.
GOOD AFTERNOON THAT CHRIS SAY
BUT- CAL PARTNERS AND THE MASTER
VIOLENCE I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
HOLDING THIS HEARING AND
APPRECIATE THE LEGISLATURE FOR
ALL OF THE INVESTMENT OVER
RECENT YEARS IN ADDRESSING
HOMELESSNESS AND I WILL ADD THAT
ONE OF THE MOST CRITICAL NEEDS
WE SEE FOR DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
SURVIVORS IS ACCESS TO- HOUSING
ACROSS THE SPECTRUM FROM
EMERGENCY SHELTER A DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE SHELTERS PERMANENT
HOUSING NEEDS- AND LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH YOU ALL TO
ENSURE THAT THIS YEAR'S BUDGET
AND FUTURE DECISIONS REALLY
INCORPORATES A SUBPOPULATION.
WITHIN THE STRUCTURES AND
DECISIONS MADE AROUND HOME.
MONDAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
COLOR PLEASE. JULY. THIRTY FOUR.
GOOD AFTERNOON SHARE THE MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
SIMONE CORRECTLY AND I WORK FOR
JOHN BURTON BECAUSE YOU WERE A
MEMBER OF THE BRING CALIFORNIA
HOME COALITION AND WE SUPPORT
THE PROPOSALS BEING PUT FORTH BY
THE COALITION. TODAY I'D LIKE TO
FOCUS MY COMMENTS ON YOUTH
JUMPER NOT TO GET FOR YOU THAT
THE PURPORT OF THE STATE'S
CURRENT APPROACH TO ADDRESSING
YOUR PUBLIC MATH BY PACKAGING
SATISFIED IN MAINSTREAM HOME. OF
THE PROGRAM OVER THE LAST FOUR
YEARS. KEEP HALF AND HOME. JERRY
IS ABOUT THREE OR FAN THE IMPACT
OF BETTER. IN KEEPING. REPORT
THE FALMOUTH THE SENATE APPROACH
HAS BEEN A- FOR SEVERAL REASONS
. NO ONE IN INVESTMENT IN YOUR
PUBLICLY. NUMBER TWO IT YOU CAN
TO LOCAL HOME A THREE LOCAL HOME
A THREE. NETWORK NUMBER THREE IT
INCREASED LOCAL UNDERSTANDING
AND AWARENESS OF YOUTH
HOMELESSNESS. NUMBER FOUR
EXPANDED THE CONTINUUM OF
HOUSING OPTIONS FOR YOU. I
NUMBER FIVE LOCAL COMMUNITY
SUPPORT YOU'D BETTER FIVE. THANK
YOU FOR THE TREMENDOUS
INVESTMENT TO DATE AND FOR BEING
A CHAMPION FOR CALIFORNIA
KEEPING AN EXCEL. WE ENCOURAGE
THE LEGISLATURE TO BUILD ON THIS
MOMENTUM AND CONSIDER HOW WE CAN
CONTINUE IMPORTANT INVESTMENT.
MOVING FORWARD AND IDEALLY
MAKING. A PERMANENT INVESTMENT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE
. THANK YOU AT THIS TIME THERE
ARE NO FURTHER COMMENTS IN Q.
OKAY THANK YOU OPERATOR I WANT
TO THANK THE MEMBERS OF THE- THE
MEMBERS THAT ATTENDED TODAY'S A
JOINT. OF JOINT HEARING AND FOR
THE MEMBERS OF THE STATE TO THE
VERY END THAK YOU SO MUCH. WE
ARE NOW ADJOURNING THE JOINT
HEARING ON ASSEMBLY BUDGET SUB
COMMITTEE FORMED AND HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE
THANK YOU SO MUCH.